Hallo, herzlich willkommen, hier ist die Freakshow und zwar die 296. Ausgabe der Freakshow.
Ja, 200 drückt immer noch näher.
Das rollt ja locker von der Zunge und ja, es waren nur zwei Wochen seit der letzten Sendung.
Also jetzt mal vorausgesetzt, ich kriege die auch rechtzeitig veröffentlicht.
Und das ist ein Rekord, finde ich, das ist ein guter Rekord.
kein Roddy heute, der hat weiß ich nicht, jetzt fahr ich wieder zurück aus China,
aber hat sich vielleicht irgendein Virus eingefangen? Ich weiß auch nicht.
Ich bin ja ganz froh, dass er heute nicht hier ist.
Genau, er hat sich dann doch entschuldigen lassen, aber Ralf ist natürlich da. Hallo Ralf.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Genau, und dann, große Überraschung, endlich wieder da, Huckel.
Hallo, Huckel, herzlich willkommen in der Freakshow.
Guten Tag.
Guten Abend.
Hallo an die Geräte und Zuhörerinnen zu Hause, an den Podcast-Hörapparaten, Hörgeräten.
Ja, ich hoffe die Ankündigung, dass heute Stargast anwesend enttäuscht hat und
nicht ein Großteil der Hörerschaft, das hat sich Tim ausgedacht.
Ja, naja, also ich meine, es gab ja Nachfragen, von daher passt das ja alles
ganz gut. Ich habe jetzt auch mal geguckt, letzte Sendung, wo du dabei warst.
Weißt du das noch auswendig?
Nö, aber es ist bestimmt mehr als drei Jahre her.
Ja, genau, vier Jahre her, 25. Juni 2021. Bei dir piept's wohl nicht, heißt die Sendung.
Bei dir piept's wohl nicht. Genau. Und ja, da werden wir jetzt nahtlos dran anschließen.
Ich gehe dann mal.
Was bisher geschah.
Ich bin immerhin nicht mehr die Stimme der Jugend. Das ist schon mal gut. Das lastet mich in.
Nicht mein alter Wasser-Mann-Ego hier voll ausleben.
Dabei hast du am wenigsten graue Haare von uns.
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Wer ist denn bei euch?
Also ich bin Baujahr 73 und das ist glaube ich.
Ja, nee, da bin ich jünger.
Immer noch die Stimme der Jugend. Immer noch. Das wurde auch mal Zeit.
Uns wird hier schon sehr großes AWM-Potenzial nachgesagt.
Naja, ich gebe mein Bestes, das zu kontern.
Ich halte das ja auch für falsch. Also das kann ja wohl nicht sein.
Ja, was hat sich denn verändert? Also erstmal, du hast schon festgestellt,
Studio hat sich ein bisschen verändert.
Ja.
Ich habe die Zeit genutzt.
Ja, Mischpult hat Große weg.
Das ist mir gleich als erstes aufgefallen. Stattdessen meine persönliche auch
Hassliebe, der Röde-Caster.
Ja, also ansonsten. Und die großen Klopper sind auch verschwunden.
Ich habe meinen Mac Pro auch den ewigen Jagdgründen übergeben.
Übergeben, nee, der war einfach, der hat irgendwann nicht mehr gebootet, dann ist er raus.
Ich bin im Mac-Mini-Land gelandet und im MacBook Air-Land, habe mich computertechnisch
sehr verkleinert, aber ja.
Ja, sind wir eigentlich auf einer Linie. Also abgesehen davon,
dass ich hier ein Mac-Studio habe.
Gerade verpflichtet natürlich.
Ja, genau, also ich wollte dann doch schon so ein bisschen Wumms haben.
Aber hast du dein Mac Pro jetzt komplett entsorgt oder hast du ihn noch irgendwo rumstehen?
Nee, habe ich irgendwann einfach zur BSR gebracht.
Ernsthaft, zur BSR?
Ja, was soll ich mit dem Metall?
Ich bitte dich, naja, aber das Gehäuse, ich bitte dich.
Nee, ich wollte den weghaben, der musste weg.
Dann stellt man das auf die Straße in Berlin.
Ja, stimmt. Wobei, das soll jetzt verboten sein, ne?
Das soll verboten werden, ein Elend.
Ich habe noch einen Mac Plus, ich habe noch meinen allerersten Mac und ich habe
noch den Cube, den ich aus der Uni abgestoppt habe.
Ich habe genug Museumsstücke von Apple.
Also der Cheese Grater war einfach zu sperrig. Dafür hatte ich keinen Platz.
Und ja, das Ding ist, der hatte irgendeinen eher fundamentalen Schaden,
weil der hat nicht mal mehr gezuckt, wenn man den Powerbutton gedrückt hat oder
versucht hat, irgendwie auf dem Motherboard mit dem Jumper den zu beleben.
Also ich weiß nicht, der hatte irgendwie Also sonst hätte ich natürlich,
wenn er noch gebootet hätte, hätte ich gesagt, hier, bitteschön,
aber der hat nicht mal mehr gezuckt, deswegen Platten ausgebaut und weg damit.
Gibt ja Leute, die pflanzen da auch Blumen drin und so, ne?
Ja.
Wäre alles auch möglich gewesen.
Ja, ja, ja. Nee, nee, also da...
Oder sich ein Gaming-PC reinmacht.
Nee, hab ich auch überlegt, aber ich hab einen richtigen Gaming-PC und das wäre nicht gegangen.
Einen richtigen.
Ja.
Das hat sie auch vielleicht getan, seit 3MH. Ich habe auch so eine Windows-Kiste unterm Tisch stehen.
Was spielst du da? So ein, zwei Titel, die das dann auch ausreizen?
Naja, das Schöne ist, das müssen gar nicht die krassesten Spiele sein.
Es muss ja nur ein Indie-Spiel sein, was in Unity programmiert ist,
statt in Unreal oder irgendwas anderem Papamantel.
In dem Fall ist es tatsächlich immer noch gerne mal Escape from Tarkov,
wenn der Adrenalinspiegel etwas steigen soll.
das am forderndste Game ist wahrscheinlich Star Citizen,
was spiele ich noch so was viel GPU und CPU frisst das sind auf jeden Fall die
beiden Brecher die mir gerade so einfallen ach so Microsoft Flight Simulator
2024 natürlich da kommen dann die 64 GB DDR5 RAM und so weiter und die 16 GB Video RAM,
auf Auf ihre Kosten, das kann man sagen, ja.
Läuft das eigentlich nur auf Windows oder läuft das auf dem Mac?
Ne, seit einigen Jahren nur noch Windows leider. Aber ja, was sich getan hat
ansonsten, also Macs durchgecycelt.
Ich bin audio-technisch bin ich auch umgestiegen.
Ich hatte ja lange Zeit zu Hause so ein Universal Audio Interface in meinem kleinen Audio-Rack.
In der Zwischenzeit bin ich komplett auf RME gewechselt und denke,
jeder, der was mit Audio professionell macht, vielleicht sogar im Podcaststudio,
sollte eigentlich RME-Interfaces benutzen.
Was habe ich noch gemacht? Ach so, in verschiedenen Firmen zwischendurch gearbeitet,
zuletzt in einem Medizinunternehmen und habe da mal gesehen,
wie das mit dieser elektronischen Patientenakte so hinter den Kulissen läuft.
Oha.
Uh, uh, ah, ah. Es ist genauso schlimm, wenn nicht schlimmer,
wie ihr schon in den Kongress-Talks gehört habt.
Dann habe ich zuletzt, hat mich ein, ich glaube, der Fabian hat mich auch über
Freakshow ursprünglich mal gefunden.
Ich hatte ja mal so eine Zeit lang irgendwie nach Jobs irgendwie auf Mastodon gesucht.
Ja.
Und da hat sich ein damals noch Mobile-Max-Hörer gemeldet, der meinte,
er hätte da so eine App sich gebaut und die würde ihm über den Kopf wachsen,
und ob ich nicht Lust hätte, ihm das Backend zu rewriten.
Das habe ich so die fast letzten sechs Monate gemacht und hatte großen Spaß dabei.
Das ist im Prinzip auch, habt ihr wahrscheinlich schon eh gehört,
das nennt sich Trekiwi und ist im Prinzip.
Naja, irgendwie habe ich es schon mal hier und da gepostet auf jeden Fall.
Die kurze Geschichte, ich versuche es mal so kurz wie möglich zu machen, ist,
dass der gute Mann lange Zeit im Wohnmobil durch Europa getiggert ist und gelebt
hat mit seiner Freundin und wollte irgendwie seine ganzen Touren halt getrackt haben,
ohne sich drum kümmern zu müssen und fand die ganzen existierenden Tracker kacke,
weil die Daten halt irgendwo an US-Firmen gehen und dies und das und jenes.
und war selber ein bisschen programmieraffin und wollte mal gucken,
ob er sich dann nicht selber eine Lösung bauen kann, die ihm gefällt.
Hat er dann auch gemacht und auf den Campingplätzen haben dann immer mal so
die Nachbarn aufs Telefon geschielt und gefragt, oh, könnte ich das vielleicht auch haben?
Und ohne groß Werbung zu machen, hat er jetzt ein paar Kunden,
ein paar Zeile und kann selber davon schon sehr gut leben.
Und er hatte halt das Backend so in PHP so selbst gestrickt nach Gutdünken und
brauchte dann schon vier oder fünf Server,
um die überschaubare, aber nicht schon durchaus signifikante Kundenzahl zu bedienen
und jetzt könnte es aktuell mit meinem Backend auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen.
Lass mich raten.
Ja, bitte. Also, Cloud oder Bare Metal?
Wie, Cloud oder Bare Metal?
Naja, wo ist es gehostet? In der Cloud oder auf so einer richtigen Maschine?
Da habe ich dich kenn. Zum FreeBSD-Rechner.
So ist es.
FreeBSD mit Jails. Schön. Ich kann dir ein Feuer geben, Ralf.
Zumindest hatte ich vor kurzem noch eins in meiner Tasche.
Professioneller Öffner in der Schublade.
Ist doch schon gleich auf das Bier. Guck mal, zack. Dann natürlich...
Magst du mir auch noch eins mitbringen, Ralf, wo du schon stehst?
Dann natürlich Elixier und Postgres und noch ein paar kleine Spezialsachen.
Aber das Coole war halt, der hat mir das gezeigt, ich fand halt sofort das Design
schön clean und minimalistisch, nicht so überladen und zugeknallt.
Und im Prinzip, die Implementierung war jetzt auch nicht total schrecklich.
Natürlich, wenn man so mit der heißen Nadel Features strickt,
dann gibt es da so ein paar Quirks, die der Performance auch im Wege stehen.
Aber das hat mir großen Spaß gemacht.
Und vielleicht geht es da später auch nochmal weiter.
Übrigens, falls...
Das ist aber interessant irgendwie. Also ich meine, was heißt denn GPS-Trigger
speziell? Also wo kommt das GPS her oder woher?
Naja, der hat sich quasi von Teltonica, was so ein Hersteller ist für diverse
Devices dieser Art, quasi das Device ausgesucht, wo man eine SIM-Karte reinstecken kann.
Das heißt, wenn du da den Trecker kaufst, ist da eine SIM-Karte drin, die Daten hat bis ewig.
Aber man muss doch für GPS-Übermittlungen, muss man doch irgendwie noch zahlen
bei Teltonica, damit das irgendwie ins Backend kommt. Also man kriegt zwar das GPS.
Aber... Der Trecker sendet an mein Backend.
Ja gut, aber das heißt, es läuft Software auf dem Teletonica nochmal,
da ist nochmal ein Paket installiert oder was?
Das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht genau, da habe ich glücklicherweise nicht
viel mit zu tun mit diesem Trecker und dessen Konfiguration.
Ich weiß nur, der wird halt fest im Camper verbaut, kriegt sein GPS und sendet
es über Mobilfunk quasi ab.
Und wenn es keinen Mobilfunk gibt, dann trägt er trotzdem und kann irgendwie
paar tausend Positionen in seinem internen Speicher halten. und wenn er das
nächste Mal wieder Netz hat, dumpt er die dann alle ans Backend.
Und genau vorher hatte der nämlich auch so eine Software, so eine Java-Software,
die quasi die verschiedenen proprietären Protokolle von diversen Tracker-Herstellern
spricht und in so JSON umwandelt.
Und jetzt mit Elixir, wenn du halt Binärprotokoll hörst und parsen,
dann schlackerst du ja nur mit den Ohren und sagst ja willkommen in der richtigen
Runtime- und Programmiersprache und habe dann quasi die Features,
die er von dem Tracker, von dem Protokoll baut, selber gebaut.
Das heißt auch gleich wieder eine Komponente rausgeschmissen. Genau.
Ach so, das ist der dedizierte GPS-Tracker Teltonica FMC920.
Ah ja, das könnte sein.
Das steht jetzt zumindest auf der Webseite. Von daher gehe ich mir davon aus,
dass das jetzt irgendwie stimmt.
Klingt plausibel, ja, ja. Genau, was ich noch sagen wollte. Das Ding ist halt auch...
Genau, wir haben jetzt auch schon die ganze Zeit überlegt, theoretisch für Segelboot.
Ich hatte jetzt auch ein Segelboot mit in so einer Tupperdose und habe mal geguckt,
wie gut das alles so im Segelboot funktioniert und funktioniert natürlich auch super.
Dann hat irgendwie der Skipper-Freund von mir gedacht, ah ja,
Motorradfahrer, die wollen eigentlich auch die ganze Zeit so ihre Routen tracken
und gerade wenn du so ein bisschen wildere Touren machst, weil er meinte,
da wären schon Leute verunglückt alleine und dann hätte man hinterher voll Probleme
gehabt, überhaupt rauszufinden, wo die waren, was die gemacht haben und so weiter.
und er hätte ja auch gerne so ein Tracker-Motorrad und dem werde ich vielleicht
auch mal so ein Testmodell geben, um zu gucken, ob das da die Erschütterung
und so weiter gut übersteht.
Aber im Wesentlichen ist die Idee ganz simpel.
Du baust irgendwo diesen Tracker ein, die Daten landen auf deutschen Servern
und nicht irgendwo bei irgendwelchen anderen Anbietern.
Und kriegst halt so ein bisschen Aufbereitung in hübsch und die Features werden
auch immer noch weiter erweitert.
Das ist halt wirklich das letztes Jahr im April damit an den Markt gegangen und deswegen,
das ist die Kurve, die zeigt die ganze Zeit nach oben, aber es ist auch von
null gestartet und von nicht allzu langer Zeit, deswegen ist alles noch sehr überschaubar.
Also die Load, das war halt so witzig, weil ich habe die Dev-Version natürlich
dann schon irgendwo auf den Server geschmissen und er hat so einen Stapel Beta-Tester,
die auf der ganzen Welt mit den Dingern rumfahren, also wirklich bis an die
letzte Spitze Patagoniens war da einer mit einem Camper unterwegs und das war
halt die ganze Zeit so das Erlang bei 0,1 Prozent oder weniger, also wirklich so null.
Wenn du Top aufgemacht hast oder Hardtop, das hatte immer die Spitzenposition im Top.
Also wie viele User, also wie viele gleichzeitig kannst du das sagen?
So sagen wir mal zwischen 1000 und 3000.
Also nicht insgesamt, sondern so Trecker.
Die die ganze Zeit da rumfunken.
Die permanent irgendwie Daten sammeln. Genau, okay, verstehe. Die aktiv sind.
Und jetzt der, okay.
Das ist ja schon was.
Der Use Case gegenüber, ich nehme die Daten einfach von meinem Handy,
wo ja auch irgendwie Trecker, GPS drin ist, ist, dass ich nicht so die ganzen
Tagestrips durch Städte und sowas als Neues drin habe, sondern wirklich nur
die Bewegungsdaten des Autos.
Du musst dich halt nicht um Strom und irgendwas anderes kümmern,
du baust den halt irgendwo ein, wo man auch keiner sieht und vergisst den.
Das heißt auch so, funktioniert so ein bisschen wie Airtake,
Diebstahlschutz. Du kannst halt auch, wenn es irgendwo überwintert,
gucken, wie geht es dem denn so.
Wenn du es richtig anschließt, kannst du sehen, ob Strom dran hängt oder den Batterieladezustand.
Und im Wesentlichen ist es wirklich für ihn so gewesen.
Ich hoffe, lieber Fabian, ich lege dir da jetzt nicht so viele Worte in den
Mund, aber einfach einmal einbauen und nicht dran denken und dann die ganze
Zeit die Möglichkeit haben, wenn sich der aus dem,
aus diesem Geofence rausbewegt, schickt mir mal eine Alarm-Push-Notification
oder eben, um einfach zu gucken, wenn man wieder nach Portugal fährt,
wo war man denn das letzte Mal, lass mal ganz woanders langfahren oder wo war
ein Campingplatz mit gratis Wasser oder ja.
Wie lange hält die Batterie?
Ach so, die interne, die hält glaube ich nur eine Stunde. Also es hängt ja an
der Fahrzeugbatterie dran. Es verbraucht auch super wenig Strom.
Das heißt, wenn du halt einen Campervan hast mit einer fetten Batterie,
dann hält das auch ziemlich lange.
Und wenn du es überwindest, dann hängt der idealerweise eh am Strom und saugt
nicht einfach nur die Batterie leer.
Ich hatte jetzt unterwegs, weil das 12 Volt Anschluss hatte,
dieses Gerät, was er mir geschickt hatte, da habe ich mir so einen ganz abgefahrenen
USB-Powerbank zu 12 Volt Schnupsi geholt und hatte das an der 20.000 Milliampere
Stunden Powerbank dran. und die hat...
Ich habe sie zweimal geladen, aber die war noch lange nicht leer.
Ich wollte sie nur top abhaben, weil es ist das erste Mal, dass ich jetzt mit
Powerbank mit dem Ding unterwegs war.
Das heißt, verbraucht ziemlich wenig Strom.
Das Ding ist halt, wenn du Polar Steps oder andere Trecker-Apps auf deinem Telefon
benutzt, dann sind die ja die ganze Zeit aktiv und lutschen dir den iPhone-Akku leer.
Genau, das wäre halt ein weiterer Aspekt davon. Und das Ding hat halt auch so,
das sendet noch so einige Meter, was ich schon meinte, liegt Spannung an,
also hat es einen Stromanschluss, wie ist der Batterieladezustand,
wenn du kannst ein Event kriegen, ob die Zündung angeht, du kannst,
das Ding sendet dir GPS-Jamming-Alerts, also wenn es detektet,
dass gerade in der Nähe GPS-Jamming ist, kriegst du auch eine Meldung.
Wenn die Russen kommen.
Das könnte ein Thema werden demnächst, ja.
Erschütterungsalarm, also das heißt, irgendwas rattelt am Wohnmobil und ein
Crash-Detector hat er auch, wenn es spontane Stop-Events, sagen wir mal, gibt. genau und,
ja das ist es im Wesentlichen und das hat aber sehr viel Spaß gemacht ein Elixier
zu bauen wir sprechen bestimmt später nochmal mehr darüber aber es ist halt
so wie ich das gerne mag so ziemlich low-levelig,
Binärprotokolle, Postgres optimieren auf die letzte Millisekunde,
Da waren einige spannende Probleme, wo man auch echt so, okay,
weiß ich gar nicht, so straightforward jetzt aus dem Kopf, wie würde ich das
Algorithmus bauen. Also war gut.
Und das Frontend?
Das macht der Fabian aktuell immer noch.
Also der macht alles in Personalunion. Wenn du als Customer das Support-Telefon
anrufst, dann geht er rein.
Deswegen, ja, das ist immer noch wahrscheinlich in einem besseren Zustand als
auch noch vor dem Jahr, aber absehbar wird ja auch nochmal die App und das Frontend nochmal neu bauen.
Was ist das Frontend dann?
JavaScript. Also du kannst es dir auch als Desktop-App quasi,
als gerappte Web-App besorgen.
Es ist halt, ich weiß nicht, ob bei Elektron benutzt oder irgendwas anderes, aber es ist...
Aber ist dann dein Backend auch das Backend der Webseite oder ist das nur das
Backend dieser Datensache?
Ah ne, also genau, das ist halt auch ganz schön, fand ich von Anfang an designt
worden, weil die ganzen Kundendaten und so, die sehe ich gar nicht.
Also ja, ich könnte in die Datenbank rein, aber ich habe mit denen nichts zu
tun und war bisher auch nicht in der Datenbank drin,
aber gab auch keinen Grund dafür und in meinem Backend habe ich nur eine Tracker-ID
und die ganzen Positionsdaten und so weiter.
Und die Webseite oder die App, die holt sich von meinem Backend bestimmte Daten zu einem Tracker ab.
Und der Rest, alles was so Kundendaten und deinem Tracker einen Namen geben
und solche Späße, die passieren dann auf der Webseite.
Das heißt, die eigentliche Analyse der Geodaten ist jetzt auch nicht in deinem
Bereich gefallen, sondern es ging im Wesentlichen nur das Einsammeln?
Nee, also ich mache im Backend zum Beispiel die Stop- und Overnight-Detection,
Distanzkalkulationen.
Statistiken auch so ein bisschen für jetzt, wenn du wissen willst,
wie viele Kilometer im Monat, an welchem Tag und so weiter so ein Käse.
Dann mache ich auch die Share-Logic, weil es kommt jetzt demnächst ein neues
Share-Feature, wo du sagen kannst,
ich will meine Live-Position, ich will meine Live-Position mit meiner Route,
aber ich will meine Route nicht ultrapräzise, ich will keine Übernachtungsplätze
drin haben oder ich will die ganze Route ein bisschen geglättet haben oder ich will sogar,
dass meine Übernachtungsorte rausgestempelt werden und die Route dann so conveniently
in bestimmbarem Radius drumrum geht, damit du halt, wenn du jetzt an Orten,
an Privatgrundstücken oder so bist und die Adresse dann nicht preisgeben willst, kannst du dann so.
Und diese ganzen Sachen, die sind dann tatsächlich doch ein bisschen aufwendig
zum Teil, vor allen Dingen, wenn du halt ein paar Millionen Records in der DB
hast und dann gucken musst du,
wie massieren wir die denn jetzt, dass das schnell auch da rauskommt. Sowas mache ich.
Und alles, was so bestellen, verlängern,
Kundendaten ändern und Route angucken, also die Map und so, die gerendert wird,
die kriegt zwar die Daten auch von meinem Backend, aber das ganze Rendering
und GUI und so, das ist auf der Webseite und dem Backend.
Okay.
Also irgendwie, fände ich, hat er intuitiv ganz gut geschnitten.
Also es war echt eine ganz entspannte...
Ich finde ja auch eine interessante Interessante Anwendung, weil diesen Bedarf gibt es natürlich.
Ich habe auch schon mehrfach drüber nachgedacht, ob ich irgendwie mal die Daten einsammle.
Ich war jetzt schon froh, dass ich meinem Teletonica Rauter mal beibringen konnte,
seine GPS-Informationen mal überhaupt mal mit meinem Victron-System zu teilen,
dass das auch mal weiß, wo es ist,
ohne dass ich da jetzt nochmal ein extra GPS hätte anschließen müssen,
weil es der Teletonica sowieso schon hatte.
Ja, siehst du mal, genau ein Feature, was halt auch viele andere dieser Dienste
nicht haben, ist, dass die fangen halt irgendwann an, Daten zu löschen,
weil es werden halt viele Daten.
Der Anspruch jetzt da ist, nichts zu löschen, sondern du hast alles für immer.
Aktuell funktioniert das auch und es wird auch noch eine ganze Weile in dem
Setup so skalieren. Allerdings sollte es super erfolgreich werden,
dann muss spätestens da dann das Postgres mal neu gestreichelt werden,
anders gestreichelt werden.
Also da haben wir auch schon ein paar Konzepte uns überlegt,
wie wir das dann machen, wenn es soweit ist.
Das heißt, es wäre dann keine böse Überraschung, aber das Postgres ist aktuell auch immer noch.
Absolut tiefenentspannt und das Erlang auch oder das Elixier.
Deswegen aktuell gibt es noch gar keine Skalierungsproblemchen.
Die Webseite ist schön. Das gefällt mir.
Da kommt man mit Fragen und wie viele Klicks brauche ich, um irgendwie zu meiner
Antwort zu kommen. Und das ist sehr schön aufgebaut.
Genau, das hat mich auch sofort angesprochen. Da dachte ich mir so,
ah ja, weil genau, wenn dann so die, ja, hast du vielleicht Bock,
mein Backend neu zu wahren? Dann so, ja, okay, mal gucken, wie das aussieht.
Womit man sich dann da so rumärgern muss.
Genau, weil es dann so die Webseite aufgemacht hat, dachte ich,
okay, gut, schon mal ein cleanes Design. Das ist mir auch sofort gut reingelaufen.
Naja, da fällt mir ein, ich kann euch auf jeden Fall, wenn euch das interessiert,
Ich habe auch, glaube ich, irgendwo so einen Affiliate-Link,
wo ihr so ein paar Prozente wegbekommt, falls ihr das haben wollt. Wer?
Wir?
Alle.
Alle?
Alle da draußen.
Okay.
Pressure.
Genau, und um jetzt das mal kurz vielleicht abzuschließen, wir können uns ja
dann noch andere Themen irgendwie rauspicken.
Achso, was ich noch so gemacht habe, was vielleicht aber auch die meisten Leute
schon mitbekommen haben, dass ich mein Stream Elements Reaper OSC Plugin gebaut
habe, weil die, die es gab,
mir nicht erlaubt haben, beliebige Command-IDs an den Reaper zu schicken und
das war so, da hatte ich gerade ein bisschen Freizeit nach dem vorletzten Job
und dachte mir, ach, guckst du mal, ob ich das mit Go machen kann,
damit ich mal ein bisschen meine Go-Skills etwas schleife und dann ja.
Kannst du mal sagen, was Stream Elements ist?
Ah, Stream Elements. Achso, sorry, ja, nee, ich habe mich natürlich vertippt. Stream Deck.
Ich verwechsel die immer. Stream Elements ist eine Streaming-Software,
die auch mit Stream Deck gesteuert werden kann. Nee, Stream Deck.
Stream Deck, alles klar. Also das kleine Elgato-Schnuppi-Teil mit den komischen Tasten.
Genau, das können wir auf jeden Fall auch noch mal verlinken für die Leute,
die es vielleicht noch nicht gesehen haben.
Weil bei mir, ich benutze ja nicht Ultraschall nach wie vor,
weil ich ja meinen Audio-Workflow nicht nur auf Podcasten beziehe.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie es bei Ultraschall ist.
Ich weiß, du wirst gleich, aber, Kleinen Moment, halte noch inne.
Mein Problem war halt immer so, wenn ich Kapitelmarken setzen wollte und dann
gerade den Browser im Vordergrund hatte oder sonst irgendwas,
dass ich den Button drücken wollte und egal in welchem Kontext ich gerade bin
oder auf welchem Computer,
soll der Reaper, der in meinem Netz gerade Aufnahme macht, halt eine Kapitelmarke
setzen oder einen Marker.
Und das war eigentlich der Ursprungsgedanke, warum ich dachte,
okay, ich will jetzt so einen Button auf meinem Stream Deck haben,
der OSC sendet, damit es halt muss nicht mal auf dem selben Computer laufen.
Und genau, das hat dann am Ende sogar ganz gut funktioniert und auf User-Anregungen
habe ich vor kurzem noch eingebaut, dass der MIDI-Editor auch jetzt seine Command-IDs
bekommt, weil der ist ja so ein,
stiefmütterliches Kind leider immer noch im Reaper und hat seinen eigenen Satz Command-IDs,
die man auch anders anspricht als den normalen Reaper und da ich auch öfters
mit dem MIDI-Editor zu tun hatte, Das ist ja okay.
Mal. Und erweitere das Programm.
Also fürs Protokoll. Wenn man nett bei uns anfragt, dann rücken wir Ultraschall
auch als sogenannte Portable Install raus.
Ja.
Die sich dann selbst völlig genug ist innerhalb von einem beliebigen Ordner im Dateisystem.
Und dann kannst du das parallel zu deiner normalen Reaper-Version betreiben.
Warum gibt es das nur auf Liebe Anfrage?
Naja, also zum einen weil wir halt mit dem Installer noch Dinge an Orte kopieren,
wo sie eigentlich so hingehören,
und nicht unbedingt in so ein Verzeichnis weggekapselt sein sollen und zum anderen
muss man dann für diesen Art der Installation sich dann halt auch noch eine
Reaper-App oder Exo oder was auch immer halt dann in diesen Ordner reinschieben,
die muss man sich erstmal irgendwo her organisieren und die können wir dann
halt nicht mit distribuieren so gerne Justin uns vielleicht auch hat so,
dass wir jetzt also quasi auch ein komplettes Reaper irgendwie wegnehmen und selber rausgeben.
Das machen wir nur auf Anfrage.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Aber das ist zum Beispiel ein Szenario für Orte da draußen, gerade Schulen,
VHS und sowas, die ein sehr abgeschottetes System haben, wo du auf dem Windows
irgendwie gar nichts installieren darfst.
Dann kopierst du da halt den Ordner hin und startest dem aus dem Ordner raus
und dann kriegt man auch in so einem Kontext noch einen Ultraschall zu laufen.
Na gut, vielleicht gebe ich der ganzen Sache nochmal eine Chance.
Warum Go?
Ja, im Prinzip, ich mag zwar Erlang und Elixir sehr gern, aber in der administrativen
Tätigkeit so auf den Servern ist mir auf jeden Fall lieb, wenn es schon kein
FreeBSD, PKG oder Release gibt,
wenn es dann wenigstens als Go-Executable kommt oder als Go-Project,
weil das Cross-Compilen ist halt das allerbeste von allen Programmiersprachen meiner Meinung nach.
Weil du kannst halt einfach sagen, ich kann auf dem Mac hier ein bisschen Go
rumhacken und sagen, mach mir jetzt mal ein Windows ARM64 Binary drauf und das
zuckt nicht, da musst du nicht noch irgendwelche Reifen durchspringen,
sondern da fliegt einfach nach wenigen Sekunden ein Windows-Executable raus
oder als ich hier das Stream Deck-Plugin gemacht habe.
Ich dachte mir halt einfach, ich will es, weil ich auch mit Sockets,
weil es sendet ja UDP, ich wollte halt so mit Netzwerk mehr zu tun haben,
als mir JavaScript das erlauben würde.
Ich hätte das bestimmt noch mit JavaScript lösen können, irgendwie mit Node
und da gibt es bestimmt auch Sockets, aber irgendwie hatte ich so das Bedürfnis,
ah, wieder mal ein bisschen mit Go rumspielen.
B, dann auch gleich geil, weil Cross-Compile ist kein Problem.
Und C, ich mag es mit den Sockets irgendwie, wenn ich die direkt an der Hand habe.
Du hättest ja wahrscheinlich eine blutige Nase geholt, weil ich habe nämlich
probiert, mit Elixir mal so ein Stream Deck Plug-In zu machen.
Und es scheitert allein schon daran, dass diese Stream Deck Software alle Plug-Ins
regelmäßig, wenn sie nichts zu tun haben, mit dem SIG-Therm irgendwie killt.
Und dann fährt einem immer die ganze VM runter.
und da ich nicht bereit war, da nochmal so ein anderes C-Programm davor zu machen,
was das irgendwie abschirmt, habe ich das dann irgendwie sein gelassen.
Aber it was fun while it lasted.
Ja, nee, das ist genauso für kleine System-Tools mag ich es ganz gerne,
weil performt, musst du dich nicht um den Speicher kümmern, dass der irgendwann
mal liegt oder so und kannst es halt geil cross-compilen.
Ich würde selber nie sowas wie Grafana oder so in Go schreiben wollen,
dafür ist mir die die Sprache ist auch zu anstrengend, aber es ist halt eine
schön kleine Sprache und,
sagen wir mal, die Lernkurve, die ist schon ein bisschen anstrengend,
weil viel muss man halt selber machen, was man gewohnt ist, jetzt nicht mehr
selber zu machen, aber auf der anderen Seite,
braucht man auch nicht monatelang, um jetzt die Sprache zu lernen,
weil da so viel gibt es da halt auch nicht.
Ja, nee, ich meine, es ist definitiv so ein Contender für,
diese Stöpsel-Sprachen. Also so Sprachen, die man so auf Systemebene einsetzt,
um irgendwelche Löcher zu stopfen.
Wo man halt sonst immer nur 10 nehmen konnte.
Gibt es halt jetzt auf der einen Seite natürlich Rust, was sich ja großer Beliebtheit erfreut.
Dann gibt es sowieso für die Freunde der besonderen Leichtathletik in dem Bereich
gibt es irgendwie noch dieses SICK, was jetzt irgendwie sich so ein bisschen rumspricht.
Ich habe da noch wenig Erfahrung mit, aber das ist irgendwie...
Hat auch eine gewisse Popularität in der Elixierwelt, so als Extension-System, egal.
Ja, und halt Go, was ja von den Graubärten, den alten C-Graubärten ja auf den
Markt geworfen wurde seinerzeit.
Ja, ich meine, vom Konzept her mag ich Rust auch so schon sehr,
aber mir ist es so anstrengend für so ein kleines, also da ist mir zu viel Schwungmasse,
um mal eben schnell so ein kleines Tool zu hacken, da muss ich mich dann hirnmäßig
viel mehr reinhirnen, gerade wenn man es nicht regelmäßig macht.
In Go, da ist halt so gut wie kein Boilerplate, keine Zeremonie nötig,
um mal schnell, ich schreibe mal kurz ein paar Funktionen in den File, compile das, fertig.
Und ja, also ich habe nichts gegen Rust und so.
Wenn ich Probleme hätte, für die Rust gut geeignet wäre, würde ich das auch gerne benutzen.
Aber glücklicherweise reicht für meinen kleinen bisschen dann immer das Go noch aus.
Russ hatte halt eine sehr klasse Lernkurve, genau. Ich meine,
wie gesagt, ich habe davor ja jahrelang Erlang gemacht und war da voll im funktionalen
Zaubertanz und dann zu Go wieder zurück zu gehen, das war schon auch hart.
So, bevor wir noch weiter in deiner Reise der letzten drei Jahre schwelgen,
da ist ja noch einiges zu holen.
Sollen wir mal Reifchen noch mal ins Boot holen und einen kleinen Feedbackblock
vielleicht mal reinwerfen, dass wir mal die letzte Sendung noch aufgefegt bekommen,
weil wir hatten ja eine kleine Competition.
Musst aber dein Mikrofon einschalten.
Mann, Mann, Mann, Mann. Einmal mit Profis.
Genau. Zur letzten Sendung gab es wieder vieles schönes Feedback.
Danke auch erstmal dafür.
Und eine Sache hatten wir dazu aufgerufen oder genauer gesagt ich,
nämlich wir erinnern uns diese Kette schlechter Entscheidungen,
die aber an und für sich leider dann jeweils alternativlos sind oder zumindest
alternativlos erscheinen.
Und dafür fehlte mir ein Begriff in der deutschen oder englischen Sprache.
Und da ist einiges reingetrudelt an Vorschlägen und ich habe ein Voting dazu
aufgesetzt mit allen Vorschlägen, die ich gefunden habe über unsere verschiedenen Feedback-Kanäle.
Und da waren ein paar sehr schöne Sachen dabei. So, das Voting läuft,
die URLs sind rumgeschickt.
Wenn ihr das jetzt nachhört, müsst ihr mit den Ergebnissen leben.
Das ist dann halt so.
Ich habe das noch gar nicht, hast du das auch auf Mastodon gepostet?
Na, du hast es ja schon gepostet.
Hatte ich das? Nee, hatte ich.
Ich habe es in den Chat geworfen und du hast es auf Mastodon.
Habe ich? Ah ja, doch, habe ich.
Genau, ich lese sie einfach mal vor, weil da sind ein paar sehr schöne dabei,
beziehungsweise ich würde nochmal ein bisschen einordnen, warum sie besser oder
schlechter passen. Also wir
erinnern uns, dieser Begriff muss glaube ich zwei Komponenten abdecken.
Nämlich zum einen, dass es eine Kette ist oder zumindest eine Vielzahl von Vorgängen.
Es reicht nicht nur, dass irgendwann mal was schrecklich ist,
sondern es muss schon eine Kette sein.
Und das zweite ist, es ging eigentlich nicht darum,
so um Alternativen, dass man irgendwie das Schlechtere wählt,
sondern es gibt eigentlich nur von dem jeweiligen Standpunkt scheinbar zumindest
nur noch einen einzigen Weg, den man weitergehen muss.
Und entsprechend gut oder schlecht bilden jetzt die verschiedenen Begriffe das ab.
In der Sendung selber hatte ich das reingeworfen, was mir ChatGPT vorgeschlagen hatte.
Pragmageddon, also eine Mischung aus pragmatisch und Armageddon,
kommt derzeit auf 8% der Votings, ist damit immerhin schon so im gesunden Mittelfeld.
Das zweite fand ich schon ziemlich gut, nämlich ein Kompromisthaufen.
Auch schön.
Da ist aber das mit der Kette nicht so richtig.
Aber schon mal mehrere. Ein Misthaufen ist schon mal nicht nur ein Mistding,
sondern schon mal ein ganzer Haufen. Das würde ich schon mal gut durchgehen lassen.
Aber der serielle Aspekt fehlt.
Das nächste ist auch schön Kompromiss Jenga vom Jenga-Turm.
Wobei da so diese Assoziation ist, irgendwann fällt das alles zusammen und es
schreut. Man kommt ja zum Ziel.
Hat 4 Prozent. Der Kompromisstaufen liegt auch bei 8 Prozent.
Dann gibt es den Kompromess.
Warte mal, Mehrfachnennungen waren möglich. Also diese Prozentzahlen addieren
sich jetzt nicht auf 100.
Auf 100, so ist es. Und das haben jetzt, stand jetzt, gucke ich mal drauf, 46 Leute abgestimmt.
Gehst du jetzt von hinten nach vorne?
Nee, von oben nach unten, wie ich es hier reingegeben habe. Aber es verschiebt
sich live alles hier. Jetzt in diesem Moment.
Was eben noch gesagt wurde, kann schon wieder falsch sein.
Genau. Also Kompromiss als quasi irgendwie englisches Kunstwort an der Stelle.
aus Kompromiss und CMS. Dann in der Tat sehr klassisch die Odyssee.
Da habe ich lange drüber nachgegangen, also von Homer und Odysseus und bis er
endlich nach Ithaka kommt, die mit humanistischen Bildungen sind hier klar im Vorteil.
Aber waren das alle schlechte Entscheidungen?
Eben, das ist der Punkt. Das waren eigentlich Situationen, in die er geworfen worden ist.
Und seine Entscheidungen waren nicht unbedingt schlecht, sondern wenn ihm wieder
Poseidon als Meeresgott übel mitspielt, dann muss er halt irgendwie kämpfen
und dem Zyklopen das Auge und so weiter. Das ist ja nicht wirklich so Entscheidungen.
Er hat sich die Sirenen ja auch nicht ausgesucht.
Doch, exakt. Die hat er sich ausgesucht.
Die hat er sich ausgesucht?
Tim. Mann, Mann, Mann, Mann. So, wir erinnern uns, die Sirenen, das waren...
Die sind doch aufgetaucht und dann musste er da hin. Oder ist er da direkt hingefallen?
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Der,
USP, der Sirenen war ja, sobald man ihren Gesang gehört hat,
war man ihnen sofort verfallen und hat alles, alle anderen Gedanken fahren lassen.
Und die saßen aber halt auf einem sehr gefährlichen Felsen, sodass jedes Schiff,
was sich ihnen genähert hat, sofort zerschellt ist und alle Leute waren tot.
Und Odysseus, der alte Fuchs, kannte das natürlich und hat gesagt,
so liebe Mannschaft, ihr kriegt mal alle Wachs in die Ohren.
Aber warum ist er da überhaupt hingefahren?
Der musste da irgendwie lang an diesem Felsen, weil er lag auf dem Weg nach Ithaka.
Aber der Clou ist, warum das schon, Odyssee ist wirklich eine gute Geschichte.
Er hat also seiner ganzen Mannschaft Wachs in die Ohren gepackt,
damit die schön vorbeisegeln können.
Er selber hat sich aber an den Mast anbinden lassen und kein Wachs in die Ohren
gemacht, weil er wollte sich das schon ganz gerne anhören, wovon die da alle immer so reden.
Naja, und dann hat er also getobt und gezetert und war seines Lebens nicht mehr
froh und das Schiff segelte aber eben dann doch unbescholten an den Klippen
vorbei, weil die Mannschaft ja nun mal geschützt war.
Also von daher Odyssee nicht schlecht, aber halt auch nicht ganz das,
was wir suchen. Genauso wie, glaube ich, das nächste, nämlich Snafu.
Das hat das Militär hier nichts zu bieten.
Situation normal, all fucked up.
bezieht sich halt auf eine Situation meiner Interpretation nach und nicht eine
Kette von Entscheidungen.
Frickeln, ja gut, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen offensichtlich,
das hat in der Tat was damit zu tun, aber fehlt auch ein bisschen die Kette.
Derzeit jetzt in the lead mit 17,2% ist die Pain Chain.
Die finde ich in der Tat auch ganz gut. Chain of Pain, je nachdem,
ob man es ein bisschen länger...
Pain of Pain, okay.
Es tut weh, aber man muss halt durch.
Da ist aber der Entscheidungsaspekt nicht dabei.
Naja, so viel entscheiden kann man sich ja vielleicht auch gar nicht.
Also man muss halt durch.
Du musst durch diesen nächsten Schritt der Pain-Shane musst du halt auch irgendwie
durchleiden. Kann man schon machen.
So, hingefrickelt ist nochmal eine Variante von Frickeln.
Murks als Akronym für maximale Umwegsroutenplanung.
Auch nicht schlecht. Das nächste mag ich auch ganz gerne, liegt auch auf Platz
zwei jetzt mit zehn Prozent, nämlich die Tja-Kaskade.
Also eine Kaskade von Entscheidungen, wo man jeweils so, tja,
ging halt nicht anders, die Tja-Kaskade.
So, das nächste ist schön, weil es quasi wissenschaftlich der exakteste Begriff
bisher ist, nämlich ein eskalierendes Commitment.
Das ist in der Tat etwas, was man aus der Betriebswirtschaftslehre kennt oder
VWL, weiß gar nicht genau das eine oder das andere.
Das heißt also, hat viel mit diesem Sunk-Cost-Prinzip zu tun.
Ich habe schon so viel rein investiert in irgendeine Unternehmung,
dass es mir unlogisch erscheint oder ich kann es nicht über mich bringen jetzt
zu sagen, das lasse ich jetzt bleiben und mache ganz was anderes,
sondern ich committe mich halt zu meinen bisherigen Entscheidungen und das eskaliert immer weiter.
Ja, okay, das ist ganz interessant.
Hattest du den Eindruck bei deinen Entscheidungen, das war doch im Urlaub.
Genau, nochmal für die, die die Sendung nicht gehört haben, mein simples Ziel
war es, ich möchte mit meinen Kindern vernünftig Musik im Auto hören.
So ein scheinbar einfaches Ziel, was halt nicht einfach zu erreichen war,
wenn man ein 19 Jahre altes Auto hat mit einem 19 Jahre alten Mercedes-Radio,
was man nicht ohne weiteres austauschen kann, weil es in der Mittelkonsole hart verbaut ist,
was keinen AUX-Eingang hatte, FM-Transmitter klingen scheiße und dann war der
einzige Ausweg CD-Brennen und der Weg dahin im Jahr 2025 aus einer Play, Liste in iTunes.
Da kam übrigens jetzt nochmal ganz frisch ein Kommentar rein mit einem heißen
Tipp, das können wir gleich am Ende nochmal nachstellen.
Es kamen mehrere sehr gute Tipps.
Ja, aber nochmal was sehr interessantes.
Würde ich danach in der Tat nochmal thematisieren. So, und der Weg dahin,
wie zum Teufel brennen ich jetzt Audio-CDs im Jahr 2025?
Habe ich erst vor kurzem gemacht, gar kein Problem.
Das ist halt die Frage.
Wo kriegt man die Songs her dafür? So, dann haben wir...
Also deine Songs nicht als Files auf der Platte.
Da ich irgendwie seit Jahren nur noch Streaming in der Tat höre.
Ich habe entweder Vinyl oder Streaming.
Alles dazwischen. Das ist Waste of Time.
Konsumkaskade haben wir noch. Trifft es glaube ich nicht gut,
weil es mit Konsum eigentlich nichts zu tun hat. Hat auch 0% Votings derzeit.
Die Compromission. Also eine Mission aus Kompromissen. Gar nicht so schlecht.
YouGuard. Das ist in der Tat ein indisches Wort, musste ich auch erst mal nachschlagen.
Das bezeichnet aber eher sowas wie Tüftlertum, Improvisationstalent.
Das ist also eher so ein Mindset, also Hackertum, sich mit vielen Unwägbarkeiten
irgendwie abfinden und dann trotzdem irgendwie zu Lösungen kommen.
Da fehlt so ein bisschen das Drama dann, weil es eigentlich eher ein positiver Begriff ist.
Das Dilemma-Geddon. Dann haben wir noch die Compro-Shittification.
Also die Shittification nochmal erweitert um Kompromiss.
Dann das Kompromiss-Katarakt.
Das ist ein Katarakt eigentlich. Da habe ich jetzt eine Bildungslücke.
Ja, ich auch. Ist das nicht was Medizinisches?
Das sind immer so Begriffe, wo ich das Gefühl habe, es ist irgendeine ansteckende Krankheit.
Da ist es auch, nämlich im Grauer Star, Linsentrübung des Auges.
Aber in der Technik eine Regelvorrichtung an Dampfmaschinen.
Okay.
Oder eine Stromschnelle.
Ein reißender, fließender Flussabschnitt.
Dann haben wir noch das Desaster-Domino. Das kam glaube ich von dir.
Ja.
Das fand ich in der Tat so mit der Abfolge, so das eine wirft sofort.
Da ist zumindest dieses das eine löst das andere aus, ist da sehr Alliteration.
Fand ich Wobei Domino.
Ich meine, das ist nur insofern glaube ich passend, als dass,
wenn wir Domino hören, niemand mehr an das eigentliche Domino-Spiel denkt,
sondern nur Dominosteine quasi als zum Umfallen.
Oder Domino Pizza.
Oh Gott.
Das ist auch eine schlechte Entscheidung, die ihre Konsequenzen hat.
Aber das ist das Desaster-Domino. Ich denke, dass jeder diese Assoziation hat.
Das ist so eine Abfolge.
Das ist auch dieses Unausweichliche. Die müssen in die nächste Richtung.
Wenn der eine erstmal umfällt, dann sind die anderen im Prinzip alle schon dabei.
Und auf welchem Platz steht Desaster-Domino?
Ich habe jetzt gerade mal den Link zu den derzeitigen Zwischenergebnissen bei
jetzt nahezu 60 Abstimmungen drin.
Das ist mit 6,3 Prozent jetzt auch so in der Mittelfeldgruppe.
Also es gibt quasi einen einsamen Spitzenreiter, das ist die Pain-Chain.
Dann gibt es ein etwas größeres Mittelfeld. Und das letzte ist ja noch das Ketten-Dilemma.
6,3 Prozent auch so im Mittelfeld. Also ich glaube, die Pain-Chain wird es werden,
wenn ich mir das so angucke.
Du sag mal hier, Tim ganz kurz, kannst du dem Jörn da im Chat mal den Link hin
posten, der will jetzt direkt einen Trecker haben. Habe ich in die Shownotes gepackt.
Trekiwi. Ich nehme mal an, er meint den Trekiwi-Link.
Achso, Trekiwi habe ich doch gepostet schon.
Na, ich habe ja den Affiliate 10% Rabatt-Link noch reingepostet, der will Prozente.
Achso.
Das ist unter meinem Punkt da.
Ach, du hast keinen Account hier auf Slack oder was?
Ne, den habe ich irgendwann mal entfernt, weil ich keinen Slack sonst brauchte.
Ja,
dann suche ich nur gerade jetzt hier, wo ist denn meine...
Wo sind denn deine Notes? Sorry, ich dachte, es geht schnell,
aber der gute Mann sucht nach seinen Fenstern.
Ja, das ist gar nicht so einfach, wenn man hier mit mehreren Computern,
mit mehreren Bildschirmen arbeitet.
Ah, okay.
Ja, da war auf jeden Fall viel Schönes dabei, das werden wir sicherlich im einen
oder anderen Zusammenhang dann nochmal nachnutzen können, was ihr da zusammengetragen habt.
Du hast jetzt von $LM nur einen generieren lassen oder waren da mehrere von LM vorgeschlagen?
Genau, da dachte ich, das ist eigentlich lustiger, wenn man das dann irgendwie
ein bisschen Schwarmintelligenz in der Sendung anzapft, anstatt jetzt irgendwie
zehn Sachen von JetGPT bauen zu lassen.
Also ich hatte nochmal eine zweite Frage, da kamen dann aber noch schlechtere Geschichten raus.
Ich hatte einen so eine Wortfindungsfrage und dachte mir, ja komm,
das ist doch genau die Paradeaufgabe für so halluzinierende Mark of Chains und meinte,
du erzählst eine Geschichte und da ist so ein kleiner Teilaspekt und dann kommt
eine Nachfrage zu dem Teilaspekt und in dem Moment denkst du,
um das jetzt aufzulösen, müsste ich über sieben Berge und durch sieben Zwerge
erstmal durch und dann ist es am Ende dem Resultat, eigentlich nicht den Aufwand wert sozusagen.
Und dann habe ich irgendwie diesen Sachverhalt erklärt, wo man so schon innerlich mit den Augen rollt.
Ah ja, um das aufzulösen. Und dann kommt am Ende nur so ein kleiner Pup raus.
Und dann kam ChatGPT was, glaube ich, mit Erklärverschwendung.
Und das fand ich dann auch einen sehr schönen...
Erklärverschwendung?
Ja, du, das wäre eine Erklärverschwendung. Kannst einfach sagen, ist nicht so wichtig.
Aber ja, Erklärverschwendung. Wenn der Aufwand ist zu erklären, dem eigentlichen,
Erklärerat, Erklärprodukt nicht wert ist, sozusagen.
Auch schön.
Okay, also dein Account gibt es noch im Slack?
Ja, ich habe den nicht gelöscht. Ich habe nur Slack irgendwann nicht mehr gehabt.
Achso, du bist da jetzt gar nicht drin.
Ich meine, du kannst über die Webseite auch an dich einfach einloggen.
Meinte ich. Ja, ja, aber dann brauche ich ja meine Credentials irgendwo. Ja, ich gucke gerade.
Kann ich dir denn ein paar... Ne, ich kann auch mal gucken.
Ich habe hier eine Meta-Ebene-Schlacke.
Na, gucke mal. Sowas schmeißt man doch nicht weg.
Ja, und in der Sache gab es halt dann auch mehr oder weniger hilfreiche Rückmeldungen.
Darf ich nochmal kurz zu Pain-Chain? Also Pain-Chain schmerzt mich ein bisschen,
aber Chain of Pain gehe ich mit.
Auch wenn ich finde, dass mein
Desaster-Domino zumindest noch einen Alliterationsbonus verdient hätte.
Aber es reicht offensichtlich nicht, sich hier durchzusetzen.
Aber es ist immerhin auf einem Platz vier. Also jetzt sei mal nicht so traurig.
Nee, traurig bin ich nicht.
Und das Voting läuft ja noch. Zum Ende der Sendung können wir nochmal draufschauen.
Die Telefonleitungen sind noch heiß.
Rufen Sie jetzt die Nummer neben Ihrer Landesflagge an.
Genau, Vibe-Code doch mal was.
Dass hier die Cookies frisch gesetzt werden.
Ja, ich meine, bei solchen Abstimmungen, da sind wir ja wieder in diesem Abstimmungsland,
immerhin hast du ja so ein Multiple-Choice, also man könnte sozusagen für mehrere
Stimmen, aber man könnte halt keinen Preference machen.
Keinen Panaschieren und Faschieren?
Nein.
Keine Prioritäten.
Kumulieren meinst du?
Ach, Kumulieren, sorry.
Ranking, Ranking-Sortierung ist hier nicht drin.
Genau, also so eine Präferenzwahl ist schon was Feines, weil das drückt dann
halt wirklich auch ganz gut aus, was die Leute eigentlich so am liebsten wollen.
Aber es ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass hier High Stakes drin wären.
Ja, wir überlegen, haben wir im Vorfeld ja schon ein bisschen,
ob wir dafür vielleicht auch mal eine vernünftige Infrastruktur für solche Sachen hier aufsetzen.
Ja, da müssen wir alle noch viel besser elixieren können. Aber da dran.
Eine Cop ist das okay.
War es das zu dem Thema?
Naja, inhaltlich kamen halt mehr oder weniger hilfreiche Hinweise noch,
es gab beispielsweise irgendwie so ein paar Stimmen aus der Windows-Fraktion,
die sich dann echauffiert hatten, ja typisch Apple, kein Wunder,
dass es alles nicht funktioniert, das hat mich ein bisschen ratlos gemacht,
mir wäre jetzt also neu dass man jetzt aus irgendeiner Windows- Musik-App heraus
einfach eine Playlist so gebrannt bekommt,
also wenn meine Einschätzung da falsch ist und das auf legalem Wege,
dass ich also mir einen wie auch immer geartete Musik-Streaming-Dienst dort
im Playlist zusammen organisiere und das dann wirklich brennen kann gegen die
Entrichtung eines symbolischen Oboluses,
dann mag ich mir das gerne nochmal rüberwerfen, aber ansonsten ist einfach halt
DRM mal das Problem an der Stelle.
Ja, also mir ist in dem Moment auch gerade nochmal wieder aufgefallen,
dass es natürlich nicht normal ist, dass Leute Files auf ihren Computern haben,
aber ich habe alle meine Musik als File,
bis auf wenige Ausnahmen und deswegen zum Beispiel habe ich letztens einer Freundin
ein Mixtape zum Geburtstag gemacht, ähnliches Problem,
also ein bisschen anders, das könnte man aus einer Streaming-Playlist sogar
eher noch machen, aber...
Mein Hauptanwandlungsfall war halt eine 3-Stunden-Playlist Best of Star Wars.
Und zwar die Williams-Einspielung. Also da lasse ich auch nicht mit mir handeln,
da will ich also jetzt nicht irgendwelche dritt-, viertklassigen Orchester,
sondern ich möchte schon die Original-Einspielung haben.
Und wenn es die legal unter Windows gibt zum, ich brenne das mal eben,
wunderbar, dann werfe das nochmal rüber und ansonsten ist, glaube ich,
der Mac hier nicht das Problem in dieser ganzen Kette.
Dann gab es halt viele Hinweise, ja, du musst doch nur über den AUX-Eingang
hinten gehen, du musst doch nur freischalten.
Das hatte ich ja in der Sendung alles schon thematisiert, das ist mir bewusst,
dass es das auch bei diesem Modell gibt.
Ich hatte aber auch gesagt, dafür musst du halt die Mittelkonsole rausreißen.
Und dann gab es jetzt gerade irgendwie vor einem Tag ein schönes Posting noch
so, ah, das ist alles gar nicht so schwer.
Irgendwie, guck mal hier, bei der C-Klasse geht das doch auch ganz einfach.
Und dann ist es am PDF verlinkt und du machst dieses PDF aus und dann baust
du das halbe Auto auseinander.
Wird dir da schrittweise gesagt, so wie du welche Verkleidung an welcher Stelle
und ja, da muss man ein bisschen mehr ziehen, bis das irgendwie auf geht.
ich nehme ja ganz gerne Dinge auseinander, aber bei meinem Auto habe ich da
so Hemmungen, wenn man da so sein Leben und so, mir ist schon klar,
dass es nicht an der Verkleidung mein Leben hängt, aber trotzdem,
das ist dann irgendwie Elektrik da drunter und weiß der Geier was.
Da würde ich dann schon eher eine Werkstatt fahren.
Und CD brennen macht ja auch Spaß.
Nein.
Ja, also tatsächlich habe ich vor kurzem auch eine CD gebrannt und nur,
also das einzige Hindernis war rauszufinden, ah ja, okay, ich muss jetzt rechtsklicken
auf die Playlist und Burn-to-Disc und dann aber es, ja.
Also meine Chain of Pain hier war halt,
über virtuelles Audio-Device von Ultraschall in Echtzeit abspielen,
aufzeichnen, mit zwei Sekunden Gaps dazwischen eingestellt in iTunes,
automatisches Skript in Ultraschall, was die,
Silence-Geschichten detektiert, dort Marker automatisch setzt und das dann direkt
als Playlist brennen kann, aus Reaper raus. Das geht ja ganz aus Reaper.
Hättest du dir wahrscheinlich für den Stundensatz, den du da investiert hast,
hättest du dir auf Discogs wahrscheinlich für einen Zehner einfach die Original-CDs bestellen können.
Ja, das sind aber schon viele.
Ja, aber hättest du auch alle.
Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass diese... Ja, wohl gut, gut. Ja, maybe.
Ja, weil das mache ich tatsächlich ganz oft, dass ich, wenn ich die Files haben
will und es gibt die halt, weil das Problem an Streaming-Diensten ist, ja.
Du kriegst ja nur die letzte aktuelle Version aus dem Katalog,
die letzte Mastering, das letzte zusammen komprimieren.
Wenn ich jetzt aber ACDC Back in Black 1980 die unkomprimierteste aller Releases
haben will, dann gibt es die nirgendwo in digital.
Dann musst du auf Discogs oder Kleinanzeigen oder sonst wo hingehen.
Du kaufst ja für einen Euro die CD, rippst die und hast Musik,
die sonst keiner in seinem Streamingdienst hören kann.
Oder irgendwelche, ich weiß nicht, ich habe so eine David Bowie CD,
die gibt es nirgendwo im Streaming-Dienst richtig.
Spotify macht ja sowieso ganz große Schweinereien und substituiert irgendwelche
Tracks auf Alben, die da nie drauf waren.
Wo ich auf Studioalben plötzlich Live-Versionen von den Tracks drauf habe.
Ich habe die CD, da ist kein Live-Track an Position 6.
Deswegen, ich kaufe auch tatsächlich immer noch CDs.
Auch zum Beispiel, es gibt eine Band, die ich richtig geil finde,
die haben sich aber später umbenannt und machen jetzt Musik,
die ich nicht so geil finde.
Und bevor sie sich umbenannt haben, haben sie eine EP rausgebracht, auf CD.
Die haben ihre gesamte Existenz vom Internet quasi mehr oder weniger gelöscht,
auf Discogs und auf Wikipedia liest man noch davon, aber du kriegst nirgendwo die Files.
Bin ich auf Discogs gegangen, hab mir die, weil davon gab's nicht so viel,
für 10 Euro die CD gekauft, gerippt und über iTunes oder dieses Apple Music Match,
Habe ich jetzt ja auch überall. Und ja, das ist, also ich bin nicht so ein großer
Streamfreund, da bin ich zu picky für.
Ja, ich sehe den Punkt. Wie gesagt, ich mache es ja mit Vinyl.
Also ich schaue auch schon sehr genau, welche Einspielung und welche Pressung ist.
Und bei Vinyl hatten wir auch in der letzten Sendung dieses ganze Hi-Fi-Thema,
ist natürlich auch alles Fledermausland.
Aber ich will echt keine CDs mehr haben. Also CDs finde ich irgendwie unsexy.
Das mag sich auch nochmal drehen.
Ich rippte ja auch nur in Paxilons ins Regal oder verkauf sie vielleicht irgendwann
auf Discogs weiter, aber...
So, Discogs ist in der Tat nochmal ein guter Hinweis. Hatten wir irgendwann
auch schon mal in der Sendung. Ich hab den Ding nochmal in die Shownotes gepackt.
Discogs.com. Das ist in der Tat eine Datenbank für alles, was jemals an Musik
publiziert worden ist in sämtlichen Pressungen, Einspielungen, Varianten.
Also der wirklich vollständigste Katalog. Und du hast halt gleich eine Börse
dran, wo du sowohl deinen eigenen
Kram verkaufen kannst, als auch halt kommerzielle Händler drauf agieren.
als auch Privatpersonen. Und da hat man auf jeden Fall schon mal einen guten
ersten Eindruck, was ist mein Kram eigentlich wert da draußen in der echten
Welt, wenn ich es also für einen mittleren Preis verkaufen würde und für dich
eine Nachfrage auch wäre. Das ist ja ähnlich wie bei Pokémon-Karten.
Theoretischen Wert und muss ich den aber auch umgesetzt bekommen.
Aber es ist schon mal eine ganz gute Orientierung.
Ich habe da in der Tat meine ganze Venuesammlung rein modelliert.
Es ist immer wieder schön, da mal drauf zu gucken.
Hier vielleicht für dich auch interessant, falls du es noch nicht kennst.
Ja, kenne ich.
Ah ja, okay, ist klar, gut.
Aber erzähl es trotzdem.
Für die HörerInnen, das ist so eine von einem Menschen betriebene Datenbank,
wo man mit einer bestimmten Software Alben oder Tracks auf ihre Dynamic Range
analysieren kann oder in layman's terms, wie komprimiert es ist.
Und da kann man dann halt zum Beispiel eben gucken, okay, welches Release von
dem Album hat die höchste Dynamic Range, wenn man mal hören will,
wie das dann klingt im Vergleich zum aktuellsten platt gemasterten Album.
Release.
Sehr, sehr schön in der Tat. Genau, du hattest noch irgendwas,
Tim, was du zu Audio und Auto noch meintest, was ganz frisch reingekommen ist?
Ja, das ist das, was hier zu sehen ist. Ich habe es auch gerade mal in den Chat reingeworfen.
Ein Produkt, ich weiß nicht, es kann sein, dass es wieder mit deinem Auto nicht
kompatibel ist, wenn ich mir diese Liste so anschaue, aber ich finde,
das Produkt an sich ganz interessant, weil es wird ja verzweifelt versucht,
in irgendeiner Form in diese Autos alles mögliche reinzubekommen,
obwohl die Autos sich so extrem dagegen wehren. Die Variante kannte ich jetzt noch nicht.
Quasi so ein SD-Karten-Leser oder USB-Interface oder halt direkt AUX,
was sich hinten direkt an das Autoradio anschließt, anstatt des CD-Wechslers.
Genau.
Also wenn du sozusagen die Möglichkeit, also sollte zufällig dein CD-Wechsler
über dieses Interface angeschlossen sein, was ja sehr gut sein kann,
dass da nicht so viele unterschiedliche gibt.
Ja, also wenn dein Radio hinten tatsächlich diesen Stecker hat,
dann könntest du einfach das ganze CD-Teil rausschmeißen und durch diesen Apparat
ersetzen, der dir dann sozusagen einfach wirklich MP3-Stick erlaubt.
Hier sind jetzt sehr viele C-Klasse-Fahrzeuge genannt und so weiter,
aber am Ende auch irgendwelche Radios, ich weiß nicht, was du da hast,
hier Becker, hast du nicht gesehen, musst du mal selber mal durchschauen,
aber ich fand das jetzt einfach als Produkt ganz interessant.
Also es gibt Lösungen, das war mir auch vorher klar, ich muss mal gucken,
ob ich quasi von meinem nächsten Autourlaub, halt mir irgendwie mal eine Bastlerbude
hier in Berlin suche, die Bock haben.
Oder einfach einen Bluetooth-Lautsprecher.
Das haben wir schon diskutiert, habe ich ausprobiert, been there,
done that. Klappt nicht.
Die kommen nicht gegen den Innenraumlärm an, weil es ist halt auch noch alt
und Benziner und einfach mal relativ laut, sobald du irgendwie 120 fährst.
Und dann hast du das, was da an Boxen verbaut ist, dagegen mit irgendeiner Boombox anzustinken.
Da musst du schon eine ganz schön Und dann hast du halt die Kinder hinten sitzen,
die hören wieder ganz was anderes als irgendwie du da vorne und wo stellst sie
die hin und Strom und auch alles. Das ist dann so ein Pain.
Ein komplettes Sonoset-up.
Naja, nee, nee.
So, was aber mich total geflasht hat. Vielen, vielen Dank, Herr Frau Kowalski.
Ist ein Dienst, von dem ich dachte, das ist viel zu gut, dass so etwas existieren darf.
Und ich hoffe, dieser Dienst kommt jetzt nicht in Schwierigkeiten,
weil wir ihn jetzt hier mal irgendwie einer breiteren Öffentlichkeit,
vorstellen oder ihr kennt das alles schon. Wir erinnern uns,
eine der CDs, die ich brennen wollte, war Best-of-Computerspiele,
insbesondere so die ganze Nintendo-Welt,
also Zelda-Soundtrack und Pokémon-Soundtrack und dieser ganze Kram und ich habe angeprangert,
dass es das überhaupt nicht irgendwie vernünftig auf CD gibt und in den Streaming-Diensten.
Die Aussage war schon mal grundfalsch.
Das habe ich dann sehr schnell gelernt. Danke auch für die Belehrung.
Nintendo selber hat nämlich einen Musik-Streaming-Dienst, wo die ganzen Teile drin sind.
Hätte mir jetzt aber mein Problem nicht gelöst, weil Streaming komme ich halt
auch wieder an die Datei nicht dran.
Aber es gibt einen Dienst, der heißt Downloads.
Wie heißt das jetzt? K-Insider.com.
K-Insider.com.
K-Insider.com In dieser Datenbank sind sämtliche,
wirklich sämtliche mir bekannten Computerspiele seit den frühen 80ern verzeichnet
mit ihren kompletten Soundtracks zum Abspielen und DRM-frei runterladen.
Und das ist irre, was man da findet. Wenn man sich also ein bisschen für irgendwie
Computerspiele und deren Musik interessiert, wir hatten hier Hülsbeck und so
weiter, alles da, der ganze Kram.
Und zwar auch jeweils mit Angabe, ob sie es quasi gerippt haben,
im Sinne von haben es halt irgendwie abgespielt und dann aufgezeichnet.
In den meisten Fällen ist es aus dem Spiel extrahiert.
Das heißt also, irgendwelche Hacker haben sich drangesetzt und geguckt,
wo sind denn hier eigentlich jetzt die Audio-Files.
Die Legalität dieses Dienstes, da würde ich mal fünf Fragezeichen hinter machen,
habe ich mich jetzt nicht weiter damit beschäftigt, aber es ist irre, was man da findet.
Beispielsweise kennt ihr Loom das Spiel? Ist jemand alt genug hier dafür?
Kann man das hier direkt abspielen?
Das kannst du direkt abspielen.
Probier das mal kurz aus hier. Kommt da was?
Genau, das ist The Legend of Zelda, Ocarina of Time. Das Titeltheme dazu.
Und wird jetzt Frick schon gleich verklagt und wird Copyright strikt.
Genau, müssen wir jetzt schnell drüber sprechen. Gebt mal in die Suche Loom ein. L-O-O-M.
Das ist doch jetzt auch schön, wenn wir es einfach im Hintergrund laufen lassen.
Früher habe ich Podcasts gemacht, wo die ganze Zeit Musik im Hintergrund lief.
Das war eine verdammt schlechte Idee.
Warum nicht mal schlechte Ideen auch wieder hervorholen nach 20 Jahren?
Vielleicht werden sie ja besser.
Wenn der Ockel schon wieder da ist.
Was soll ich suchen?
Loom. L-O-O-M.
Aha, das ist aber nicht Fruit of the Loom.
Nein. So, wir erinnern uns, das ist das vierte Spiel von LucasArts.
Oder LucasFilm hießen sie, glaube ich, damals noch.
Hier gibt es ganz viel Loom.
Genau, da brauchst du die MS-DOS-Windows-Variante. GameRip, genau.
So, wenn ihr das mal abspielt, zum Beispiel die Overtüre.
Ja, dann hören wir aber kein Legend of Zelda mehr.
Das ist korrekt. Okay, gut. Aber es hat einen didaktischen Wert, dass wir jetzt...
Die Overtüre?
Die Overtüre.
Okay, die Overtüre kommt. Moment, drei, zwei, eins. Here we go.
Ich mache wieder ein bisschen lauter. Du hast ja geklaut.
Schwabensee ist das.
Schwabensee ist das, korrekt.
Das hat nicht angefangen.
Der Soundtrack von dem ganzen Spiel ist Schwabensee.
Und du spielst, es geht darum, Schwäne zu retten und du spielst das Spiel mit Noten.
Du musst selber Zaubersprüche in dem
Spiel applizieren und das tust du mit Melodiefolgen auch aus Schwabensee.
völlig irres Spiel, eines der, würde ich sagen, so romantischsten Spiele,
die ich kenne. Das ist das vierte Spiel von...
Schwäne mit Noten abschließen.
Nicht abschießen, sondern... Ja, du musst halt beispielsweise irgendwie die Tür aufmachen.
Und dann musst du halt lernen, ein Lied, eine Melodiefolge, die Türen aufschließt. Statt einen Schlüssel.
Also am Ende ist es ein Point-and-Click-Adventure. So wie halt Maniac Mansion
und Zach McCracken und Secret of Monkey Island.
Nur, dass es halt mit Musik und Melodien funktioniert und so ziemlich alle relevanten
Stücke aus Schwansee sind halt der Soundtrack dieses Spieles und das werden
eben auch so Handlungselemente aufgerufen.
Das, meine lieben Kinder, ist aus einer Zeit, als Computerspiele noch etwas gewagt haben.
Ja, es gibt ja...
So und sowas finde ich hier und da kommen mir ja fast die Tränen.
Ja, ich habe mal die Top 1000, All-Time Top 1000 Soundtracks geklickt und natürlich,
wenig überraschend, ganz oben Minecraft.
Aber auf Platz 3, Legend of Zelda Breath of the Wild.
Und auf Platz 5 Super Mario Brothers.
Zum Beispiel bei Animal Crossing habe ich völlig verzweifelt gesucht den Song, den der Käpt'n spielt.
Der singt immer so stilisierte Sachen und es gibt es einfach nirgendwo vernünftig.
Also ich muss mal sagen, von wegen alte Männer.
Wenn sich hier mit Computerspielmusik von Animal Crossing und anderen bei Laune gehalten wird.
Also da sprudelt ja nur vor Jugendlichkeit.
Aber such zum Beispiel mal Frankie Goes to Hollywood.
Das ist doch uralt.
Such mal Frankie Goes to Hollywood zum Beispiel.
Okay, nee, ich nehme alles zurück.
Das war auch ein Superspiel. Ich glaube auch auf dem Amiga oder gab es das auch schon auf dem C64,
wo halt dann so die bekanntesten Hits von Frankie Goes to Hollywood der Soundtrack
waren und die dann auch sehr das Spiel, da spielt man quasi dann auch so das,
was in den Songs passiert.
Frankie, muss ich gucken. Das
ist mit Sicherheit drin, das würde mich wundern, wenn das nicht drin ist.
Alle sowas ist da vor Ort. Also da kann man Stunden und Tage drin versenken.
Wenn einem hier ist kein Frankie Goes to Hollywood drin. Hollywood gibt es aber kein Frankie.
Da muss ich nochmal gucken.
Muss ich nochmal was hochladen.
Das ist ein Skandal, wenn das da nicht drin wäre.
Also da könnt ihr euch mal tummeln. Danke nochmal.
Aber das ist ja nicht schlecht, dass man hier wirklich mal alles hat.
An einem Ort.
Aber wo kann man denn hier nach Computer gibt es hier keine,
Kategorie? Nach Plattform. Nach Plattform, ja, ich meine, das doch steht ja eh überall dabei.
Also man will doch mal irgendwie, was weiß ich, die C64 oder so, na egal.
Also die Suche könnte besser sein. Das ganze Datenmodell dahinter ist alles etwas zweifelhaft.
Aber wenn man ein bisschen, zum Beispiel The Bard's Tale, hat das einer von euch gespielt?
Mal den ersten The Bard's Tale Teil. Damals auch auf dem Amiga.
Also ja, gab es vorher auf dem PC und auch auf dem C64, aber die Amiga-Version,
würde ich sagen, war die coolste.
Und da war halt das Spielprinzip, das war ein Rollenspiel, du hattest halt eine
Party von irgendwie einem Krieger und einer Diebin und einem Zauberer und eben
ein Barde, hence The Bard's Tale.
Und der Clou dieses Spiels war es, du konntest dem Barden Musik spielen lassen,
die dann quasi einen Zauber-Effekt auf deine Party ausgelassen hat.
Das heißt, du hast selber die ganze Zeit dir den Soundtrack selber spielen lassen von deinem Barden.
Und auch diese einzel kurzen Musik-Loops sind da auch alle drin zu finden und
das ist wirklich so Memory Lane, wenn man das damals wochenlang,
monatelang gespielt hat.
Da denkt man sich, schön, dass so etwas nochmal erhalten ist.
Das müsste ich zum Beispiel hier ins Computerspielmuseum. Kennen die das?
Haben die das? Dürfen die das?
Das wäre eine Superstation für die. Also hier in Berlin gibt es ja das Deutsche
Computerspielmuseum. Wollt ihr das schon mal?
Ja. Die sind jetzt gerade umgezogen, glaube ich.
Nee.
Doch.
Wenn du gerade meinst, vor irgendwie acht Jahren, dann mag das stimmen.
Also ich war da noch vor ein paar Monaten und da waren sie noch da, wo sie immer sind.
Ja, und jetzt sind sie glaube ich umgezogen.
Was?
Das kann gar nicht sein.
Also die haben ausgebaut, die haben sich enorm verbreitert. Aber die sind noch nicht umgezogen.
Guck mal, vielleicht war das ja auch eine Fehlinformation, aber ne,
doch noch kein Max-Aldee. Okay, gut, ich nehme alles zurück.
Zum ersten Mal war ich da wirklich so vor acht Jahren oder sowas.
Da war das alles noch sehr übersichtlich, aber mittlerweile kann man da echt
gut ein paar Stunden rumbringen, wenn sich ohnehin in Berlin ist und ein Computerspiel interessieren.
Das ist definitiv auch ein Adresse, wo man viel Spaß haben kann.
Ich hatte ja, das habe ich gleich schon mal erzählt, aber ich hatte ja so,
als ich mit dem Programmieren angefangen habe, war ja eine meiner ersten Hacker-Disziplinen,
war ja dieses, da hatte ich ein ähnliches Problem wie du.
Wie kriege ich jetzt die Musik zum Abspielen?
Die tolle Musik aus den Computerspielen abspielen.
Und das war ja noch die Zeit, als es keinerlei Möglichkeit gab,
irgendwas digital aufzunehmen oder so. Überhaupt aufzunehmen war schon schwierig.
Ein Tape Deck da dran halten.
Ein Tape Deck von Bildschirmen halten und so weiter. Und das war halt irgendwie nicht the real thing.
Naja, deswegen habe ich dann so meine Assembler-Programmierungskünste daran
geschärft. quasi Programme, also Spiele zu nehmen,
Und die zu disassemblieren und dann die Songroutinen sozusagen zu extrahieren.
Also man behält sozusagen alles bei, was Musik macht und schmeißt den Rest weg
und macht daraus dann so ein neues Standalone-Binary.
Aber mir fällt jetzt einfach ums Verrecken nicht ein, an welchen Spielen ich
mich damals vergangen habe.
Aber wie würde man jetzt sagen, hat dir nicht geschadet.
Dass es mir nicht einfällt?
Nein, aber ich bin überzeugt, durch solche Projekte kommt man halt irgendwie
zu einem gesunden Verhältnis zu Computer.
Du hast halt einfach mal ein Problem und das hat noch keiner gelöst und dann
musst du halt selber ran, weil einer muss den Job ja machen.
Da habe ich einen Link, den ich mal hier in den Chat poste, den musst du nicht
unbedingt gleich abspielen, aber da ist quasi,
zeigt eine Dame, wie sie elektronische Musik mit Code macht und da gibt es halt
so quasi so wie diese Live-Books oder so, wie man irgendwie Daten so live interaktiv
ein bisschen crunchen kann.
hat sie jetzt da so zum Beispiel so eine Drum-Section und du kannst halt interaktiv
noch die Slider von dieser Loop, die die ganze Zeit da austiggert,
beeinflussen. Ich fand es irgendwie auch ganz spannend.
Also das ist jetzt Musik, die ich nicht so unbedingt...
Jetzt hast du es doch mal abgespielt. Ja, das war aber eher Zufall.
Soll ich das trotzdem nochmal machen?
Ja, du kannst es mal kurz so ein bisschen hören und sehen, wird es klar.
Ja, muss man wieder lauter machen.
Du hast Witz.
Du siehst halt, Welche Elemente da jeweils immer aktiv sind.
Ich habe immer die gleichen Komponenten in allen.
Es gibt immer eine Drum-Section, immer eine.
Meinen Mouse-Movements, das ist sehr hilfreich, wenn ich live performe.
Für Samples, ich sie entweder oder ich sie auf Github.
So hier ist ein Sample von Github, das ich einfach habe. Das ist halt so ein
Slider da mit drin im Code.
Ja, eine schöne Roland-Tea 808, so muss das. Sehr fein.
Ist ja irre.
Ja, das ist wirklich sehr, sehr cool.
Also es ist auch wirklich advanced, so gleich Sidechain mit drin,
EQ, alles. Ich bin so hard, so bring in some more drums.
Ich bin so hard.
So bring in some more drums.
Und halt auch irgendwie eine geile Visualisierung, fände ich so für dieses Format
halt. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Irre. Also das ist halt alles, wir müssen das mal kurz ein bisschen in die Köpfe visualisieren.
Also man blickt eigentlich mehr oder weniger auf Code, so.
Wobei, wenn es so richtig verschieden ist, jede Sektion ist so eine eigene Spur.
und die besteht dann eben aus verschiedensten Parametern, die dann so explizit angegeben sind.
Punkt Sustain, Punkt Detune, Punkt Gain, Punkt Mask mit irgendwelchen Werten
und teilweise auch mit so Berechnungen.
Und nicht nur, dass man da Werte eingeben kann mit der Tastatur,
sondern sie steuert das dann auch noch mit der Maus direkt auf dem Code und
so und dann laufen halt irgendwie auch noch kleine Visualisierungen von den Loops. Das ist ja crazy.
Schön, was Menschen so machen.
Wer ist denn das?
Mir ist das nur auf Mastodon vorbei gescrollt und dachte mir da mal ein Sternchen
dran, damit ich das genau in solchen Momenten schnell wiederfinde.
Ein Computational Notebook, nennt sie das?
Ist das das hier, was die im Chat hier auch gepostet haben, das Strudel-Rappel?
Weiß ich nicht, ob es das ist. Ist es das? I believe she's using Strudel.
Aha.
Strudel, Strudel, Strudel. Ja, Scheinstrudel. Jetzt Strudel.
Okay. Strudel ist also das, was sie verwendet.
Strudel.cc. Also Strudel wie Apfelstrudel. Ah, und da kann man das dann alles selber machen.
Hier, TR909. Und wenn ich jetzt auf Play drücke.
Also sprich, man könnte sich das als Copy and Pasten und dann...
Guck, da ist jetzt hier...
Das ist eine 909.
Ja. Wenn ich jetzt hier nicht 909, sondern 808 mache, klingt das dann anders?
Musst du vielleicht da updaten.
Oder ist die MIDI-Belegung deine andere? Dann kannst du auch so einen 303-Gefriebser.
Ich hab doch schon Talent, oder?
Kram ja auch in Hardware. Dann machen wir eben eine Gems-Session.
Okay. Interessant.
A live, was stand da bei Welcome? Vielleicht kann man was für die Hörer.
A live coding platform to write dynamic music pieces in the browser.
It's free, open source and made for beginners and experts alike.
Na wie schön. Ja.
Ist eine JavaScript-Version von Tidal Cycles.
Which is a popular live coding language for music written in Haskell.
Okay, okay. Alright.
Okay,
dann müssen wir das aber auch noch mal Monadenbasierte Musik Live coding music
with algorithmic patterns.
Da haben sie auch eine Visualisierung drin.
Psychedelisch. Ja, das könnte ich, das gefällt mir.
Wenn du da mit dem Karawanen auf dem Festival sitzt und deinen eigenen Floor
mal mit einem gescherten Pad irgendwie.
Aber das ist überhaupt das erste Mal, dass ich ein cooles Projekt sehe,
was in der Eskel probiert ist. Das ist auch die Universität normalerweise.
Und dazu gibt es ja dann auch noch, wenn du noch Visuals, also so VJ-mäßig,
ich weiß nicht, wie hieß das?
Ich muss das kurz mal in meinen Chat-Nachrichten wiederfinden.
Der Simon aus dem CCC, der hat ja hier kürzlich so eine Vernissage in Berlin
gemacht, im Parkhaus. Warst du da?
Nee, ich hab was von nichts.
Das war geil. So ein West-Berliner Parkhaus. So die Tiefgaragen halt irgendwie
bespielt mit Kunst und er hatte da auch so eine visuelle Geschichte. Genau, Faust war das.
Ich packe auch noch mal den Link da rein. Allerdings da, weiß ich nicht,
ob ich jetzt so spontane Demo dafür habe, aber Faust ist Functional Audio Stream.
Warte, wo geht der Chat rein? Da, beng. Er meinte irgendwie,
dass das auch total abgeht und cool ist und so.
Also für die Vollständigkeit halber würde ich das ja auch mal reinpasten,
aber da habe ich weniger Plan, was da eigentlich geht.
Functional Audio Stream, Functional Programming Language for Sound Synthesis
and Audio Processing with a strong focus on the design of synthesizers,
musical instruments, audio effects, etc.
Ja, davon habe ich schon mal gehört. Das ist, genau, damit programmierst du
tatsächlich richtig die Effekte.
Das ist so richtig low level und geht so richtig...
Wide Range C++, C, LLVM, WebAssembly, Rust.
In Reaper macht man das ja mit IL-2. Das ist da die Effektsprache.
Auch so ganz unten auf dem Blech.
Ganz unten auf dem Blech. Auf dem Kuchenblech?
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ein interessantes Feld.
Weil ich meine, letzten Endes kann man jetzt eben mit dem Computer mittlerweile,
mit der Performance, die diese Maschinen haben,
einfach Sachen machen, die bis vor kurzem einfach noch Synthesizern,
also Hardwaregeräten und vor allem analogen Synthesizern vorbehalten waren.
Und während es natürlich digitale Synthesizer gibt,
die dies und das machen, ist natürlich der Computer als Universalmaschine da
einfach perfekt, wenn man den ja auch noch so programmieren kann,
dann auch mit solchen User-Interfaces dafür oder mit solchen Programming-Interfaces dafür.
dann wird es echt sportlich.
Wenn euch dieses Thema interessieren sollte, dann meldet euch mal.
Da hätte ich nämlich ein bisschen was an Hard- und Software,
was man mal in einer zukünftigen Sendung mal live machen könnte.
So, Virtualisierung klassischer Synthesizer. Das alles, was Rang und Namen hat
und wahnsinnig teuer ist.
In was für eine Qualität das heutzutage geht. Da habe ich ein bisschen was. Rumzustehen.
An Geräten, die du verschenken willst oder was?
Wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe da mal viel Geld drauf geworfen in so eine Synthesizer-Virtualisierungs-Suite.
Wo du also halt vom DX7, die ganze Emulator-Reihe, Vocoder, Fairlight,
Synclavier, also das, worauf so die relevante Musik in den 80ern vor allen Dingen gemacht worden ist.
Wo du die alle bis zum letzten Knopf und bis zum letzten Analogfilter nachmodelliert hast.
Und nicht so ein bisschen so, wir tun so als ob, sondern wirklich so mit dem
selben User-Interface.
Du redest jetzt von einer Hardware?
Ich rede von Software.
Von Software.
Ich habe auch Hardware, ein bisschen was.
Aber welche Software ist denn das, die das macht? Wenn du das jetzt schon erwähnst?
Ja, jetzt. Ich habe die schon lange nicht mehr hochgefahren.
Jetzt muss ich gleich mal gucken.
Red mal kurz weiter, ich schmeiße es gleich rein.
Na gut, ja, Koden-Audio, super toll. Ich mache das aber auch immer noch nicht, außer...
Ich klicke immer noch Musik mit der Maus.
Ja, ich finde ja so funktionale Sachen ganz gut. Ich meine, wir hatten hier
in der letzten Sendung, habe ich ja von unserer Blink-Lights-Variante dieses
Jahres berichtet, die so ein bisschen gescheitert ist und neue User-Interface-Ideen überlegt,
wo man ja quasi die Bildschirme im Kreis hat und dann das Movement der Leute erfassen will.
So Arturia ist das.
Was ja nochmal sozusagen so ein eigenes Problem ist, so Menschen zu tracken.
Da kamen auch einige gute Hinweise.
Vielen Dank für die ganzen Kommentare.
Ein, zwei Sachen werde ich da auf jeden Fall auch nochmal verfolgen.
Aber unabhängig davon, wenn man das Ganze noch mit Musik begleiten will,
dann bist du ja sofort auch in diesem generativen Bereich.
Also sowohl visuell als eben auch mit Audio.
Und da sind natürlich dann solche Systeme unter Umständen ein ganz guter Einstieg,
weil du dann eben mit so Building Blocks schon mal ganz brauchbare Sachen machen
kannst, die du auf jeder Ebene parametrisieren kannst.
Auf welcher Ebene man sie dann parametrisiert, da brauchst du dann vielleicht
doch mal jemand, der Ahnung von Audio hat.
Aber gut, dass es schon mal solche Backbones gibt und man das nicht alles komplett selber machen muss.
Ja.
So, jetzt noch mal Arturio.
Arturia ist einfach ein Softwarehersteller und die haben unter anderem so die
besten, also einige Plugins, die so echte Audio-Hardware emulieren.
Runterscrollen, du musst runterscrollen.
Und die haben halt auch ein Synthesizer-Bundle,
wo sie wirklich so einmal alles, was Rang und Namen hat und auch ihre eigenen
Produkte einmal als Plug-in oder innerhalb dieser virtuellen Synthesizer-Suite
zur Verfügung gestellt haben.
Und ab und zu gibt es auch einen Sale, wo man die zum halben Preis kriegt, wo ich die gekauft habe.
Ich habe eine gebrauchte auf dem Zweitmarkt hier stand, was die enforcen,
dass man das machen darf, dass du deine Lizenzen weitergibst.
Und man muss gleich dazu sagen, für die ganze Hardware, die die da modellieren,
der Preis, der regulär ist jetzt auch nicht sündhaft teuer, das sind irgendwie
ein paar hundert Euro oder so, also jetzt unter tausend, weit unter tausend.
aber ich glaube im Sommer habe ich es für 299 oder so irgendwas unter 300 bekommen
und die sind wirklich sehr gut, also nicht nur deren Audio-Effekt-Plugins,
also irgendwelche Kompressoren oder so,
sondern die Synthesizer sind auch allesamt wirklich ziemlich cool,
bis zu dem Punkt wo, die haben halt ihre eigenen Synthesizer die bauen auch
Hardware-Synthesizer und die sind auch richtig cool, also die haben wirklich,
das sind so oft Hybrid-Synthesizer und die haben schon coole Ideen und Features,
aber dann hast du das Plugin, was alles kann und alles digital und klickbar
ist und presetable, dann...
Weiß ich auch gar nicht, wozu ich noch die Hardware brauche,
wobei ich auch von denen den Mikrofreak rumstehen habe.
Das könnte man in der Tat mal eine Sendung drum bauen. Dann ratet oder erinnert
ihr euch, in welchem bekannten Song dieser Sound gerade vorkam?
Wenn man sowas hier hat, wie ein Arp 2600, das ist dann halt so Jean-Michel
Jarre, Oxygen, das Meeresrauschen.
Hörst du sofort. Naja.
Woher ist denn der Laden?
Ich glaube Frankreich oder Italien, eins von beiden.
Ich versuche gerade hier irgendwie die Information rauszuziehen,
aber viele französische Namen.
Die Webseite war so überzeugend deutsch, dass ich erst dachte,
das wäre ein deutsches Projekt.
Nee, nee, die sind Frankreich oder Italien, ich weiß nicht mehr genau.
Es sieht mir sowohl nach Frankreich als auch Italien aus.
Und für mich war die Einstiegsdroge, die haben halt ein günstiges,
brauchbares MIDI-Keyboard so in verschiedenen Größenklassen.
Ich wollte halt irgendwas Kleines haben, was man irgendwie schnell irgendwo
mitnehmen kann und da ist dann halt eine Testversion von dieser Suite mit dabei.
Normalerweise installiere ich so ein Kram nie. Aber in dem Fall hatte ich mir
so, ja Gott, hast gerade nichts zu tun.
Und dann hast du plötzlich diese Sounds im Ohr und denkst so,
oh fuck. Und dann guckst du, wie viel habt ihr da jetzt drin?
200 Sounds. Oh, die probiere ich jetzt alle aus.
Die sind halt alle geil, aber es sind dann auch nur diese 200 und dann,
du kannst auch nicht alle Parameter verändern und dann siehst du halt den Preis,
was das Gesamtpaket kostet und denkst du so, oh, aber irgendwann ist man dann halt weichgekocht.
Okay, den Laden gibt es offensichtlich schon seit über 20 Jahren und sie haben
Offices in Grenoble, in Kalifornien, in Mexiko City, in Hongkong und in London.
Ja, die sind auf jeden Fall mittlerweile ganz groß, aber es ist auf jeden Fall
einer der wenigen so Audio Hardware als auch Softwarehersteller,
wo ich beide Kategorien von Produkten tatsächlich bisher immer gut fand.
Also die haben auch ihre Produktfehlschläge schon gehabt, aber so im Großen und Ganzen gebaren.
Also vor allen Dingen dieser Microfreak, der kleine Synthesizer,
der vieles kann, der hat noch Jahre nach der Veröffentlichung Software-Updates
bekommen, wo tausende neue Features reingeballert wurden.
Wurde wirklich bei anderen Herstellern lange bis gar nicht drauf warten kannst,
dass die überhaupt mal noch ein Update oder irgendwas raushauen.
Also die sind auf jeden Fall ganz gut am Ball, sagen wir mal so.
Also ich check eins jetzt noch nicht. Die machen ganz viel Software,
aber die machen auch Hardware?
Ja.
Also es gibt Hardwares, aber man braucht deren Hardware-Synthesizer,
um die Software laufen zu lassen?
Nee, das ist wirklich entkoppelt. Also die haben auch ihre eigenen Hardware-Synthesizer
quasi virtualisiert, sodass du die auch nur in Software betreiben kannst.
Und sie haben halt auch reine MIDI-Controller-Keyboards. Das ist das,
was ich mir damals gekauft habe. 99 Euro ist dieses Minilab 3.
Link dazu in den Shownotes und da ist halt diese Testversion drin und das ist
also für 99 Euro, schöner Formfaktor, kann man halt schnell irgendwie durch die Gegend schleppen.
Und da kann man das mal ausprobieren.
Zum Beispiel das Glitterbrains Intro wird immer live auf einem Microfreak gespielt.
Sehr gut.
Minifreak.
Microfreak. Ich habe den Microfreak.
Ah, Microfreak. Stellar Edition.
Die Thomann Edition. Thomann hat eine Special Edition davon.
Die ist, finde ich, die allerschickste. Aber ich habe meinen Gebrauch gekauft.
Da muss ich mit dem Default Antlitz leben.
Sieht ja fancy aus, das Teil.
Ja, die haben wirklich, also das ist jetzt zu viel für die Sendung, aber die Features,
wie die so diese Hybrid-Geschichten konzeptionell gemacht haben und deren virtuelle
Patch-Bay und so, das ist erstaunlich gut, fand ich so,
weil ganz oft sind so die User-Interfaces von Hardware-Synthesizer eigentlich
immer totales Gräuel und Menu-Diving und hast du nicht gesehen.
und die haben es irgendwie geschafft, das sehr haptisch zu halten und verständlich.
Also jedes Preset, was du so auswählst, sieht man dann auch,
also man sieht die Konfiguration auch live auf dem Board sozusagen.
Man muss nicht durch tausende Menüs diven, um dann rauszufinden,
was ist denn da jetzt eigentlich Basis. Und ja.
Okay, erstaunlich.
Und ich meine, Kritiker würden jetzt sagen, gerade der Micro Freak klingt halt
auch etwas digital und clean oder klinisch.
Ist halt kein analoger Sünder, sei es kein vollständiger, deswegen ja,
aber das mache ich dann im Nachhinein noch so ein paar Post-Effekts,
dass da noch ein bisschen...
Und ob das dann im Mix überhaupt noch irgendjemand auch die entfernteste Chance
hat, dann noch rauszuhören.
Ja, also die Leute wissen wirklich, was sie tun. Vor denen habe ich einen ziemlichen
Respekt. Das ist wild, was die machen.
Und du hast dann halt Hardware-Synthesizer im Wert von einer Million dann da
stehen auf deinem Laptop.
Das ist schon, du kriegst den Kram ja auch einfach teilweise überhaupt gar nicht mehr. Schön, schön.
So, womit machen wir weiter? Wollen wir im Audioland bleiben?
Was denn?
Keine Ahnung, du hast ja noch hier so ein Audio-Thema.
Vielleicht machen wir mal ganz kurz, ich versuche es kurz zu halten,
weil wir haben ja wirklich noch schärfere Themen.
Aber haben Sie sich schon mal mit RME beschäftigt?
Also ich muss, ich sage mal nur ganz kurz, ich habe mit Universal Audio Interfaces
lange Zeit jetzt rumhandiert zu Hause und auch im Proberaum.
Ich dachte, ich hätte fand es gut mit den Effekten und Plugins,
die so DSP-beschleunigt sind ohne Latenz und so weiter und irgendwie ja,
Universal Audio hat auch so seinen Ruf und benutzen ganz viele.
Hat mich aber am Ende vollends genervt, weil deren User Interface und gesamte
Denkweise ist auf Konsolen ausgerichtet.
Leute, die früher an einer Mixing-Konsole saßen, finden auch Universal Audio, UIs und so intuitiv.
Wenn man aber aus so einer Computerwelt kommt, wie du und ich und du und ich
und du und du und wir. Wir alle, wir da draußen.
Dann will man ja einfach, dann weiß man ja, wir haben ja Software gemacht,
damit man nicht von Hardware beschränkt wird in dem, was man mit diesen Daten
und diesen Bits und so so machen kann und wo man die hinlenken kann.
Nicht, dass uns die Hardware nicht trotzdem noch beschränkt wird.
Und dann habe ich halt die ganze Zeit immer schon so mit so einem Auge auf RME
geschielt, nicht nur, weil ich das ein paar Mal schon in Studios gesehen habe,
sondern Sondern weil mir immer mal wieder gesagt wurde, Tim,
ja, bring mal noch so eine Runde mit.
Drei Bierchen, bitte.
Weil mir immer mal wieder gesagt wird, dass deren Mixer-Software das ultimative
Stück Software ist, wenn ich genau das will.
Die volle Kontrolle, welches Signal geht auf welchen Port, wann,
wie oft kopiert, wie viele unterschiedliche Level, wie viele unterschiedliche Submixe etc.
You name it. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, ich habe da gerade so ein bisschen
Geld übrig von so einer Rechnung, die ich schreiben durfte, von der ich nicht
wusste, dass sich die Möglichkeit bietet.
Und bevor das ganze Geld zum Finanzamt kommt, gebe ich es doch lieber dem Thomann, dachte ich.
habe mein Universal Audio Interface verhökert für noch einen ganz guten Preis,
weil es auch noch nicht so wahnsinnig alt war und habe mir so ein Fireface,
UFX3 gekauft, was gerade zu dem Zeitpunkt frisch raus war und ja, seitdem, ich glaube.
Hast du das Licht nicht nur gesehen, sondern auch gehört?
Ja, und zwar, der Clou ist, also die Hardware ist sehr geil,
aber man kriegt ähnliches von anderen Firmen grundsätzlich, also so die Pre-Amp
sind jetzt nicht Größenordnung besser und so.
Zwei Sachen stehen für mich so bei denen heraus, abgesehen, dass sie wirklich gut gebaut sind.
Die Treiber in Anführungsstrichen sind ganz vorne mit dabei.
Also die sind die ersten, die eine neue Version rausbringen,
wenn macOS auch nur den kleinsten Fitzel ändert, zum Beispiel als diese Umstellung
kam, dass sie keine Kernel-Extensions mehr haben wollen, sondern nur noch Driver-Kit.
RME gibt dir einen Driver-Kit-Driver und der hat genau dieselbe vernachlässigbare
Latenz wie der Kernel-Extension-Driver.
Die updaten wirklich regelmäßig und ich hatte noch nie dieses,
ich kann das jetzt nicht benutzen oder kann ich updaten.
Ja, Klassiker.
Zudem, ich glaube, meins kannst du auch als Klaas, wie heißt das,
Klaas Audio-Dings, also wenn du keinen Treiber installierst,
hast du trotzdem noch Signal-Anliegen sozusagen.
Und die sind ja mit USB angeschlossen, aber ich weiß nicht, was die machen.
Du hast einfach keine Latenz fast.
Hast du mal gemessen?
Es sind einstellig Millisekunden.
Ja gut, davon will man wohl rausgehen. Wie einstellig?
Weiß nicht, 4, 5?
Also ab sechs beginnt es zu schmerzen.
Also ich merke auf jeden Fall nichts davon. Also im Reaper steht vier bis fünf
oder so, aber es ist einfach kein Problem sozusagen.
Also nicht, dass man jetzt denkt, ich brauche jetzt unbedingt ein Thunderbolt-Interface.
War ich ja auch so, jetzt hatte ich hier mein Universal Audio,
war ja ein Thunderbolt-Interface.
Das ist jetzt halt USB 3, aber es ist schneller, also es hat weniger Latenz
als das Universal Audio auf Thunderbolt. Insofern, whatever.
Und der absolute Star für mich ist halt deren Mixer, deren Software-Mixer, Total Mix heißt es.
Und es gibt die Leute, die aus dieser Konsolenwelt kommen, so mit Federn und
Bussen und so weiter, die hassen das.
Und Leute wie ich, die sagen, ich will Signale routen, egal wohin,
egal ob das, ich mach mir einen Bass, wenn ich einen Bass brauche,
lass mich in Ruhe mit Bassen.
Ich will Signale routen, duplizieren, N-1, was auch immer.
und da geht dir das Ding halt wirklich maximal aus dem Weg, wenn man mal einmal
so das Konzept verstanden hat, wie sie sich das gedacht haben und,
Ich brauche jetzt keine Zusatzsoftware mehr, keine Special Tricks irgendwie,
um alle meine Routing-Wünsche zu realisieren.
Und das hat mich jetzt zu einem überzeugten RME-Fanboy gemacht und weswegen ich dann gedacht habe,
jeder, der irgendwas mit Streaming oder Streaming und Recording macht,
eigentlich ist das so die optimale Lösung, weil du hast wirklich alles in einem Blog drin.
Und ich hatte noch so ein Universal Audio Apollo für unterwegs oder wenn ich
mal in den Proberaum gehe.
Nicht ein Apollo, ein Twin heißt das irgendwie, so ein kleines Ding.
Und das habe ich dann auch verkauft und habe mir von RME noch ein Babyface Pro auch gekauft.
Auch nicht ganz billig, aber das Geile ist, das hat auch dieses Total Mix und
im Prinzip die ganzen anderen Features, die ich gerade erwähnt habe und ist schön und kompakt.
Und das hatte ich zum Beispiel jetzt auf meiner Workation dabei als Podcasting
und Videocall-Interface.
Babyface.
Jetzt müssen wir, glaube ich, aber doch auch nochmal reinwerfen,
was denn so die Strafgebühr ist dafür.
Also jetzt hier der Tumann, sagt er, im E-Fireface 2399.
Aber das Universal Audio war jetzt...
Zuck zuckt man schon so ein bisschen.
Ist schon eine Hausnummer, aber das Ding wird jetzt wahrscheinlich die nächsten
10 Jahre einfach mal im Rack bleiben.
Das ist alles Thunderbolt.
Ne, alles USB.
Ja, USB.
USB. Kein Thunderbolt.
Welches USB 3?
Ja, guck mal, hier bei Tech Specs steht bestimmt auch gleich ganz oben da.
USB 3, Class Compliant steht hier.
Also das war auch so mein größter so Augenbrauen, so will ich das,
aber wie gesagt, alle Leute, die,
also ich habe mir natürlich vorher viel Videos so von Studio-Leuten und so auch
angeguckt, was die dazu meinten und alle haben gesagt, das sind die besten Driver,
die sie jemals hatten und ja, funktioniert.
Das Schöne ist halt auch, RMI macht ja auch so richtig krasse Zwischenharten,
wenn du nochmal auf die Webseite gehst, bei Produkte.
Die haben ja auch so ganz viele Wandler, so von Mardi auf dies,
von Dante auf das und auch so ganz kleine Kisten, die so alles mögliche an digitalen
Audio in verschiedene Bahnen lenken.
Da kann man sich auf jeden Fall auch sehr auszumachen.
Wenn du dir so mal Videos anguckst, wie Leute sich Studios damit ausrüsten,
wenn die dann halt irgendwie 64 Kanäle oder mehr brauchen und dann die Units
da zusammen klöppeln, das ist ein bisschen so Audio-Engineer-Porn,
aber für mich irrelevant.
Also ich bin jetzt schon total drüber mit dem Fireface und dem Babyface und
dann habe ich mir natürlich auch noch die Fernbedienung dafür besorgt,
damit ich schön alles auf dem Schreibtisch handläufig habe.
Aber ja, ich sage nur so viel einfach,
wenn ihr mal nach einem Profigerät schaut und die volle Mixfreiheit haben wollt,
ich kann es empfehlen. Ich finde es sehr geil.
Ich habe bisher noch keinen Software-Audio-Interface-Mixer gesehen,
der flexibler war und mehr konnte. Das ist halt alles so FPGA-getrieben auf der Hardware und ja.
Also ich hatte früher mal mit einem eben ein bisschen rumgespielt, das war schon ewig her.
Da hat es damals für mich irgendwie nichts getan. Was ist denn das hier für?
Das ist einfach adert.
Ja genau, du kannst halt deine ganzen Adert-Devices dran stellen und kriegst
dann über USB halt alle, was weiß ich, wie viel 100 oder 64 oder was Kanäle?
66. Auf 192 Kilohertz.
Ja okay, das hatten die früher nicht, die ganzen Adopter, das ist echt interessant. Okay.
Das wäre mein Audio-Beitrag schon gewesen, weil,
ja, hat mich einfach, ich hatte es einfach satt, so mit diesem N-1 oder allen
möglichen, alles so, was so vom Trampelfahrt abweicht, an Audio-Routing immer
rumhühnern zu müssen und ja,
das Schöne ist halt, was ich jetzt zum Beispiel für,
manche Streaming-Szenarien mache, ich mache mir jetzt ein virtuelles Audio-Interface
hier über Audio-Midi-Settings,
und setze da quasi die Default-Speaker, die sonst immer auf 1 und 2,
die folten halt auf andere Kanäle.
Habt ihr dann sozusagen auf einen extra Fader in diesem Total Mix und rute die
da lustig umher auf die Outputs, die ich haben will.
Und ja, es funktioniert alles. So das erste Mal irgendwie, dass so auch das
Mac OS sich irgendwie erwartbar mit diesem Audio-Interface irgendwie unterhält.
Also gibt sicherlich auch andere, aber zumindest das Universal Audio war nicht in dieser Kategorie.
obwohl es ähnlich viel gekostet hat und immer mit den Treibern hinterher hing
und erst vor wenigen Monaten das mit diesem Arm mit diesem,
Apple Silicon so richtig verstanden hat und so,
Naja,
So
Ralf.
Möchtest du was thematisieren? Ich habe heute keine Themen mitgebracht Ich kommentiere alles nur.
Ich habe mich in den letzten zwei Wochen absolut monothematisch verhalten und
habe keinerlei neue Informationen, die hier irgendwie groß helfen könnten.
Vielleicht mit einer Ausnahme.
Ja, wir haben ein bisschen was mitgebracht. Das Wir ist jetzt nicht das Pluralis
Majestatis oder wie hieß das damals,
sondern Huckel und ich haben in der Tat so einen ganz losen Chatkanal,
wo wir uns ab und zu Dinge rüberwerfen und diese Dinge haben monothematisch
nur mit einem einzigen Thema zu tun und das sind Messer.
Wir erinnern uns, ich hatte das schon mal angeteasert vor zwei Sendungen,
wo wir unsere große Tierlist der Single-Purpose-Geräte für die Küche hatten.
Das ist sozusagen der Chat der langen Messer.
Dass das Thema Messer mich umtreibt seit vielen, vielen Jahren.
Und da dachte ich, was kann besser sein als in einem Audio-Podcast?
Ich habe versucht, ihm auszureden.
Ted. mal Dinge zu zerschnippeln, weil ich glaube, also der erste Instinkt ist,
was immer ihr jetzt vorhabt mit Messern, das müsst ihr doch auf YouTube machen,
damit man es auch irgendwie sieht.
Willst du jetzt hier physische Experimente?
Wir werden gleich physische Experimente machen.
Ich habe einen ganzen Rucksack voll Stuff dabei. Ich kann ja nur mal kurz meine
Perspektive dazu, zu dem Thema, wie ich da reingerutscht bin.
Es war Covid, man hat viel gekocht.
Ich dachte mir, hm, irgendwie war die Messer auch schon mal schärfer.
Mal auf YouTube geguckt, wie schärfe ich dein Messer selber,
weil ich jetzt nicht zu so einem Schärfonkel gehen wollte, sondern wollte natürlich
wissen, wie man selber seine Küchenmesser schärft.
Hab dann einen Nerd-typischen Deep Dive veranstaltet, bin zu diversen Zwischenlösungen
gekommen, um dann bei der Lösung anzukommen, die ich dann auch Ralf versucht
habe, schon frühzeitig mitzuteilen.
Aber wie das bei Nerds so ist, muss man ja...
Die glauben ja erstmal nicht.
Genau, muss man bestimmte Wege auch erstmal selber abtrampeln.
Ich packe gerade die Tomaten aus.
Ja, sehr schön. Und als es darum ging, dass ich vielleicht mal wieder in der
Freakshow zu Gast sein könnte,
dann kam Ralf direkt um die Ecke mit der Frage, ob wir dann jetzt mal diese
Sache besprechen wollen.
Und für mich ist es tatsächlich auch interessant, weil, wie Ralf schon sagt,
wir haben uns da schon ein paar Mal drüber ausgetauscht und ich Ich habe ihm
dann irgendwann gesagt, als er sozusagen auf einer Stufe war, wo ich auch schon war,
das ist das, was für mich funktioniert, hier ein paar Links und so weiter.
Und dann habe ich erst mal nichts weiter gehört.
Und was ich jetzt auch hier sehe auf dem Tisch, bin ich sehr gespannt,
ob denn das auch irgendwie ähnliche Erfahrungen ergeben hat oder ob er irgendwie
nochmal was anderes gefunden hat.
Genau, also...
Hast du eine Geschichte zum Messer, Tim, oder haben bisher in deinem Leben keine
signifikante Rolle gespielt? Das ist eine ernst gemeinte Frage.
Also ich erkenne an, dass man gute Messer braucht.
Man kann das natürlich wie immer auch alles total übertreiben,
aber ich finde, schlechte Messer zu haben, ist ein Zeichen eines schlechten Charakters.
Also so Messer, die so rumwabbeln oder sich fast schon wie Blech anfühlen.
Ich finde, man muss auch große Messer haben. Also ich bin jetzt nicht der totale
Messerfetischist, aber ich bestehe darauf, dass eine Küche auf jeden Fall mindestens
ein ordentliches Kochmesser hat.
Also so ein Kochmesser, das muss schon sein und ich würde sogar noch einen Schritt
weiter gehen und da bin ich der, da habe ich leider gerade einen kleinen Fehlkauf gemacht.
Tatsächlich gibt es noch Fehlkaufpunkt bis?
Es gibt bald neue Stickerleinen ab und Fehlkauf, Flatterband und alles.
Ja, weil ich ja gerade eine Wohnung neu einzurichten hatte und dann habe ich
mich für WMF-Kram entschieden, weil ich den generell eigentlich sehr gut finde
und habe dann auch da einfach mal zu so einem Messerpaket zugegriffen.
Was allerdings etwas enttäuschend war, war das Brotmesser.
Und ich hatte vorher hier in so einem Spezi-Messerladen, den es jetzt leider
hier im Prinzlauer Berg nicht mehr gibt, der ist irgendwie aufgelöst,
hatte ich tatsächlich mal wirklich ein fettes Brotmesser gekauft. Das war das schwerste.
Das Güde-Brot-Schwert.
Das Güde, genau.
Das Güde, das hatte ich. Und vielleicht sollte ich mir das auch nochmal holen,
weil das WMF-Ding, was ich da jetzt gekauft habe, das ist ehrlich gesagt ein Witz.
Also ein Brotmesser, also wenn euer Brotmesser, wenn es sich leicht in die Hand
nehmen lässt, also weg damit, genau.
Also das muss einfach schon eine gewisse Schwere haben, so genau.
Da endet dann so ein bisschen mein Nerdtum auch.
Aber… Tim, eine Frage zu deinem Messerstand, zu deinem aktuellen Level.
Ja.
Drückst du noch oder schneidest du schon?
Also, nee, anders gefragt. Wenn du Zwiebeln schneidest, kommen dir Tränen in die Augen?
Sind deine Tomatenscheiben, haben sie eine Mindestdicke, weil dünner geht einfach nicht, weil dann...
Also ich habe jetzt schon länger keine Tomaten mehr geschnitten, aber bei Zwiebeln...
Wenn es neue Messer sind, sollten die von WMF noch scharf genug sein.
Ja, schmerzt nichts. Nee, tatsächlich interessanter Aspekt, habe ich mir vorher nachgedacht.
Aber Tränen in den Augen ist ein Zeichen von stumpfen Messern.
Ja, okay, verstehe.
Ich habe ein bisschen eine Dramaturgie überlegt im Vorfeld. Und da kommen wir
in der Tat auch noch zu, warum überhaupt scharfe Messer.
Kurze Fußnote, es soll glaube ich jetzt heute gar nicht groß um die Messer gehen,
sondern um das Messerschärfen. Aber das, was Tim gerade gesagt hat bezüglich Brotmesser.
Also ich glaube, man kann mit vielen Messern glücklich werden auf der Welt.
Aber beim Thema Brotmesser kann es keine zwei Meinungen geben.
Es muss das Güde-Brot-Schwert sein.
Oh Gott, das fackt drin hier aus.
Die Metaebene hat sich mittlerweile in eine formidable Schmiede verwandelt.
In eine schärfe...
Das ist ja scharf.
So, aber kurz meine Geschichte, weil meine Messergeschichte reicht in der Tat, 45 Jahre zurück.
Nämlich mit meiner Mutter, die gesagt hat, da war ich glaube ich so zwölf,
Junge, du wirst keine Frau mehr finden, die noch für dich kocht. Lern es selber.
Das war ein sehr schlauer Spruch von ihr. Der war in der Sache Grund falsch.
Ich war danach nur mit Frauen zusammen, die hervorragend gekocht haben.
Aber es hat mir kein Stück geschadet. Und ich habe dann also eben kochen gelernt.
Und natürlich, das war eine Zeit, da gab es kein YouTube, da gab es auch noch keine Kochsendungen.
Also wir sprechen ja so von den mittelachtziger Jahren. Da gab es ARD und ZDF
und sonst gar nichts an Fernsehen.
Sprich, ich habe halt mir angeguckt, wie macht Mama das? Und die...
hat nie den Sinn eines Schneidbretts beispielsweise verstanden.
Das heißt also, die hat alles in der Hand geschnitten.
Die hat also eine Zwiebel genommen und halt gepellt und dann mit so einem kleinen
Schnibbelmesser erst in die eine Richtung, in die andere Richtung.
Und wenn du es nie anders gesehen hast, denkst du erst mal, das ist die normale Natur der Dinge.
Die hatte also nur stumpfe Messer und hat alles in der Hand geschnitten.
Und so habe ich es dann auch gemacht.
Dann habe ich mich halt irgendwann an die Uni gekommen.
Und dann fing das an mit diesen ersten Kochshows. So mit irgendwie Lafa und
wie sie damals alle hießen.
Wo man plötzlich mal gesehen hat, wie diese Profiköche sowas machen.
Das war immer noch lange für YouTube.
Und in meinem Freundes- und Bekanntenkreis war niemand.
Fernsehkoch oder was?
Fernsehkoch, genau. Lafa kennst du doch, oder? Lafa, Lichter.
Sehr, sehr, sehr lange.
Irgendwann später dann Tim Melzer und so. Aber das war schon wirklich deutlich später.
Biolank habe ich schon mal kochen sehen.
Ja, genau. Und dann hast du plötzlich gesehen, oh, die schneiden eine Zwiebel
gar nicht aus der Hand und das dauert nur ein Zehntel der Zeit und da kommen
viel bessere Teile raus.
So will ich das aber auch können. Und dann probierst du das halt irgendwie mit
schlechtem Equipment und dann merkst du, es funktioniert nicht.
Und dann merkst du plötzlich, okay, es geht nicht nur darum,
irgendwie jetzt ein Messer zu haben oder ich hatte ein vernünftiges Messer gekauft
und das war halt nach zwei Monaten stumpf und was machst du dann?
Und dann war klar, okay, man muss sich irgendwie mit diesem Thema Messerschärfen
beschäftigen. Und das erste, was
ich gemacht habe, ich habe es dann halt hingeschickt zu so einem Dienst.
Das gab es damals in der Tat auch schon. Das heißt, du packst das irgendwie
ein und schickst es irgendwo hin und dann kriegst du es geschliffen zurück.
Und das war im Prinzip, hat das schon auch ganz gut funktioniert.
Ich habe da mein großes Kochmesser, was ich mir damals irgendwie geleistet habe.
Ich glaube, das war auch ein WMF sogar, habe ich nicht mehr.
Das wurde mal nach mir geworfen.
20 Zentimeter Klinge, das ist ihm nicht gut bekommen. Aber ich habe es zum Schärfen
hingeschickt. Hast du getroffen?
Ja, zum Glück nicht. Aber die Kante vorne drin war immer noch.
Aber mit der Frau bist du nicht mehr zusammen.
Mit der bin ich nicht mehr zusammen. Die war ein bisschen verrückt.
Aber kochen konnte sie.
Na, egal.
Anderes Thema. So, aber was mich genervt hat, das Messer, was ich da hingeschickt
hatte, zum Schärfen, war danach einen halben Zentimeter kürzer.
Sprich, die haben einfach eine komplette Schicht von dem Stahl weggenommen.
Und nicht nur irgendwie die Schneide neu aufgebaut.
Einen halben Zentimeter?
So ungefähr. So, so.
So viel ist das ja nicht beim Messer.
Was?
Ein halber Zentimeter? Dann kannst du doch jahrelang schleifen auf einem halben Zentimeter.
Das Ding ist halt zum Beispiel diese elektrischen Schleifgeräte,
wo du im Prinzip nur einmal durchziehst.
Wenn du nicht so richtig weißt, wie du mit denen umzugehen hast oder ein schlechtes hast, dann fressen die.
Was heißt elektrischen?
Ja, es gibt halt so für irgendwelche Profiküchen, die setzen sich da nicht jetzt
mit einem Schleifstein hin.
Die haben entweder einen Wetzstahl oder so eine Maschine, wo du das Messer durchziehst
und da drehen oder rotieren halt irgendwelche Scheiben drin.
Und wenn du, ganz oft ist das bei diesen Messerschärfdiensten,
weil meine Oma ist zum Beispiel einer mit so einem Bus einmal im Quartal umgefahren,
hat da aus der Rentnersiedlung die ganzen Messer geschärft, der hat da auch
so einen Messerfresser, wo du hast das Messer hingegeben, hast es wiedergekriegt,
so im Moment irgendwie sieht das anders aus als vorher.
Das merkst du zum Beispiel, wenn du dann hier diese Showmesser hast,
ich habe also so eins davon mitgebracht, wo du hier so eine Maserung, wie heißt das?
Damaststahl oder sowas hier auch. Das hat ja so eine Baumrindenstruktur haben
und was sofort so eine große Kunstfertigkeit und Wertigkeit irgendwie suggeriert.
Das hat ja null Effekt auf die eigentliche Schnittleistung. Das ist reine Zierde.
Aber wenn du das eben zu so einem Dienst hinschickst, also ich halte jetzt zwei
Messer hoch. Vorher sah das hier auch so aus, wie das was Huckel hier hat.
Achso, die haben sozusagen die komplette Maserung weggeschliffen.
Die haben die Maserung halt einfach du siehst noch ein bisschen,
was ist da noch. Das ist krass. Und dann ist dir halt klar, das willst du ja eigentlich nicht.
Das ist so, als ob du dein Auto zum Lack ausbessern schickst und danach hast du eine andere Farbe.
So, und dann ist halt der, zumindest was damals State of the Art war,
war halt, da musst du halt mit Schleifstein ran.
Wasserstein. So, haben wir jetzt hier mal, ich hab einen. Ich hab keinen.
Ich mach nichts mit Wasserstein.
Ja, aus Gründen. So, das heißt also, wie hat man sich das vorzustellen.
So ein Wasserstein ist also einfach mal halt einfach ein Stein,
den gibt es dann mit unterschiedlichen Körnungen, meistens noch irgendwie farblich,
kodiert und über die schiebt man dann halt das Messer so hin und her.
Da können wir diesen schönen Sound hier mal ein.
Bisschen ASMR machen jetzt hier.
Ja, so hört sich das dann an. Ist jetzt natürlich aber grundfalsch,
dass ich das jetzt überhaupt auf einem trockenen Stein mache,
weil du musst ihn nämlich erstmal wässern. So eine halbe Stunde.
Eine halbe Stunde?
So ungefähr. Relativ lange, damit er sich richtig durchzieht.
Ja, das ist relativ porös.
Je nachdem, welchen Granularitätsgrad du hast, ist er halt immer weniger porös.
So, und dann, also sprich mit irgendwie, ich will jetzt kochen und ich brauche
ein scharfes Messer und jetzt aber erstmal eine halbe Stunde warten,
bis mein Stein gewässert ist, so. Das macht halt irgendwie auch keine Freude.
Ich habe dann einfach so einen Wetzstahl aus dem Schublade genommen und das
Ding da ein paar Mal dran nimmt her und dann war es scharf.
Ja, damit kannst du halt den Grat kurzfristig aufrichten, aber du hast halt
nicht eine Klinge scharf aufgebaut.
Das ist einfach der Grundunterschied zwischen, ich sorge dafür,
dass ich damit eine Viertelstunde irgendwie einigermaßen über die Runde komme versus,
ich habe eine Schärfe, die erstmal ein paar Wochen hält und dann muss ich mich
erst wieder drum kümmern, weil es halt einfach die Klingenspitze selber anders
aufgebaut ist, wenn du es richtig schärfst.
So, dann habe ich also wirklich lange versucht, mit diesem Wasserstein klar
zu kommen und damals, ich habe versucht, das für die Sendung rauszufinden,
aber ich habe es nicht mehr gefunden.
Es gab ein Video, wie gesagt vor YouTube, wo so eine Messerschmiede gezeigt
hat, wie man denn richtig auf so einem Wetzstein seine Messer schärft.
Das waren zwei Vollhonks, die also offensichtlich zum ersten Mal vor der Kamera
standen und die haben 40 Minuten lang, das halt irgendwie immer Push und Relax
und jetzt wieder Push und Relax.
Aber es hatte einen totalen Kult gerade.
Ein Video, was totaler Kult ist und was jetzt nicht auf YouTube ist?
Ja, ich kann auch sagen, wenn jemand das noch irgendwie weiß,
wovon ich rede, das müssen so die späten 90er gewesen sein, Mitte 90er,
so 95, 96 rum würde ich sagen ungefähr müsste das gewesen sein.
Ab wann gab es YouTube eigentlich?
2004.
Ach okay, also doch wirklich sehr viel später. Wenn das jemand irgendwie findet,
bitte unbedingt drüber werfen.
Kannst du es noch ein bisschen genauer beschreiben?
Also es war schon im Studio vernünftig
gedreht, auch schon irgendwie mit ordentlichen Kameras und sowas.
Und es waren halt zwei Typen mittleren Alters.
Und woran ich mich vor allen Dingen erinnere, ist, dass sie zum einen einen
starken Fokus auf den Schleifschlamm gelegt haben.
Weil das, was schärft, ist nicht der Stein selber, sondern der Schleifschlamm.
Der sich nämlich durch das Wässern auf der einen Seite, dass es überhaupt Wasser
dran ist und dann, wenn du das Messer dann immer drüber bewegst,
dann wird halt etwas von dem Stein abgetragen und das verwandelt sich in Schlamm.
Und dieser Steinschlamm, Schleifschlamm, der hat die eigentlich schleifende
Wirkung, mit der du die Klinge aufbaust.
Und alleine wie sie also dieses Wort Schleifschlamm immer wieder ausgesprochen haben.
Auf Deutsch.
Das war auf Deutsch.
Auch wenn sie Push sagen.
Ja, genau. Und dieses Push und Relax, das hatten sie dann auch immer so mantra-mäßig.
Und in welchem Winkel man das als... Ich fand das ganz fantastisch.
Ich habe es nicht besonders gut hingekriegt, aber dieses Video war so cool.
dass ich in der Tat in Göttingen eine Schleifschlamm-Party veranstaltet habe,
wo als ich alle Freunde und Bekannte eingeladen habe, bringt eure Messer vorbei,
wir gucken das Schleifschlamm-Video und dann schärfen wir alle gemeinsam unsere
Messer und gucken, ob es funktioniert und dann kochen wir lecker was Asiatisches,
wo man ja viel schnibbeln muss und gucken mal, wie weit wir kommen.
Und guck, Claudia war damals schon mit dabei und noch gar nicht meine Frau.
Aber genau, dieser Schleifschlamm ist zum Beispiel auch der Grund,
warum ich mit so einem Stein gar nicht erst angefangen habe,
weil die machen halt einerseits brauchst du Vorarbeit, zweitens machen die eine riesen Sauerei,
also es schlampt halt nicht nur dein Messer voll, sondern auch den ganzen Tisch
und ein weiteres Problem ist dadurch, dass du die ganze Zeit Material abträgst,
passiert es halt auch, dass dann irgendwann sich so eine...
Wie sagt man denn, so eine Kuhle einschleift und dann muss man den Stein selber
erstmal wieder abrichten, damit er wieder gerade ist.
Genau, da muss man zwei Steine aneinander schlammen, damit diese Ebene obendrauf
wirklich plan ist von diesem Stein.
Also es ist alles ein großes Elend. Ich habe immer den Eindruck gehabt,
dass ich diesen Winkel nicht vernünftig treffe.
Und wenn du das ständig mit einem unterschiedlichen Winkel schleifst,
kann man sich vorstellen, dann kriegst du natürlich auch keinen sauberen Grat
irgendwie hin, sondern verhackst dir dann mit einer einzigen Bewegung wieder
das, was du vorher dem mühsam mit fünf Minuten erarbeitet hast.
Ich fand das alles scheiße.
Und war dann lange auf der Suche nach irgendwie Alternativen.
Und dann kam das hier halt um die Ecke. und für jemanden...
Wie ist diese Sendung, wo das die Deutschland irgendwas erfinde,
die waren noch so im Fernsehen damit auch ganz viel.
Das habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen. War die irgendwie Höhle des Löwen oder so?
Ja, irgendwie so ein Quatsch war. Doch, doch, doch, da sind die...
Hast du das hier schon mal gesehen, Tim?
Den Haul-Rollschleifer.
Ich habe das schon mal von gehört, aber ich habe es nie benutzt.
Und wenn man ein bisschen Nerd ist, dann finde ich, geht einem da schon das
Herz auf. Unabhängig, wie gut das funktioniert.
Genau, warte, bevor du da gleich erklärst, ich nehme nichts vorweg.
Ich will nur mal vielleicht noch eine Sache vorwegnehmen.
Um ein Messer zu schleifen, gibt es eigentlich nur zwei Sachen,
die so grob zu beachten sind.
Und das Allerwichtigste ist tatsächlich, dass der Winkel, für den man sich entscheidet,
gleich bleibt beim Schleifen.
Also das, wenn man einen Film sieht, wenn die Leute so das Messer über irgendwas
drüber wählen, dann machst du dir die Klinge rund bei.
Also das Wichtige ist, egal ob du auf einer Tellerrückseite,
auf einem flachen Stein, auf einem nassen Stein, auf was auch immer du schleifst,
der Winkel muss gleich sein und damit haben halt die meisten Leute...
Quasi Probleme, wie ja Ralf auch schon bei dem Wetzstein sagte.
Und da kommt jetzt dieser Haul-Rollschleifer quasi mit einer genialen Idee zur Rettung.
Genau, also er bringt zwei Dinge auf den Tisch. Nämlich, es besteht aus zwei
Komponenten, dieser Haul-Schleifer.
Nämlich zum einen ist das ein Holzblock, gar nicht sonderlich schwer.
Da ist also nicht viel dran. Der hat aber starke Magnete an den Seiten eingebaut,
die in der Lage sind, auch große Messer stabil zu halten.
Oder dein Telefon zu löschen.
Auf der einen Seite steht 20 Grad, auf der anderen steht 15 Grad.
Genau, das ist der Winkel, mit dem du sozusagen die Klinge dann anschleifst.
So sind dann diese Seiten dann auch entsprechend geschrägt.
Genau, das eine ist quasi europäisch, das ist 20 Grad und das andere ist quasi
eher asiatisch-japanische 15 Grad.
Ich dachte jetzt schon amerikanisch irgendwie wieder mit Inch und so.
Nee, nee, aber auch das, ich sag mal, nimm das mal als Haul-Interpretation dieser
Winkel und nicht als ultimative Wahrheit, dass das jetzt dafür und dafür ist.
Welche benutzt du? 20 oder 15?
18 oder 13.
Aber im Grundlegenden ist es so, je größer der Winkel,
desto stabiler natürlich die Klinge. Das heißt, wenn du so einen Beil hast,
um so einen Schweineknochen-Dingsbums zu zaubern, dann machst du halt nicht
eine super dünne Klinge, weil sonst bricht dir das Metall weg.
Das heißt so eine Axt, ein Outdoor-Messer, ein Hackebeilchen hier oder da.
Alles, was so ein bisschen durch was Grobes mit auch ein bisschen Wucht durchgeht,
willst du halt einen fetteren Winkel.
Und wenn es hier um Mikrometer Tomatenscheiben schneiden geht,
dann halt so spitz wie möglich.
In einer asiatischen Küche ist ja das filigrane Schnibbeln häufig angezeigt
und von daher sagt man, sind die halt eher die mit den engen,
mit den 15 Grad oder noch kleineren Winkeln.
Aber am Ende des Tages, wie Huckel völlig richtig sagt, Hauptsache du hast einen Winkel.
Ich finde jetzt auch den Unterschied zwischen 15 und 20 ist das nicht so weltbewegend.
Hauptsache man hat überhaupt einen Winkel.
Hauptsache du hast überhaupt einen Winkel.
Das ist wirklich, jeder, also es ist wirklich, es ist echt schwer am Anfang ohne diesen Holzblock,
wenn du so versuchst, so ein Messer zu schleifen, wirklich dich ganz zu zügeln
und zu beobachten, mach ich, verziehe ich das gerade, weil jedes bisschen verlierst
du halt an der ultimativen Skalpellschärfe.
So und der Gedanke dieses Schleifers ist also, da sind Magneten dran,
du stellst diesen Holzflock auf den Tisch und dann machst du eben,
bist du nicht mit deinem Messer mobil, das du irgendwo rüber ziehst in einem
Winkel, der sich verändert, sondern das Messer ist starr auf dem Tisch.
Klinge nach oben.
Rücken nach unten auf den Tisch. Und jetzt ist das ziemlich stabil arretiert.
Du musst noch die Hand auf diesem Block halten, aber jetzt bewegt sich das Messer
quasi wirklich gar nicht mehr.
Darf ich das mal kurz überprüfen, ob die Festigkeit das hat?
Unbedingt.
Okay, also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man viel Kraft aufwenden müsste,
aber es bleibt erstmal da, ja.
Es ist ganz gut austariert, würde ich sagen. Also das ist nicht das Problem dieses Geräte.
Leisten. Die sind relativ stark, wenn du direkt orthogonal das Messer wegziehst,
aber normalerweise soll man die Messer anklappen und dann abziehen,
damit du halt nicht so, ne.
So wie du es gerade abgezogen hast, das ist ja auch so ein bisschen so abgewinkelt.
Das geht leicht, aber wenn du es jetzt so tatsächlich so gerade wegziehen wolltest,
dann bleibt es schon ziemlich gut.
So, und die zweite Komponente von diesem Haul ist also eine Tonne mit einem
Radius von vielleicht, was wird das sein?
Kleineres Nullholz.
5 cm.
Das Teil ist schwer.
Ja, das ist also aus Holz und hat zwei Seiten mit einer unterschiedlichen Körnung.
Das heißt also, man hat, wenn man so will, zwei verschiedene Wetzstahle oder
Schleifsteine oder was man da jetzt auch immer als Vergleich heranziehen will.
So, und da das Ganze eine Tonne ist, sprich es ist rund, kann man es über den Tisch rollen.
Genau.
Und es ist so gebaut, dass man also das Holzstück in der Mitte festhält und
links und rechts wie zwei Räder quasi die Schleifbereiche.
Genau, der Griff in der Mitte ist quasi die Achse und dann hast du links und
rechts so zwei Schleifräder und die sind dann unterschiedlich gekörnt.
Und das eine hat hier so konzentrische Ringe mit drei, vier verschiedenen Schleifbereichen oder was?
Ja, wofür da genau diese Ringe drin sind.
Das ist nicht die Abziehseite?
Ja, das kann auch sein, dass das irgendwas mit Temperatur zu tun hat,
dass sie da irgendwie versuchen.
Naja, also auf jeden Fall, der Effekt, den man jetzt also haben möchte,
ist, dass man jetzt also mit der groben Seite anfängt und das Ganze dann also
an dem Messer, schöner Sound,
vor- und zurückschiebt.
Mach mal ein bisschen AMSR hier.
ASMR.
So, und man sieht schon.
Nein, sieht man nicht.
Oder man hört oder ahnt.
Man ahnt.
Nimm mal näher ran. Nimm mal näher ran da mit deinem Mikrofon.
Man muss es ja auch hören, wenn wir es schon nicht sehen können.
Ich gehe jetzt also immer über die ganze Klinge von ganz hinten bis ganz vorne.
Und der Winkel ändert sich halt praktisch kaum dadurch. Du hast halt wirklich
schon mal dieses Problem, okay, ist der Winkel konstant?
Das geht schon. Und wenn du mit der einen Seite fertig bist, dann,
montierst du das ganze Messer andersrum, machst es dann auf der anderen Seite
der Schneide, weil du musst ja quasi immer von beiden Seiten abwechselnd.
Was heißt denn fertig? Wann ist man denn fertig mit einer Seite?
Ja, kommen wir gleich zu, zu den Testverfahren. Da könnt ihr dann auch alle
mitmachen da draußen an den Geräten. So, und wenn du das...
Verbandkasten schon mal rausholen.
Wenn du den Grobschliff hast, dann drehst du das Ganze, diese Tonne um und gehst
dann halt mit der feinen Seite nochmal rüber, um quasi nochmal so einen Die
feine ist mit den konzentrischen Ringen.
Ja, genau. Das merkt man ein bisschen, wenn man so drüber geht.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe das nicht gemerkt.
Du kannst es jetzt auch einfach mal selber ausprobieren. Das ist ja für den
Laien verständlich. Das ist halt das Versprechen. Und ich würde sagen, das lösen sie auch ein.
Man kann halt praktisch nichts falsch machen.
Aber wie viel Druck muss ich denn hier ausüben?
Das ist relativ egal. Also grundsätzlich heißt, wenn du einen Grundschliff schon
drin hast in dem Messer, brauchst du eigentlich weder viele Durchgänge noch viel Druck.
Aber jetzt kommen wir halt so ein bisschen zu der Problemlage.
Ich würde sagen, in der Theorie ist das eine fantastische Erfindung,
ein geniales Gerät, dessen Bedienung sich sofort irgendwie erschließt und alle
denken, ja, endlich, warum nicht gleich so.
Das Problem ist halt, die Messer werden nicht so geil scharf damit.
Das heißt also, das eigentliche Wirkungsziel wird halt nicht so richtig gut erreicht.
Und das hat man jetzt auch gerade bei Ralf gerade schon ganz geil gesehen.
Ich gucke so gerade von der Seite drauf, wie er geschliffen hat,
weil das Messer hat halt natürlich wie so viele Kochmesser eine runde Klinge
und läuft spitz zu und der Haul hat es jetzt zum Beispiel nicht geschafft,
dann diese Spitze richtig zu erwischen.
Abgesehen davon, ich habe ja auch so einen Haul, ich hatte den ersten davon,
deswegen, das meine ich vorhin, ich hatte vor Ralf schon diese Haul-Erfahrung
und habe versucht, ihm das gleich auszureden.
Aber er wollte ja nicht hören.
Ja, nee, ist auch okay. Manchmal muss man es selber rausfinden.
Also ich habe dann auch irgendwann gesagt, alles cool, mach mal und wir sprechen
uns in einem Jahr wieder und so war es dann irgendwie auch in etwa. Ähm...
Weil ich dann auch gemerkt habe, ja Moment mal, also ja, meine stumpfen Messer
sind auf jeden Fall weniger stumpf als vorher, aber das, was ich mir so vorgestellt
hatte und jetzt sind meine Messer wieder scharf,
das hat sich irgendwie nicht eingestellt und da ging dann meine Suchreise nämlich auch nochmal weiter.
So, aber hier machen wir jetzt mal einen kleinen Boxen-Stop.
Nämlich, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich ein scharfes Messer?
Die Frage von Tim ist ja völlig berechtigt. Wann ist ein Messer denn jetzt eigentlich
scharf genug, damit man damit irgendwie vernünftig kochen kann?
So und da gibt es eine Reihe von Tests und das ist der Moment,
wo ihr da draußen alle mal mitmachen könnt.
Das heißt, lauft doch jetzt mal in die Küche, holt mal so eure zwei,
drei Messer raus, von denen ihr meint, mit denen arbeitet ihr und dann gehen
wir mal so ein paar Verfahren durch,
die sehr einfach und nachvollziehbar sind und wo man einen ganz guten Eindruck
bekommt, was denn nun irgendwie scharf oder nicht scharf ist.
Grundsätzlich, Huckl hat schon gesagt, wenn ihr beim Zwiebelschneiden anfangt
zu weinen, ist das schon mal ein deutlicher Indikator dafür,
dass das Messer nicht scharf genug ist.
Weil wir bekanntlich nur durch die ätherischen Öle, ätherische Öle sind das?
Auf jeden Fall irgendwelche Säfte.
Die Säfte, die da so in diesen Zwiebeln drin sind, wenn ich mit einem stumpfen
Messer darin rumhantiere, gerät mehr davon in die Luft und darauf reagieren dann die Augen.
Und wenn ich ein wirklich scharfes Messer habe, bleibt quasi der ganze Saft
in der Zwiebel drin, nichts spritzt, nichts wird irgendwie freigesetzt.
Das ist schon mal so ein Indikator. Es gibt aber ein paar andere Verfahren,
die ich auch noch gar nicht so lange kenne, wo ich denke, das sind gute Indikatoren,
um sich dann Eindruck zu machen.
Das erste ist euer Fingernagel. Genau.
Liebe Kinder da draußen, hört jetzt gut zu, was ihr machen sollt.
Wir übernehmen keine Verantwortung dafür, wenn es jetzt fehlinterpretiert.
Versucht niemals auf einem Messer mit irgendwie Haut, also sprich Fingerkuppe
oder sowas zu gucken, ist das scharf. Das hast du nämlich gerade gemacht, Tim.
Du bist mit deinem Finger über die gerade eben so mäßig geschärfte Klingel drüber gegangen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn du das hier mit Huckels Präparat gemacht hättest,
hättest du jetzt schon eine formidable Wunde in deinem Finger.
Scharfe Messer sind auch wirklich scharf.
So, da kannst du nicht einfach mit Wir haben hier.
So ein paar.
Dokumentationsfotos.
Damit dann die Leute später noch im Slack sehen können, was hier passiert.
Unbedingt, ja. Und wo man das aber gut testen kann, ist in der Tat der menschliche Fingernagel.
Das heißt also, wenn man jetzt einen Finger vor sich streckt einfach und mit
der anderen Hand ganz locker das Messer nimmt und dann mal leicht mit der Schneide
über den Fingernagel drüber schert.
dann merkt man, ob es so reinbeißt oder ob es einfach rübergleitet.
Und das ist ein sehr guter erster Indikator dafür, wenn es wirklich relativ
entspannt so drüber geht, ohne dass man den Eindruck hat, so da ruckt es jetzt
gerade so, da beißt es sich so ein bisschen fest in dem Fingernagel,
dann ist Schärfung angesagt, weil dann ist es einfach zu stumpf.
Und das ist auch gleichzeitig, ne, das ist auch der erste Test.
Tim schaut kritisch auf das Messer.
Naja, so mit dem Messer und weißt du, das ist für mich schon wieder alles so ein bisschen.
Also so einen Winkel in etwa hier irgendwie, dass man wir als Schnitz,
als würdest du deinen Nagel schnitzen im Wesentlichen.
Bloß nicht mit Druck.
Genau, du musst nur drauflegen, wenn es drüber rutscht, ist es stumpf, wenn es stecken bleibt.
Aber der rutscht doch hier.
Genau, die sind alle stumpf. Alle Messer, die ich mitgebracht habe, sind stumpf.
Das ist okay.
So, die habe ich nämlich jetzt alle seit, als Vorbereitung für diese Sendung, habe ich...
Hast du die alle schon...
Das ist scharf. Warte.
Das ist der nächste Test, zu dem kommen wir jetzt.
Genau. Das mit dem Papier reicht mir einfach nicht.
So, diese Nagelprobe ist auch deshalb interessant, weil man dort die ganze Klinge lang testen kann.
Weil mir ist es gerade mit dem Haul häufig so passiert. Es gab Zonen auf der
Messerklinge, die durchaus eine vernünftige Schärfe hatten.
Durch den Effekt, den Huckel gerade richtig beschrieben hat,
die Krümmung wird nicht vernünftig mitgegangen.
Aber oben und oder unten beispielsweise ist dann eben nicht scharf genug wahr.
Und das bekommt man mit dem eigenen Finger. den Nagel relativ gut mit.
Oh, in der Mitte ist es top, aber oben und unten ist es scheiße.
Die nächsten Test, den ihr machen könnt, ist, das hat Huckel gerade eben schon
mal angefangen, ein ganz normales 80 Gramm DIN A4 Papier nehmen,
und versuchen, das hält man vor sich, gar nicht irgendwie mit Spannung,
sondern in der linken Hand hält man es entspannt vor sich und versucht dann
mit dem Messer an der Oberkante was abzuschneiden, so als ob man was abschnitzen wollte,
also an der Spitzenkante des Papiers nicht versuchen reinzuhacken oder so sondern
versuchen was abzuschneiden da sieht man,
bei keinem meiner Messer sieht man nicht, aber man ahnt man ahnt,
hier gibt es auch kaum einen Sound, mal gucken ob man das hört.
Also im Prinzip rutscht die Klinge über die lange Seite ASMR Sektion.
Nochmal nochmal ans Mikrofon,
Das klingt, ach, das klingt ja furchtbar.
Wenn man sich viel Müll gibt und viel zieht oder drückt, dann kommt es ein bisschen.
Das ist ein Trauerspiel.
Das will man nicht im Fernsehen sehen. Man kann nicht im Podcast hören.
Also da geht also auch nicht viel. Aber das ist auch ein guter Indikator.
Genau, ich mache es jetzt hier für Tim nochmal langsam mit dem hier,
weil auch da sind unterschiedlichen Schärfegrade spürbar.
wenn du sozusagen so eine Grundschärfe wiederhergestellt hast,
dann geht es durch, aber man merkt, man muss noch ein bisschen drücken.
Und wenn du dann so Richtung Rasier- und Skalpellschärfe kommst,
dann kannst du das quasi ganz locker in der Hand halten und so durchziehen.
Machen wir nochmal näher, richtig schnell nach dem Mikrofon.
Das ist auch schon ein ganz anderer Sound.
Und dann kannst du halt auch wirklich so irgendwie dein Papier da zerhacken.
Das ist schon ein ordentlich scharfes Messer, was du da hast.
Ja.
Das ist schon gut.
Das ist schon gut, genau.
Aber das hast du selbst geschärft.
Ja.
Okay.
Also ich sage mal gleich dazu, jetzt vielleicht an der Stelle,
dass meine Reise auch durch YouTube weiter inspiriert wurde.
Also den Haul habe ich über YouTube gefunden.
Und ich habe dann irgendwie einen deutschen YouTube-Kanal gefunden, Schmiedeglut.
Und das ist im Prinzip ein Nerd, der Nantga, der eigentlich was ganz anderes
früher gemacht hat und dann beim Grillen mal dachte, hey, was passiert denn,
wenn ich hier so ein bisschen Metall in den Grill halte und kann man das dann
schmieden? Ja, aha, guck mal, da passiert was.
Und er hat jetzt so eine, sich über die Jahre so eine richtige Schmiede aufgebaut,
baut selber Messer und hat halt auch diverse Videos gemacht,
wie man Messer schnell und effizient schärft.
Und an dem habe ich mich dann irgendwann so ein bisschen festgeklammert und
dachte, okay, pass mal auf, was der erzählt, das macht irgendwie Sinn.
Ich probiere das mal aus und seitdem bin ich quasi ein Bekehrter von Nankas
Lehren von Schmiedeglut und dieses Messer ist auch ein Schmiedeglut Santoco Essential.
Also die haben so eine günstige Messereihe, auch ein Brotmesser übrigens.
Es gibt das Kneipchen, das Santoco und das Brotmesser in einem Combo-Pack.
Ich habe nur das Kneipchen und das Santoco, weil ich schon ein großes Brotmesser habe, aber...
Ich muss sagen, weil ich das jetzt auch schon viele Jahre quasi mache und für
andere Leute Messerschleife und so weiter, ich bin auch von denen sehr überzeugt.
Also das, was der Nandke erzählt, meiner Meinung nach macht alles Sinn und er
hat recht und seine Messer sind auch geil.
Okay.
Weil jetzt kommt, glaube ich.
Auch dann Wir nähern uns.
Achso, du machst noch den Tomatentest.
Genau, der Tomatentest. Genau. Also wem das jetzt zu abstrakt war,
mit dem Fingernagel und dem Blatt Papier und zu weit weg von dem,
wie es doch in der Küche passiert.
So der letzte Klassiker ist halt, man nimmt eine Tomate und schneidet jetzt
aber nicht normal mit der, sondern hält das Messer, was man hat, ganz hinten am Griff.
Jetzt war fast der Finger ab. Gut, das ist...
Das Blut muss fritzen.
Legt das locker drauf, das Messer und fährt es ohne irgendeinen zusätzlichen Druck reinzugeben.
Das heißt nur das Gewicht des Messers nach vorne und schaut, was passiert.
So, da sehen wir das bisschen Angeschärfe, was ich eben gemacht habe.
Hatte immerhin schon mal dafür gesorgt.
Sehen wir nicht.
Wir sehen nicht.
Man ahnt.
Ihr seht es und jetzt beschreibe ich es.
Man sieht nicht, man ahnt.
Ich durch eine kleine Tomate, keine winzige Cocktailtomate, zu einem Drittel
durchgekommen bin, indem ich es einmal drüber geschoben habe.
Und jetzt kann man also die verschiedenen Messer hier probieren.
Da kommen wir auch nicht ansatzweise so weit. Jetzt haben wir das kleine.
Ein ganz kleines Messer. Das ist so ein Schnibbelmesser. Das hat natürlich weniger
Gewicht. Das heißt also, das ist natürlich nochmal unfairer.
Das geht überhaupt nicht mehr rein in die Tomate. Da passiert ja auch nichts.
So, und gucken, wo wir hier landen. Mein Standard-Santoku ist auch so stumpf,
dass gar nichts passiert.
Und jetzt macht einfach mal Huckel mit Seine dasselbe. Auch ein bisschen schwerer, aber wir werden...
So, der ist also noch nicht mit der Hälfte der Klinge drüber gezogen,
da ist die Tomate schon komplett.
Das Messer fällt einfach durch die Tomate durch.
Genau, deswegen dieses drückst du noch oder schneidest du schon,
aber mein Test ist immer irgendwie auch, wie dünn kriege ich dann die Tomate da filetiert.
Ich merke gerade vorne muss ich mal wieder ein bisschen ran,
um an die Skalpellschärfe zu kommen, aber ja.
Dafür sind wir ja hier.
So, also das ist jetzt schon ein Unterschied wie Tag und Nacht von dem Messer,
was Huckel jetzt hat, hier zu meinem.
So, und jetzt ist halt Die Frage, okay, was ist denn jetzt also der Weg?
Ein Zwischenstadium, was ich noch gegangen bin, ist, dass ich mir gedacht habe,
okay, dieser Haul-Rollschleifer, im Prinzip ist das ja schon eine coole Idee,
wenn nur die Restschärfe fehlt.
Dann nimmt man halt noch ein Leder dazu.
Das ist ja also auch eine dieser Komponenten. Wir hatten Wassersteine und wir hatten Wettstahl.
Ich sehe ja, dass dieser Haul offensichtlich ein bisschen überhypt und so weiter ist.
Gutes Marketing, semi-gutes Resultat.
Aber besser als diese komischen Wassersteine.
Einfacher. Besser ist schwierig. Du kannst ein super Messer schärfen auf einem
Wasserstein, aber du brauchst viel Erfahrung, würde ich sagen.
Das Ding ist, ich würde sagen, ich würde den Haul gar niemanden empfehlen.
Und zwar aus folgendem Grund, weil es führt zu frustrierenden Ergebnissen,
wenn dein Messer an manchen Stellen scharf ist und an anderen nicht.
Und dann hast du irgendwie, das fühlt sich einfach kacke an.
Du weißt im Prinzip, vorne ist nichts zu holen. Dann schneidest du immer nur
noch hinten und dann, ja, was hat man dann gewonnen für seine,
wie viel hundert Euro auch immer das Ding kostet.
Und es funktioniert nicht mal für alle Messer. Also wenn du zum Beispiel so
ein kleines Kneipchenmesser hast, also wirklich diese so Schälmesser oder was
auch immer, die kannst du mit diesem Ding auch nicht wirklich gut schleifen.
Und das Beste, was mir das gezeigt hatte, war folgendes.
Ich war beim Freund, der hat auch dieses Haul-Ding gehabt und war ganz stolz,
weil ich habe so seine Messer gesehen und meinte so, naja, ich gucke mir die mal an.
Und er hat da, bevor ich das in der Hand hatte, meinte, ja, ich habe diesen
Haul-Rollschleifer und die sind jetzt alle total toll.
Ich nehme die Messer, lasse die über den Fingernagel gehen, die rutschen alle
rüber. Und ich so, naja, gib mir mal ein Stück Papier.
Alles reißen, mehr reißen oder drücken als schneiden. Und dann haben wir versucht,
uns mit dem Haul hinzusetzen und es nochmal so ganz bei the book und ganz vorsichtig
zu machen. Und dann am Ende habe ich gesagt, pass mal auf.
Ich nehme jetzt diesen Haul, hast du den hier gerade nochmal liegen?
Ich zeige das mal Tim, aber ich habe den einfach so vor mich hingestellt und
habe quasi aus meinem Handgelenk versucht, einen gleichmäßigen Winkel zu halten
und habe einfach das Messer quasi so auf dem, weil es ist ja am Ende ein Schleifstein,
von Hand drübergezogen und habe ein schärferes Ergebnis hinbekommen,
als mit diesem ganzen Hin- und Hergeröhre für 20 Minuten.
Und dann war mir endgültig klar, wie Ralf schon sagt, gutes Marketing und für
manche Messer mag es funktionieren, aber es ist...
Das Foto ist ja super, was wir jetzt im Chat haben.
Ich poste die anderen auch mal gleich.
So eine Zwischenstation war, ich habe mir da noch so ein Leder geholt.
Also das ist, was sehen wir jetzt vor uns? Ich halte jetzt hoch ein.
Was ahnen wir jetzt?
Wir ahnen, dass ich hochhalte einen Holzstab, der so ein bisschen flach ist,
wie so ein Cricket-Schläger, so ungefähr.
Eine kleine Ausgabe von einem Cricket-Schläger. Ein Paddel mit zwei Seiten.
Und auf den beiden Seiten ist unterschiedliches Leder aufgeklebt.
Mit einer unterschiedlichen Körnung wieder auch.
Also richtiges, echtes Leder.
Richtiges, echtes Leder, genau.
Und da muss man... Aufrechtieren.
Rind.
Rind ist es?
Weiß ich nicht.
Und dazu hat man dann solche Pasten, mit die auch wieder eine unterschiedliche
Körnung nochmal irgendwie mitgeben.
Und damit bearbeitet man dieses Leder und lässt es irgendwie trocknen.
Ein paar Stunden in der Tat. Das muss ja so richtig trocken sein.
Aber das machst du einmal in drei Jahren.
Einmal alle x Jahre, genau. Und dann kann man dort drüber gehen und in der Tat
seinem Messer nochmal einen Restkick geben, was der Haul nicht hinbekommt.
Und das hat dann schon einen echten Effekt.
Da zieht man das Messer dann quasi nach hinten.
Also wieder von Hand halt so drüber, wie man es auch beim Schleifstein machen würde.
Also es ist schwer jetzt im Podcast zu transportieren, aber ich zeige es mal
Tim und vielleicht kannst du es beschreiben. Wenn du jetzt so,
ich mache meine Hände, ich führe meine Hände zu einem Dreieck zusammen und die
Spitze ist quasi die Klinge.
Und wenn du jetzt anfängst, eine Seite zu schleifen, dann entsteht ja so ein Grat.
Und dieser Grat ist im Prinzip, jetzt zeigt der Wipfel von meinem Handdreieck zu einer Seite.
Dann schleifst du die andere Seite, also jetzt da, wo der Grat ist,
und dann kommt der Grat auf die andere Seite.
Der letzte Schritt beim Schleifen ist dann gegen die Klinge nochmal ein-,
zweimal auf beiden Seiten zu ziehen, um diesen Grat abzubrechen.
Jetzt hast du den Grat abgebrochen, jetzt wird es auch schon beißen.
Und was du jetzt mit dem Leder machst, ist ähnlich wie bei Nagelpolieren oder so.
Du nimmst immer eine feinere, oder generell polieren, Du nimmst immer eine feinere
Körnung und polierst die Klinge und machst jede Unebenheit raus sozusagen.
Und je polierter die Klinge, und das musst du natürlich auch im richtigen Winkel
oder im selben Winkel idealerweise machen, wenn du das einfach machst,
relativ konstant, dann kriegst du Skalpellrasierschärfe hin.
Und die Frage, wie lange diese Schärfe dann hält, das ist dann halt nochmal
so ein, du hast vielleicht auch schon gesehen, bei Messern gibt es halt tausend
eine Stahllegierung und dies und das und jenes.
Und im Prinzip sind es alles Versuche aus den Kompromissen rostfrei,
ja nein, hart, ja nein, also oder beziehungsweise bruchfest, ja nein.
Das heißt, Stahl, der rostfrei ist, in der Regel, es gibt Ausnahmen,
den kannst du nicht so hart machen wie...
einen rostigen Stahl sozusagen.
Beziehungsweise hast du immer dieses Dreieck. Also ja, wir können ihn hart machen,
aber dann ist er brüchig.
Das heißt, bei rostfreiem Messerstahl versucht man einen Kompromiss zwischen
Härte und Bruchfestigkeit zu machen, weil wenn du, das sieht man ganz oft so
in Ferienhäusern, wenn du dann so auf die Klingen guckst, dann sind da so richtige Scharten drin.
Und dann haben sie vielleicht einen harten Stahl genommen, aber zu hart oder zu brüchig.
Es gibt ein, zwei Stahlligierungen, die sehr gute Kompromisse da geschaffen haben.
Aber zum Beispiel die besten Messerstähle sind halt nicht rostfrei und die packst
du dann halt nicht in Geschirrspüler, was dann halt für viele Leute schon mal so ein Ausschluss...
Was man überhaupt niemals tun sollte.
Ja, soll man generell nicht machen, aber...
Und auch nicht in irgendeine Schublade, sondern Messer gehören an ein Magnetbrett.
Und deswegen ist dieses, man kann aus fast jedem Messer so Skalpellschärfe rausholen,
wenn der Stahl einigermaßen okay ist.
Wie lange dann diese Schnittfestigkeit ist und wie robust das Messer bei ein
bisschen Abuse ist, das sind halt dann noch so Variablen in dem Spiel.
Das ist im Prinzip so ein Kompromiss-Dreieck.
Choose any two.
Und das Krasse ist halt, dass anscheinend halt kein Stahl wirklich für so Küchenmesser
dediziert designt wurde oder für Messer generell, sondern dass immer im Prinzip so,
irgendwelche Experimente von den Schmieden sind mit irgendwelchen Jetzt machen
wir hier ein bisschen mehr Chrom und da ein bisschen mehr Nickel oder was auch immer rein.
Und dann vor kurzem gab es so einen Stahl, der heißt Magna Cut,
heißt diese spezielle Legierung, die rostfrei ist, sehr hart und trotzdem bruchfest.
Und das ist gerade so der Messerstahl-Hype, weil das ist der erste Stahl,
der dediziert für Messer wohl Design.
Ich habe es jetzt nicht nachgelesen in der Wikipedia, das sagen die Messerleute,
das kann auch alles Hokuspokus sein.
Aber ich habe ein Messer mit MagnaCut und das war das, was du auf der Nation
benutzt hast, um aus dem Holzding was rauszubrechen, was danach einfach exakt
genauso scharf war wie vorher.
Du wolltest doch so ein größeres Loch für den ersten Testbutton machen.
Dann habe ich dir mein kleines Outdoor-Messer gegeben, womit du dann so rausgebrochen hast das Holz.
Das war ein MagnaCut-Messer zum Beispiel.
Genau, also das nur so als Hintergrund, dieses Polieren ist vor allen Dingen
ähnlich, wie wenn man sich die Nägel poliert oder irgendwas anderes,
Unebenheiten und Imperfektionen rauspacken, damit...
richtig zappelt. Oder nicht mehr zappelt, sondern durchgeht.
Genau. Das ist übrigens der vierte Test, weil du jetzt immer sagst, so reißig.
Test, test. Irgendwas ist hier gerade sehr sonderbar.
Es rauscht hier auch irgendwas.
Irgendwie ist das Headset gerade hinübergegangen.
Naja, es kommt schon Audio durch, aber auch eine Menge anderer Dinge,
die wir nicht hören wollen.
Das klingt nicht gut. Kannst du mal das andere, das Note-Headset Not-Headset.
Not-Headset to the rescue.
Ja, an der Meta-Ebene.
Warte, warte mal eben.
Da ist gerade irgendwas gestorben bei dem Headset.
Ja, sag mal, was ist jetzt das?
Vorsicht.
Da bin ich wieder.
Kabel durchgeschnitten.
Wie transportiert der Unkel denn seine Superschaffen? Ich habe nur eins mitgebracht,
weil ich wollte eigentlich gar keins mitbringen, Aber ich bin vorhin ein Taxi
gefahren und habe das in einen dünnen Amazon-Karton gefaltet,
reingesteckt und in meinem Rucksack, Hartschalen-Rucksack transportiert.
Das fällt nicht durch den Karton durch. Also ist es eigentlich gar nicht richtig scharf.
Nee, guck mal, das war ja hier jung. Der Griff hält es quasi dann.
Genau, so Rasiermesser-Schärfe. Das ist halt so der vierte Test.
Den kann man probieren, aber den finde ich immer so ein bisschen irgendwie weird.
Das ist dann sich wirklich auf dem Armrücken die Härchen abrasieren.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du Videos von Nandga von Schmiedeglut guckst,
der hat halt so dieses Messerschärfen total im Griff und muss gar nicht mehr
drüber nachdenken über Winkel.
Der macht das ganz intuitiv und der guckt dann immer in seinen Hosenbeinen,
zieht da hoch und guckt, ob er noch irgendwo Haare am Bein hat,
um mal kurz zu gucken, dass es rasierscharf ist.
Genau, so und jetzt bei unserer langen Reise kommen wir ja langsam jetzt zum
Ende, also wie gesagt dieses Leder, das war so eine Zwischenstufe,
wo ich auch den Eindruck hatte, ja,
das gibt da nochmal was drauf, aber es kann halt irgendwie dann doch die Konstruktionsmängel
von dem Haul nicht wirklich kompensieren und dann dachte ich daran,
der Huckel, der hat doch vor einem Jahr da mal was geschrieben,
und da wolltest du nicht auf ihn hören und du dachtest die können doch nicht
alle irren, die diesem Haul hinterherlaufen.
Und dann kamst du eben genau hier mit Schmiedeglut, wobei ich würde sagen,
das Grundprinzip gibt es wahrscheinlich auch bei anderen Anbietern,
ist also nicht, dass die da jetzt irgendwie,
wahnsinnig was erfunden haben, sondern es ist halt einfach nur,
es ist kein Wasserstein, sondern es ist auf der einen Seite ein Stahl und auf
der anderen Seite ein Leder und es gibt es quasi in zwei Größen,
nämlich einmal genau mit so einem Paddle,
wie wir es gerade eben schon beschrieben hatten und die Profivariante davon
hast du jetzt auch nochmal mitgebracht.
Ich kann ja mal kurz noch dazu was sagen, weil das erste, was ich gekauft hatte,
war dieses formschöne Workbench-Teil und die Firma, die im Prinzip…,
Das Erste, was ich sagen muss, der Nandga hat gleich von Anfang an mir gesagt,
diese Wasserschleifsteine, alles Müll, das benutzen wir nicht in der Werkstatt,
haben wir keine Zeit für, macht nur Dreck.
Wir benutzen DMT, heißt die Firma, der Marktführer in so diamantbeschichteten
Metallplatten für Schleifwerkzeuge aus den USA und die benutzen einfach so eine,
also es ist ziemlich schwer, es könnte Stahl sein, also keine Ahnung,
kannst du ja mal in die Hand nehmen, kannst du auch abnehmen,
ist eine Magnethalterung für die Platte.
da habe ich mir also gleich mal angehört okay, Metall mit Diamantbeschichtung
ist der Weg und von DMT und dann habe ich mir ein bisschen größenwahnsinnig
gleich so das größte Produkt, was sie da hatten,
gekauft, weil das Schöne ist, das müsst ihr euch so vorstellen ist,
weiß nicht, wie lang ist das 40 Zentimeter vielleicht, wir können gleich noch
ein Foto in den Chat packen,
ist so eine kleine Minibank, die man sich so auf den Tisch stellt,
magnetisch auch und darauf kann man diese Schleifplatten draufpacken.
Ich habe eine grobe und eine feine.
Und das Ding ist, wenn du ein Messer hast, wo der Rücken genauso scharf ist
wie die Klinge, und das kommt öfter mal vor in Ferienhäusern oder Segelboden.
Der Rücken.
Der Messerrücken, ja. Wenn die Seite genauso scharf ist wie die andere. Was? Ja, na ja.
Dann gibt es viel zu tun. Dann brauchst du halt was Grobes. Wenn du nämlich
mit den feinen Körnungen anfängst, wie bei allen Schleifarbeiten, machst du dich kaputt.
Du meinst, wenn das Ding so stumpf ist?
Ja, ja, ja. Genau, wenn beide Seiten genauso scharf sind.
Oder stumpf.
Und deswegen dachte ich mir, ich will halt viel Fläche und ich will eine grobe und eine feine.
Und dann habe ich mir dieses fette Stück, wir machen natürlich Links in die
Beschreibung, Magna Base Adapter heißt das Ding.
Und habe damit meine Zwillingenmesser alle geschliffen und war auch sehr zufrieden. Frieden.
Und dann kam der Nandga um die Ecke und meinte, ja, dieses DMC-Zeug,
das ist alles schon mal ganz cool und das benutzen wir auch in der Werkstatt,
aber für euch zu Hause, weil die machen diese Polierschritte nicht mit dem Abziehleder.
Die haben natürlich irgendwelche Bandschleifer, wo sie die Messer ranhalten.
Also was, was man vielleicht zu Hause nicht in der Küche hat.
So einen fetten Werkstatt-Bandschleifer.
Und dann hat er halt, glaube ich, das hier zuerst gemacht.
Das ist jetzt ein Vierkant mit Griff, sage ich mal, auch so circa 30 Zentimeter
lang, vielleicht 4, 5 Zentimeter,
Jede Kante, wie auch immer. Und das besteht aus einer feinen gekörnten Metallplatte,
wo man also sozusagen wirklich schleifen kann und dann drei Abziehlederseiten
mit was weiß ich wie viel Mikron. Die letzte ist ein Mikron.
Und damit kriegst du die Rasierschärfe schon ziemlich zuverlässig.
Und wenn du das mit dem Winkelhalten einigermaßen hinkriegst,
kann man mit diesem Ding jedes Messer rattenscharf machen, wie jetzt das schon heißt.
Das habe ich bei mir eigentlich immer im Einsatz und ich muss jetzt dazu sagen,
das klingt so nach viel Arbeit und so.
Dieses Messer hier, was ich mitgebracht habe, was hier durch die Tomate durchging,
das Papier zersäbelt hat, ich schleife das nicht in der Regel.
Das schleife ich vielleicht einmal oder zweimal im Jahr.
Die meiste Zeit ziehe ich das nur so alle zwei Wochen mal übers Abziehleder,
um die durchs Schneiden entstandenen Imperfections schnell wegzupolieren.
Also es ist wirklich so ein 10 Sekunden, zack, zack, zack, 10 Sekunden andere
Seite und dann ist es wieder so scharf.
Das heißt, ich schleife so gut wie gar nicht mehr.
Das Ding ist die meiste Zeit nur dafür da, dass wenn ein Besuch kommt mit richtig
stumpfen Messern, dann gehe ich hier auf diese fette Platte drauf.
Ansonsten ist dieses wie heißt das denn?
Diamantleder irgendwie. Wir machen gleich das auf Schmiedeglut.
Verlinken wir das nochmal.
Mache ich damit. Und dieses Paddel, was Ralf angesprochen hat,
das ist im Prinzip dieselbe Metallplatte, dieselbe Körnung.
Und dann, ich glaube, Stufe 1 von dem Diamantleder ist hier drauf.
Und damit kommst du auch auf sehr, sehr gute Tomaten, wenn nicht sogar Rasierschärfe.
Das ist wirklich, wenn du wirklich so und die neue Version, die aktuelle Version
davon ist nochmal besser sogar, weil da kannst du den Griff rausschrauben und
da ist ein kegelförmiger,
Schleifstab, mit dem du auch Brotmesser, also alles was serrated, was heißt denn das auf.
Kugel oder Wellenschliff.
Wellenschliff hat, wo du halt auch Brotmesser mit schleifen kannst,
weil da kannst du halt nicht an so eine Platte oder sowas rangehen da musst
du jede Rille einmal mit so einem Kegelstab, sage ich mal.
Also jetzt nochmal kurz zusammenfassen. Also DMT, das ist jetzt die Firma aus
den USA, die macht irgendwie das geile Metall.
Du hast ja diesen Magna Base. Heißt das dann, dass das auch aus diesem Magna Material ist?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Und das ist diamantbeschichtet?
Mhm.
Okay.
Die Platten heißen Diasharp.
Ach so, der Adapter ist nur, um das Teil da oben drauf zu machen.
Genau, diese Platten, die kannst du dir in allen Körnungen sozusagen kaufen.
Gibt es auch so schöne Köfferchen zum Reifen.
Ach so, das ist sozusagen nur magnetisch da drauf. Deswegen heißt es Magna.
Genau.
Okay, gut. Und dann machst du da oben deinen Diasharp-Metall-Goldbarren da drauf.
Ja.
Und dann machst du genau was mit dem Messer, wenn du ein Stück das Messer schärfen würdest?
Jetzt kommt noch genau der Clou. Nämlich bei Schmiedeglut und ich habe keine
Affiliates und so, ich bin wirklich einfach nur Fan von dem,
was der Nandga sich so ausdenkt, um den Leuten das leicht zu machen.
Zu jedem Schleifprodukt, was man da kauft, kriegt man noch dieses kleine Stück Plastik dazu.
Das ist ein kleines Dreieck mit einem 18 und einem 13 Grad Winkel.
Und den kannst du dir hier, wie Ralf das gerade zeigt, also den legt man sozusagen
auf seine Schleifplatte und kann dann das Messer einmal so ausrichten auf den
Winkel, den man haben will, grob oder fein. Also kannst du dir so als kleine,
Winkelhilfe sozusagen mal kurz unterlegen und immer überprüfen,
gerade am Anfang, wenn man noch nicht so den Muscle Memory hat,
gucken, habe ich das jetzt immer noch im richtigen Winkel?
Was ist denn der richtige Winkel jetzt?
Naja, Nanka sagt 13 und 18 Grad.
Was denn jetzt, 13 oder 18?
13 für, was ich vorhin meinte, für feine Küchenmesser arbeiten und für Outdoor-Messer
oder Axt oder sonst was. Genau.
Und dann, das sind die DMT-Produkte, wobei...
Warte mal, das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe, dieses Diamantleder,
was quasi nur auf der einen Seite Leder hat, auf der anderen Seite hat es Metall,
ist eigentlich alles, was man braucht.
Man braucht nicht diesen Base-Adapter.
Das ist alles Overkill. Ich würde sagen, wenn man wenn man wirklich das Maximum
rausholen will, ist das schon geil und gerade auch noch jetzt mit diesem Vainschliff.
Also dieses Viererteil.
Genau. Aber Ralf kann ja auch gleich mal sagen, ich habe das schon ein paar
Mal verschenkt, weil es halt auch, was weiß ich, was kostet das? 69 Euro oder sowas?
Genau, das ist gut finanzierbar, ja.
Das habe ich schon ein paar Mal verschenkt, weil Leute haben schon von mir ein
Messer geschliffen bekommen und wollten dann, haben dann so,
kommst du dieses Weihnachten wieder vorbei und vielleicht vor dem Kochen.
Was früher Computer einrichten war, ist jetzt besser schleifen.
Ein Produkt nenne ich noch, bevor wir hier noch in die Feinanalyse kommen und
das ist hier mein Butterfly.
Das ist in meiner Reisebox immer dabei. Ferienhaus, Airbnb, Segelboot.
Einmal quasi Diafold heißt der, glaube ich. Das ist auch direkt von DMT.
Äh, steht das hier vielleicht mal drauf? Es gibt alles im Schmiedeglut-Shop,
falls ihr dann mal gucken wollt.
Aber im Prinzip ist das so ein kleiner, portabler Schleif.
Entschuldigung, wie heißt das Teil?
Ich glaube, Diafold. Also wie Falten. Ich gucke mal hier bei Schmiedeglut.
In verschiedenen Körnungen erhältlich.
Genau, ich würde sagen, wenn ihr auf Reisen seid und ihr habt es schon öfter
gehabt, dass in eurem Airbnb oder wo auch immer, ihr so seid und das Geschirr
benutzen müsst, was da ist.
Und die Messer sind alle scheiße stumpf, was sie grundsätzlich eigentlich immer
sind, weil es halt irgendwelche Ikea-Messer sind.
Nehme ich das Ding mit, setze mich dann bei der Reise halt mal 10 Minuten oder
20 Minuten hin, mache so die vielversprechendsten aussehendsten Küchenmesser
kurz scharf und die restlichen zwei oder drei Wochen sind alle Leute beim Kochen glücklich,
weil sie nicht die Tomaten drücken, sondern schneiden.
Und beim Zwiebelschneiden nicht weinen, sondern sich freudig fröhlich unterhalten
können. Das ist auf jeden Fall immer auf Reisen dabei.
Das kannst du mir auch bitte mal zeigen.
Übrigens kleiner Nachtrag zu den Zwiebeln, das hat natürlich mit ätherischen
Ölen alles nichts zu tun, sondern durch das Schneiden setzt man schwefelhaltige Aminosäuren frei und,
außerdem auch noch ein Enzym namens Alinase und wenn die zusammenkommen,
dann bildet sich der eigentliche reizende Stoff,
ein sogenanntes Propantial-S-Oxid und das verdunstet leicht und dann reicht
es eben über die Luft schnell die Augen und reizt die Nerven im Auge und dann
ist es also ätherisch hat es nichts zu tun.
Auch nicht esoterisch. Bist du zufrieden jetzt mit deinem Schleifergebnis?
Das klingt noch nicht gut.
Mit dem Clean hier auf Reisen, Ich weiß nicht. Ob man dann nicht doch einfach
irgendwie das Paddel mitnimmt.
Ja, ich habe auch manchmal das noch mit, also das passt halt überall mit rein,
weil es halt so klein ist.
Das nehme ich tatsächlich bei der Workation, nehme ich das mit,
weil dann ist schon dieses Abzähleder nochmal.
Okay, also ich passe mal zusammen. Wenn ihr Schleifsteine zu Hause habt, schmeißt sie weg.
Es sei denn, ihr kommt gut mit denen klar. Da müsst ihr natürlich nichts wegschmeißen.
Wenn ihr einen Haul-Schleifer habt, Das schenkt sich irgendjemandem,
den ihr eigentlich nicht leiden könnt.
Die finde ich dann toll und du bist los. Und ansonsten, wenn man irgendwie ordentlich
was geschliffen bekommen will,
muss man eigentlich nur so einen kleinen Plastikwinkelapparat haben und das
Ganze auf einer Metallplatte ein paar Mal hin und her.
Immer nach rückwärts sozusagen.
Nee, ist egal. Du kannst in Kreisen vor und zurück. Das Wichtigste ist nur,
am Ende musst du diesen Grat abrechnen.
Diese letzten zwei, die sind gegen die Klinge.
Auch das Metall. Und dann das Leder, um das nochmal richtig schön.
Auf dem Leder dann weg von der Klinge sozusagen.
Ansonsten schneidest du nämlich das Leder kaputt.
Ich hab mal ganz kurz noch in den Chat dieses bei Schmiedeglot,
weil ich wirklich, ich hab die Messer und die sind sehr gut.
Wenn ihr mal so einen Küchenmessersatz braucht, zum Beispiel so ein kleines
Schälmesser, dieses Dantoko, was ich habe, und das Brotmesser, geil.
Es gibt auch das Set zum Beispiel dieses Dantokomesser mit gleich diesem Paddel dazu.
Wenn ihr dieses Paddel da kauft also deren Schleifwerkzeuge da gibt es auch
so ein Set was ganz geil ist, die geben dir dann so einen kleinen Schleifschwamm
und Pasten mit, wenn nämlich dieses Leder irgendwann so schwarz ist,
so annähernd so schwarz ist wie meins,
dann kann man mit so einem kleinen Schleifschwamm, den du da kaufen kannst und
für ein paar Euro noch die Pasten kurz mal das gröbste wieder wegnehmen,
das mit der Paste wieder einbalsamieren und dann hast du die nächsten tausend
Messerschliffe wieder deine Ruhe.
Also und die YouTube-Videos, wo Nandga diverse Male auf verschiedensten Arten
und Weisen zeigt, wie man dann ein Messer schleift und wie man sich vielleicht
hilft, diesen Winkel, dieses Winkel halten zu lernen.
Kann ich alle sehr empfehlen, hat mir auch geholfen. Das geilste Video war eigentlich
eins der letzten, wo er meinte, pass auf, wenn ihr irgendwie gar keine Ahnung
habt und euch jetzt den Winkel mitnehmen, ist euch auch zu blöd.
Einfach vorstellen, ihr würdet jetzt statt ein Messer schleifen,
ihr würdet jetzt was schnitzen.
Also jeder kennt irgendwie, hat so intuitiv das Gefühl, wenn ich jetzt eine
Rinde von einem Ästchen wegschnitzen würde, welcher Winkel ist das?
Und das Wichtige ist einfach nur, den möglichst beizubehalten.
Konstanz.
Und das zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie ein neues Messer,
was ich nicht kenne, das hat garantiert nicht weder 13 noch 18 Grad,
dann musst du halt am Anfang mal grob sozusagen eine neue Phase raufschleifen.
Da Grund reinbringen.
Und danach, dieser Nachschliff, der ist dann total trivial einfach und dauert nicht lange.
Das ist halt nur einmal so die initiale, ja der Grundschliff, ne?
Ja, also während Tuckl jetzt hier die Ausführung gebracht hat,
habe ich jetzt also meine vier Messer hier bearbeitet auf meinem Paddel und
habe die also in jeweils, wie lange war ich dazu gegangen, eine Minute pro Messer
jetzt auf eine Schärfe gebracht,
dass sie in einem Zug durch die Temate durchgehen.
Zeig mal her eins, da will ich ja auch nochmal kurz testen, Moment.
Die werden jetzt wahrscheinlich noch nicht so scharf sein.
Ja, aber wir können jetzt ja mal gucken.
Wir sind da, glaube ich, in der Gut Enough.
Wenn, jetzt kann man noch diese zwei anderen Seiten vom Diamantleder kurz mal drüberjagen.
Könnte man tun.
Dann gucken, ob es einen Unterschied gibt bei.
Da geht noch was.
Da geht noch was. Hier hat der Haul auf jeden Fall vorne die Spitze versaut,
weil die geht gar nicht durch.
Hinten ist schon ganz gut. Genau, so. Und jetzt probieren wir mal,
da ihm noch ein bisschen mehr zu geben.
So, jetzt kommt das Diamant. Wie heißt das Teil? Nochmal?
Das ist, ja, ich weiß, da ultimatives Schärfwerkzeug. Wie heißt das richtig
dann? Klick mal da auf den Link da oben.
Fünffach Schärfsystem. Diamantleder Unlimited.
Ja, ich habe noch den Vorgänger, der hat nicht diesen Wetzkegelstaben noch mit drin.
Also man muss dazu sagen, weil wir gerade eben so hier ein bisschen auf Haul
gebasht haben, was deren PR angeht, das macht natürlich dieser Typ von Schmiedeglut
auf seine Art ganz genauso.
Also mich triggert der auch. Ich finde den ziemlich eklig.
Ist doch alles ganz einfach und lasst euch da keinen Quatsch erzählen.
Ja, aber es ist am Ende des Tages klar, du musst ein bisschen investieren,
aber die Grundsätze, die er so sagt.
Und auch so dieser AB-Test, die er dann macht, so als Pseudowissenschaftler
will ich dann auch sagen, ja, da hast du ja auch die eine oder andere Abkürzung gerade mal genommen.
Aber hast du die Follow-Up-Videos gesehen, weil er ist ja auf die ganze Kritik
da noch eingegangen, ne?
So, aber nichtsdestotrotz, dieses Produkt ist schon so, dass man damit arbeiten kann.
So, jetzt gucke ich nochmal, ob sich das hier gelohnt hat.
Ist immer noch auf jeden Fall nicht ganz Mackenfrei.
Wüsste man wahrscheinlich in der Tat nochmal mit dem Stahl, mit der Stahl-Diamant-Seite ran.
Gut.
Zumindest ist es jetzt hier eigentlich alles übertrieben. Schmiede,
Glut, Diamantleder, essentiell, 60 Euro.
Das kann man auf jeden Fall.
Und man ist sozusagen schon im Messerglück.
Ja.
Eine Sache wollte ich zum Schluss noch, wir haben ja gesagt,
Wir reden nicht über Messer, aber es gibt wirklich viele gute Messer.
Aber das hier ist mein totaler Liebling.
Und es geht ja auch immer so ein bisschen um Design und Ästhetik in diesem Podcast.
Apple hat ja mal eine Rolle gespielt.
Es gibt ein Messer, was ich jahrelang immer total belächelt hatte,
weil ich dachte so, das ist doch nur Poser-Tum.
Das ist nämlich die von Chroma, die 301-Serie.
Designed by F.A. Porsche.
Und diese Messer sehen schon sehr speziell aus. Ich würde sagen,
die sehen aus wie keine anderen Messer da draußen.
Die zeichnen sich durch zwei Dinge aus. Nämlich erstens, dass sie aus einem
einzigen Stück Stahl bestehen.
Das heißt, es macht nicht einen Griff und dann irgendwie eine Klinge,
sondern es ist alles ein einziges Objekt.
In der Mitte hat man dann so eine kleine Kuddel drin, so eine kleine...
So eine Niete quasi von beiden Seiten, damit man einen Griffpunkt hat und nicht
ganz so in dem Glatten ist.
Und der Griff selber, das ist so ein bisschen wie das neue World Trade Center, wie heißt das?
Freedom Tower.
Freedom Tower, genau. Ihr habt so ein bisschen die Form, dass es plötzlich so
von einem quadratischen Grundriss sich einmal so zusammenschiebt und dann oben
irgendwie auf was anderem rauskommt und man denkt so, was war das denn?
Das ist ein bisschen eine ähnliche Form und man denkt sich, das ist doch reines
Design und Overthinking, aber ich kenne in der Tat kein Messer,
was zumindest in meiner Hand so gut drin liegt und ausbalanciert ist.
Ich finde, das ist ein spektakulär gut handhabbares Messer und das habe ich
jetzt auch schon, ich glaube, 15 Jahre, 20 Jahre.
Und das ist eine 14 cm Klinge. Das ist, finde ich, auch so ein Faktor.
Ich finde die klassischen Santokos mit so 18 cm schon zu groß,
weil ich mit dem praktisch alles schneide. Und dann ist das eine super Zwischengröße.
Und letzter Kniff, den das hat, du kannst es hinstellen. Dafür ist das Design auch gemeint.
Und in die Tischplatte schneiden.
Nee, weil es also quasi auf den ganz, ganz untersten Pin der Schneide dann aufliegt
und die ist einfach mal nicht besonders scharf.
Und dann kippt es aber nicht um. Das heißt, du hast nicht ständig irgendwie
ein querliegendes Messer, wo du schon ständig dich wieder ein bisschen mit der
Tischplatte eine Unschärfe reinbringst.
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich, also ich habe mir irgendwann so einen Messerschubladeneinsatz
von Zwillingen besorgt, wo die Messer alle so drin liegen.
Deswegen, wenn ich mit dem Schneiden fertig bin, dann wird das schnell geputzt
und kommt auch wieder rein.
Ja, aber du musst es ja auf deinem Schneidbrett irgendwie ablegen.
Und da fängt ja das Übel schon an.
So, und auch dieses Problem hat dieses Messer gelöst. Also ich finde es,
weil es ist super zu reinigen, weil du halt nie diesen Übergang hast von Griff
zu irgendwas anderem. Das heißt, es ist also eine einzige Fläche, die man reinigt.
Die gibt es noch online zu kaufen. Jetzt hat man hier drüber geworfen,
dass die irgendwie insolvent wären und ähnliches.
Hoffe ich mal nicht. Das Design gibt es, glaube ich, seit 25 Jahren.
Episch. Gibt es also in verschiedenen Formen. 301 von Chroma.
Probiert das mal aus im Laden, wenn ihr das irgendwo seht.
Das ist also eben nicht nur ein Design-Klassiker, sondern auch etwas,
was vom Handling her, finde ich, spektakulär gut ist.
Ja, ich finde ja eh, also ein Griff muss schwer sein.
Also ein Messer muss man spüren und damit man das auch irgendwie gut führen
kann, braucht es einfach ein gewisses Gewicht. Das ist ja schon mal das Hauptproblem.
Mach das mal nicht immer mit diesen Fingern.
Das ist geil. Es gibt wirklich die Leute, die sagen, nee, will ich nicht sehen.
Ja, jetzt musst du ja hier die Kontrolle über die Sendung beibehalten.
Dein Messer ist schon absurd scharf.
Und das ist nicht mal, also das ist jetzt so nach einer Woche rumkochen,
das ist dann nach der Frischpolitur noch besser.
Das ist jetzt gar nicht so scharf. Durch die Temate, da hat es sogar schon Schwierigkeiten.
Die Temate?
Also guck mal hier vorne, Huckel, was ist da los?
Ja, ja, ich sag das. Ich hab das nicht vorher geschärft, bevor ich hierher gekommen bin.
So doll ist das nicht. Also die richtigen Pausermesser, da gibt es ja noch quasi
den Tomaten-Plus-Test.
da legst du es vor dir hin, dass die Schneide nach oben guckt und lässt von
oben die Tomate drauf fallen und dann wird dir nichts passieren, aber dutscht halt weg.
Und bei diesen Pausermessern ist alleine quasi das Fallen der Tomate reicht,
dass sie von der Schneide dutscht.
Vielleicht muss sie von etwas höher fallen lassen.
Das würde funktionieren, aber das Ding ist halt auch, das ist halt auch wieder ein Kompromiss.
Wenn du halt die so fein schleifst und so dünn machst, dann hält die halt auch
nicht lange, weil dann nach ein bisschen Arbeiten das schon wieder abgebrochen
ist und dann musst du halt wieder nachpolieren.
Ich mache auch meine Messer jetzt nicht alle auf Skalpellschärfe,
sondern es ist immer so, ich will beim Schneiden nie drücken müssen und nie weinen müssen.
Und dann ist es auch schon gut.
Genau, also das ist die Botschaft, wenn das mit dem Papierschneiden funktioniert
und wenn ihr in einem Zug durch die Tenate durchkommt, dann ist es auch echt mal good enough.
Alles darüber hinaus muss man dann schon sehr… Beziehungsweise.
Ich sag mal so, meine Messer sind so scharf, dass ich mir irgendwann so ein
Pflaster-Kit in eine Küchenschublade gelegt habe, weil ab und zu macht man so
eine unüberlegte Bewegung und dann ist rot auf dem Tisch.
Aber eine Sache, die ich noch zum Abschluss sagen wollte, ist,
wenn euch das alles zu viel ist und hier, wie Tim schon sagte,
dieses Essential, das reicht vollkommen,
um eine sinnvolle Küchenschärfe easy beizubehalten, muss nur ein bisschen üben
und welche Messer kann man so im 0815-Handel bekommen, die gut sind.
Ich finde WMF persönlich nicht so geil.
Meine Standardempfehlung so für Leute, die nicht groß überlegen oder irgendwie
Boutique shoppen, ist immer Wüsthof oder Zwilling und da auch nicht die günstigsten
Serien, aber die machen auch beide,
also die gibt es überall zu kaufen und machen auch sehr solide Messer.
Messer Wüsthoff ist halt so die Standard-Chef-Knife-Firma, also dieses Standard-Deutsche
mit diesem schwarz genieteten Griff und so weiter, das ist so synonym fast mit Wüsthoff.
Ja, so sind ja auch diese WMF-Spitzenklasse genauso, die habe ich.
Spitzenklasse plus.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall.
Das ist einfach nur Spitzenklasse.
Das Wichtige ist eigentlich nur, dass es idealerweise nicht die günstigste aller
Serien ist, weil nicht nur,
vielleicht ist der Stahl sogar ganz gut, aber diese Balance von dem Messer und
diese Gewichtung und dass der Griff sich nicht löst oder nicht Wasser da reinkommt
oder diese ganzen Sachen,
die sind dann bei den etwas, nur ein bisschen, Ein bisschen mehr als total günstigstes Modell.
Da ist das alles schon ein bisschen besser.
Wüsthof und was war das andere?
Zwillingen macht auch sehr gute.
Es geht nichts darüber, es im Laden mal auszuprobieren. Ich würde in der Tat
auch sagen, was damit schneiden.
Bei meinem Dänemark-Urlaub hatten die ein Ikea-Santoku in unserer Urlaubsküche.
Das war sogar okay scharf noch. Da haben offensichtlich sich nicht viele Leute dran getraut.
So ein Santoku muss man ja auch erst mal wollen. wenn die nicht nur so von so
kleinen Schnibbelmessern kommen.
Aber das war einfach scheiße vom Druckpunkt her.
Also wenn ihr damit irgendwie ein bisschen was Härteres, sagen wir mal einen
Apfel irgendwie in der Mitte durchschneiden wollt, das hast du gemerkt,
das passt nicht für meine Hand.
So in andere Hände mag das gut passen, aber dieser Übergang von Griff zur Klinge,
das war alles nicht gut ausbalanciert, hat einfach nicht funktioniert.
Also man muss es schon, finde ich, ausprobieren.
Ich würde ja gerne, vielleicht um das Messerthema dann auch noch abzurunden.
Naja, wir haben genug gemessert.
Ja, die eigentliche Frage ist ja, es gibt ja so viele Messertypen.
Welcher Messertyp bist du?
Welcher Messertyp bist du denn? Naja, was ihr für Messertypen seid,
das haben wir jetzt alle gemerkt. Ganz scharfe Nummer, ne?
Nö, ich meine nur, also ich habe mich natürlich auch gefragt,
jetzt wenn man sozusagen so eine Küchenausrüstung bei Null startet,
was brauchst du eigentlich?
Und ich habe versucht, mit dem Minimum zu starten, merke schon, da geht noch was.
Wie gesagt, Brotmesser war ein bisschen Vierkaufpunkt bis.
Kochmesser ist sozusagen, finde ich, meiner Meinung nach das Universalmesser
für eigentlich alle Fälle.
Es gibt ja so Leute, die sind der Meinung, so große Messer, wann sollte man die denn benutzen?
Aber es macht meiner Meinung nach einfach sehr oft Sinn, weil die haben einfach am meisten Wumms.
Und man hat auch, obwohl die so groß und schwer sind, dadurch meiner Auffassung
nach mehr Kontrolle, weil einfach diese Trägheit der Masse dann dabei auch noch hilft.
Aber es gibt ja dann noch so diverse andere Messer.
Fleischmesser, Gemüsemesser, die schon mehrfach erwähnten Santoku Formen was
würdet ihr jetzt sagen ist wofür praktisch.
Also, meiner Meinung nach braucht man drei Messer.
Ein Brotmesser hatten wir schon. Das güde Brotschwert, alles andere taugt nichts.
Es gibt schon noch andere gute Brotmesser, aber ja.
Das ist schon sehr gut, das ist aber auch arsch.
Naja, 120 Euro ist jetzt auch noch nicht völlig absurd.
Ich habe hier eher für 200 Euro gesehen.
Ja, es kommt drauf an, was für eine Holzgriffform man dann so nimmt.
Also die fangen an bei 129.
So, das zweite Messer, was man finde ich schon braucht, ist ein kleines Schnibbelmesser,
womit man dann doch irgendwie in kleine Details reinkommt.
So, und was nun da genau, ob man eine gerade Klinge nimmt, eine leicht gebogene,
wie das, was ich jetzt hier gerade habe, was für eine Griffform,
das finde ich, muss man einfach ausprobieren.
So, und das dritte, das ist jetzt aber halt meine Meinung oder das,
worauf ich mich auch einfach getunt habe, ist in der Tat dann ein Santoku mit
nicht zu langer Klinge. Also ich sehe das mit dem Kochmesser,
aber traditionell ein europäisches Kochmesser ist so 20 Zentimeter plus.
Das finde ich persönlich zu groß. Damit komme ich in Detail-Schnittgeschichten
irgendwie nicht mehr rein.
Von daher mache ich praktisch alles mit einer 14 cm Klinge und das sind dann
von der Form her, finde ich da in der Tat Santokus am praktischsten,
weil mit denen kannst du sowohl hacken, du kannst durchschieben,
du kannst problemlos eine Paprika von innen aushöhlen beispielsweise,
das ist mit einem europäischen Kochmesser 22 cm.
Mit dem Kochmesser, da gehst du ja mit dem Gemüsemesser.
Nee, aber habe ich halt nicht, brauche ich nicht, weil ich habe halt ein Santoku.
Ist doch ein Gemüsemesser hier ein kleines.
Das ist auch ein Santoko.
Nein, das Kleine.
Ach so, das Kleine. Ja, aber dann muss ich ja das Messer wechseln.
Warum soll ich das tun, wenn ich das mit demselben machen kann?
Ach so, du siehst sozusagen das Santoko so als Universalgröße.
Darum heißt es das Messer der Drei Tugenden. Das ist die wörtliche Übersetzung.
Santoko heißt Drei Tugenden.
Santoko heißt Drei Tugenden?
Aber ja.
Wie machen die das in so wenigen Silben, so viel Bedeutung?
Ja, so sind sie die Asiaten. Und damit kannst du Fleisch machen, Fisch und Gemüse.
Das heißt also, in der traditionellen japanischen Küche ist eben ein Santoku
das alles Messer für alles.
Was bei uns ein europäisches Kochmesser ist, nur dass man halt beim Santoku
ist, man eher bei 18 Zentimeter, nicht bei 20 bis 22 wie bei den europäischen.
Und ich persönlich, aber das ist jetzt ein persönliches Ding,
bin sogar lieber bei 14 bis 16 Zentimeter.
Aber das ist dann eine Frage ein bisschen des Stils.
Aber mit diesen drei Klassen kommt man sehr, sehr hoch.
Also ich würde auch sagen, ich habe ja so einen Zwilling-Messer-Blog gehabt.
Ich habe übrigens jetzt nochmal diese Messerschubladeneinsätze auch nochmal in den Chat getan.
Vielleicht finden die die auch in die Shownotes noch, weil das,
danach hatte ich lange gesucht vorher.
Was im Chat kommt, landet alles in den Shownotes.
Okay, perfekt, ja. Ich hatte auch so einen Zwilling-Messer-Blog mit so einem
fetten Kochmesser und so kleinen und dann so einem Brotmesser und dies und das und jenes.
Und seitdem ich dieses Messer habe und das Kneipchen, das kleine.
Also dieses Messer ist das dann Deko?
Genau, das Schmiedeglut-Santoku, das ist ein bisschen größer als...
Das wird 18 haben, würde ich sagen.
Ist aber immer noch kleiner als mein Zwilling. Und ich muss auch sagen,
ich benutze nur, also ich persönlich benutze eigentlich nur dieses Messer zum
Kochen, ausschließlich für kleines wie großes.
Es sei denn, es ist ein Kürbis, dann hole ich das fette Zwilling-Kochmesser
raus, weil das einfach dann noch ein bisschen mehr Beilcharakter hat und so weiter.
Der große Unterschied bei den Santokos zu den vielen Chefkochmessern oder Kochmessern
in deutscher Stilart ist,
dass diese Chefkochmesser oft hinten so einen Schutzknebel dran haben,
damit du mit dem Finger nicht hier an diese fiese, scharfe Kante kommst.
Weißt du, wovon ich spreche?
Geh mal kurz auf Wüsthoff oder sowas.
Bei Wüsthoff hast du wahrscheinlich Kochmesser direkt auf der ersten Seite.
Wie nennt man das da hinten? Diesen Keilkegel Fingerschutz.
Der führt einerseits dazu, dass du nicht da rankommst. In der Praxis passiert das aber eh nicht.
Und der Nachteil davon ist, dass du nie bis ganz hinten gut schärfen kannst,
weil der immer im Weg ist, um den letzten Millimeter da von der Klinge zu erwischen. Aber...
Und auch nicht durchschneiden. Das heißt, du kannst es nicht einfach komplett
durchgleiten lassen, weil du hängst dann immer halt da an der Ecke fest.
Und da dachte ich so am Anfang, ich weiß nicht, also gerade hier bei dem hier,
das sieht halt voll gefährlich aus, aber effektiv habe ich mich noch nie an
dieser Stelle geschnitten, sondern immer wo anders.
Also das ist halt, ja, darauf kann man zum Beispiel auf verzichten,
Aber es gibt auch von Wüsthof, Zwilling und all den anderen meist so Kochmesser,
die nicht diesen Fingerschutz-Knebel-Dingsbums haben, wenn man das nicht will.
Aber genau, also ich habe ein Brotmesser auch. Ich habe ein anderes,
ich habe nicht das Güde-Brotstatt. Ich habe so ein bisschen,
das sieht ein bisschen säbelmäßiger aus.
Welches?
Weiß ich gerade nicht aus dem Kopf.
Und dann habe ich noch die vom Zwilling, die habe ich nicht weggeschmissen.
Die benutze ich so gut wie nie. Von Schmiedeglut habe ich noch dieses Kleine, das Kneipchen.
Wenn ich mal Besuch habe, die Freundin da ist, manchmal mögen Gäste lieber kleine Messer.
Dann wird das Kneipchen oder die anderen Gemüsemesser benutzt,
aber ich bin auch Santoco only für die meiste Zeit.
Das ist the way. Fernsehköche sind jetzt bekanntermaßen kein Maßstab für irgendwas.
Aber ich würde sagen, 80% sind die auch auf Santokus unterwegs.
Also es hat einfach schon so eine gewisse Mainstreamigkeit.
Ich werde auch mal sein Toko nachrüsten. Das war mir nicht so ganz klar,
aber das Argument kann ich nachvollziehen. Mal schauen.
Noch ein echter Pro-Tipp. Wenn ihr dann irgendwie Zwiebeln gehackt habt,
auf einem vernünftigen, darüber haben wir nicht geredet, Grundlage ist natürlich
ein vernünftiges Schneidbrett.
Je größer, desto besser und je schwerer und stabiler. Bloß nicht auf so einem
kleinen Ding anfangen rumzuschnibbeln, wo alles wegrutscht und so,
sondern eins, was sich so vorne in die Kante reingreift und dann wirklich große,
Arbeitsfläche für euch bereitet.
So und jetzt hast du deine Zwiebel geschnibbelt und wie kriegst du die jetzt
in die Pfanne oder in den Topf oder was auch immer?
Niemals mit der Schneide dann irgendwie zusammenkehren, sondern umdrehen das
Santoku und mit der, zum Glück beim Santoku, dann ja glatten Rückseite schieben.
Ja, das ist wirklich so, wenn du so ins Messerschärfen so ein bisschen reingekommen
bist, Und dann so Leute sind sie mit der Klinge quer übers Brett oder so auf
Keramiktellern so richtig so reinhacken und so. Oh nein.
Da hast du dich 20 Minuten abgemühlt und mit einer Bewegung machst du alles wieder kaputt.
Warum? Niemals in die Waschmaschine, niemals einfach so in eine Küche,
in eine Schublade, wo es gegen zig andere Objekte dran dutscht, die Schneide.
Und halt niemals mit der Schneide Sachen zusammen kämen.
Kann man schon machen.
Sondern mit der Rückseite. Du kannst es schon so machen, dann wird es uns gar nicht.
Und diese eine Drehung, ja, einfach auf die Rückseite drehen und dann schieben,
das ist so einfach, wenn man es einmal kapiert hat, dass es wichtig ist.
So, was habt ihr jetzt nicht alles gelernt in dieser Freakshow?
Guck, Service am Kunden.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Welcher Stuhl quietscht denn hier so?
Das ist traditionell meiner.
Du hast den Hamster.
Ist es der Stuhl oder ist es, was quietscht da?
Nee, das ist der Stuhl. Wir haben es alle ein paar Sendungen,
wird es thematisiert und du wirst es nicht wahrhaben.
Ich habe noch ein Ersatz-Headset und einen Ersatzstuhl, habe ich auch noch.
Ja, ich versuche jetzt einfach weniger rumzuhebeln.
Auf Phonik wird es richten.
So, jetzt können wir, jetzt haben wir noch so ein bisschen für den,
für das letzte Viertel, da hätten wir noch zwei diametral unterschiedliche Ausrichtungen.
Ja, das eine ist mehr so Urlaub, Reise, Outdoor.
Würde jetzt mehr an das Messer-Thema anschließen, sozusagen,
um den praktischen Teil zu Ende zu bringen.
Und wir müssen natürlich auch noch mal ein bisschen über Software reden.
über Development. So als Rausschmeißer.
Developers, Developers, Developers. Ja.
So, ich räume mir erstmal die Küche wieder auf.
Nicht über Flugsimulatoren. Nein, okay. Ja, such dir was aus.
Naja, ich meine so thematisch. Also, bleiben wir mal bei diesem Gerätezeug und
so. Ich habe mir schon ein anderes Produkt, was du mir, glaube ich, empfohlen hast.
Den Knipex Twinkie.
Den Knipex Twinkie, den habe ich jetzt auch.
Den habe ich zwar noch nicht zum Einsatz gebracht, aber ich habe ihn jetzt zumindest
mal ins Holster überführt sozusagen.
Mal gucken, was er so leistet.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Tipp. Kannst du dir mal was zu sagen?
Ja, ich weiß auch. Ich habe irgendwie so einen YouTube-Kanal,
wo so ein Typ, der mal einen Laden hatte, wo er so ganz viel Gadget und EDC,
also Everyday Carry, so Kram, den man so in seiner,
in seinem Fannypack so mit sich rumträgt, weil man denkt, man müsste auf jede
Situation vorbereitet sein.
Und der hat halt immer so relativ trockene und wenig gehypte Videos,
wo er so neue Gadgets vorstellt, die er so gefunden hat.
Und eins davon eines Tages war dieser Knipex oder Kniepex Twinkie, heißt der wirklich so?
Ja. Und da ist mir sofort das Essen aus den Augen gefallen, weil das ist ein
zweifacher Kreuzschlüssel, könnte man das vielleicht nennen,
mit Schlüsseln für Dreikant, Vierkant, Schaltschränke, S-Bahn-Türen,
Fenster, Schranken, Boller,
you name it.
alles, was an Hindernissen einem vielleicht den Weg versperren könnte, kann man damit öffnen.
Oder zumindest sehr viel davon. Und das...
Habe ich persönlich auch nicht oft, aber es gab immer mal so Situationen,
wo ich dachte, das wäre schon geil, wenn man jetzt dieses Fenster aufmachen
könnte, voll stickig hier.
Moment, ich habe, lass mal gucken, oh ja, er passt sehr schön.
Oder zumachen, wenn man wieder auf irgendeinem Bahnklo, so einen Schrank die
ganze Zeit auf und zu ballert, weil er nicht richtig abgeschlossen wurde.
Jetzt hat man zugegebenermaßen nicht unbedingt diesen Twinkie immer dabei, aber man könnte.
Man könnte alles klein genug. Ich habe halt so eine kleine Tasche,
wo ich so diverse kleine Helferlein, die sich auch schon in der Vergangenheit
wirklich bewiesen haben als nützlich.
Da ist auch noch ein zweites Produkt von Kniepacks dabei gleich.
Und da ist der halt auch immer mit drin. und ja, wenn ich irgendwie so auf Reisen
bin und das Ding eh irgendwie noch im Gepäck ist, dann ja.
Aber ich habe es, glaube ich, viel mehr so lokal in meinem Kiez angewendet als auf Reisen bisher.
Pst. Ja, aber es ist auf jeden Fall für so eine längere Reise ist es definitiv
etwas, was man sich zurechtlegen könnte.
Der heißt Twin Key besteht tatsächlich irgendwo grob auch aus zwei Komponenten,
die magnetisch zusammengehalten sind.
Eigentlich ist es mehr so ein Octo-Key, man könnte sogar Deka-Key sagen,
weil da ist ja auch noch so ein kleiner
Ring noch mit dran, der alles dann zusammen hält, wo nochmal so ein,
Steckteil ist für einen Akkuschrauber.
Also wo man immer noch ein Kreuz und einen Schlitz hat, den man so direkt einen
Akkuschrauber reinmachen kann.
Manchmal auch nicht so richtig dabei oder eben auch einfach mal so von der Hand
irgendwie Schlitz und Kreuz aufdrehen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, kann man den da in diesen Twin Key reinmachen?
Genau, du kannst den da, ich glaube
auf der unteren Seite kannst du den reinstecken und kannst den so als,
oder einer von den vierkanten passt dann oder irgendwie ist,
also du kannst den irgendwie da reinstecken und den Key so als.
Ah ja genau, hier in einem von den vierkanten reinmachen, genau,
alles klar, ja genau, cool.
So und dann damit kriegt man irgendwie alles auf, was jetzt nicht richtig ein
Schloss ist, aber sich eben auch nicht einfach mal so Ich sag dir.
Sobald du das Ding irgendwie hast.
Plötzlich siehst du überall diese Dinger.
Dabei besteht das ganze Ding nur noch aus Opportunities.
Ja, genau. Das ist wirklich so.
Ja, was früher so der Leatherman ist, ist jetzt vielleicht so der Twinkie.
Genau.
Ein zweites Produkt von Kniepacks, was ich wirklich so, also noch viel öfter
als den Twin Key selbst verwendet habe und was echte Probleme gelöst hat.
Und es würde jetzt sehr banal klingen, aber es ist die Kniepex Cobra,
Und zwar in der 125 Millimeter als auch in der 180 Millimeter Variante.
Habe ich mir letzte Woche eine gekauft.
Ja.
Und es ist einfach die einzige Wasserpumpenzange, die man benutzen darf.
Und alle anderen müssen verboten werden.
Es ist. Also Wasserpumpenzange finde ich auch anders hält das Ganze,
weil ich habe das Ding benutzt auf Segelbooten, um verranzte Gasflaschen,
den Druckregulierer abzuschrauben und wieder anzuschrauben.
Dosen, also so Schraubgläser, die man einfach mit der bloßen Hand nicht aufkriegt.
Mit der 125er wird es ein bisschen schwierig manchmal, aber man kriegt einfach
Dinge auf, die man sonst nicht aufkriegt.
Also die haben richtig guten Grip und der Clou bei diesen Kobras ist,
das siehst du vielleicht nicht und wenn du sie nicht kennst,
weißt du es vielleicht nicht auch vom Bild her, Die haben so einen Druckknopf
und den drückst du, stellst dann deine gewünschte Rasterung ein,
lässt los und es bleibt da.
Du hast nie, wie bei, wie heißen diese anderen Wasserrohrzangen, wie dann immer so rum.
Da hast du halt diesen komischen, zur Hälfte gefüllten Zahn,
den du irgendwie immer, wenn du das Ding ein bisschen aufmachst,
kannst du den verschieben.
Aber das heißt auch, dass er sich während des Öffnens auch immer wieder gerne
von alleine verschiebt.
Und es ist Wahnsinn. Und diese Kobra, die hält einfach bombensicher und dann
hast du ein richtiges Tool.
Und die gibt es auch mit glatten Zangen, Backen, wie auch immer.
Ach so, ohne Zähne.
Genau, wenn man so an wirklich Wasserrohren, wo man jetzt die Schrauben,
die Mutter nicht zerkratzen will.
Ich glaube, die heißen anders, aber die haben dasselbe Prinzip.
Die heißen dann nicht Cobra.
Ja, ich glaube. Also es gibt die auf jeden Fall auch noch mit glatten Backenzangen
oder wie auch immer man es nennt.
Ah, da. Zangenschlüssel. Zack.
Der davor war es.
Gar nicht mal so teuer.
Und was ich auch wirklich sagen muss, die liegen extrem gut in der Hand.
Also die kleine, die 125er, die ist so ein bisschen süßer.
Da hat man die nicht so voll gut in der Hand vielleicht. Aber die 180er,
die liegt einfach auch so gut in der Hand. Man denkt so echt volle Koffer.
Da hat natürlich beides zu Hause rumliegend.
Ja, ja, ja.
Großartig.
Die Leute, die wissen, sie wissen.
Also die 180er, sagst du, die will man haben.
Das ist so die, die die allermeisten Probleme schon gelöst hat und trotzdem
noch relativ kompakt ist.
Die 125er, die finde ich persönlich ganz süß, weil die kann man wirklich immer
auch dabei haben. Die passt halt auch in so ein kleines Täschchen irgendwie.
Und damit kriegt man halt auch mal eine Flasche auf, die man sonst nicht aufkriegt.
Oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen, wo man so einen guten Hebel braucht.
und wo der Leatherman und die Leatherman-Zange mich schon oft enttäuscht hat.
Es gibt von Leatherman auch ein Multitool, was auch so um die Ecke hat,
ist aber eher ein obskures und dieser, ich weiß nicht, dieser Rohrzangen-Grip
und so und diese versetzte,
ja, ist schwer zu beschreiben, aber diese versetzten, gewinkelten Backen,
das ist einfach viel besser. Es gibt noch eine 150er.
Ist das dann nicht so ein Sweet-Spot vielleicht?
Vielleicht.
Ja, die Länge, da musst du einfach gucken.
Da musst du einfach alle mal bestellen.
Ja, es hängt jetzt einfach mal davon ab, was du machen willst.
Richtig lang brauchst du es halt nur, wenn wirklich richtig viel Hebel wirkt.
Aber 180 ist immer noch sehr kompakt. Ich hätte es ja auch mal eigentlich mitnehmen
können. Leider habe ich es nicht, aber...
Gerade auf Amazon hat es mich reduziert auf 18 Euro.
Hier habe ich sogar auch eine. Warte mal.
Ich habe ein paar von meinen Werkzeugkoffern mit Cobra nachgerüstet.
die weiß bloß jetzt gerade nicht, ob der...
Ja, gib mal eine her, wenn du eine hast, sehr gerne. Weil das ist in der Tat
so ein Tool, das braucht man ja nicht häufig, aber wenn ich es mal brauche,
dann ärgere ich mich auch.
Das ist mehr als 180.
Das ist die 250er.
Ja, die finde ich jetzt zum Beispiel schon...
Die ist auch schon recht groß.
Ja.
So, und wie funktioniert das jetzt hier mit diesem... Ah.
Ah, die ist sogar nochmal anders.
Wie anders?
Kann ich nochmal kurz...
Dann verschiebt man das so und dann rastet es...
Genau, weil es eigentlich nicht so hin und her schieben, sondern einfach nur
so ein Druckknopf, der da mit so einer Feder ist und ja.
Die ist aber schon älter, oder?
Ja, die neuen, die haben bessere Griffe, ja.
Ich habe einen schönen Einsatz gesehen hier. Aber die finde ich jetzt ja schon gar nicht mal so groß.
Ich sag dir, hört auf Huckel, 180 und 125 sind die goldenen Größen.
Weil 125 kannst du wirklich immer dabei haben, also immer, wenn du halt so ein
kleines Toolkit irgendwie dabei haben wird, die 180er,
Ein bisschen mehr, aber die löst dann auch noch härtere Probleme.
Also an einer Butangasflasche auf dem Segelboot, da ist die 125er dann nicht
mehr geeignet, um den Druckregulierer von
so einem verrosteten Gewinde runterzuschrauben. Da nehme ich die 180er.
Die würde natürlich hier die 200, was war es? 250er.
Die ist natürlich dann noch schneller, aber ich sage euch, für euch getestet. 180, 125.
Ich kaufe mir jetzt die 150er. Ich gehe jetzt hier ins Risiko und gucke.
Jeder Nerd muss seinen eigenen Weg gehen. Schreib mir in einem Jahr, wenn du die 180er hast.
Du hattest schon wieder recht.
Nein, es kann aber auch gut sein, dass die 150er auch cool ist.
Da bin ich nicht so festgelegt.
Und dann möchte ich noch ein, also aus meinem Gadget-Katalog,
möchte ich noch eine kleine Lanze brechen für mein liebstes Victorinox-Taschenmesser.
Es sind ja immer Kompromisse, diese Multitools und auch die Schweizer Taschenmesser und so weiter.
Und jetzt muss ich mal kurz nochmal gucken, nicht, dass ich einen Namen falsch sage.
Ich finde, eins ist der Champion von all denen, weil es so der beste Kompromiss
ist aus, wie groß ist es, wie leicht kann ich es mitnehmen und welche Tools sind da dran.
Und das ist das Victorinox Compact, tatsächlich heißt es.
Und das hat so eine geile Mischung aus Tools.
Es hat natürlich ein Messer, es hat natürlich einen Korkenzieher.
An dem Korkenzieher ist ein Brillenschraubendreher, den du gerade in deinem
iFixit-Tool gesucht hast, um deine Brillenbügel wieder festzuschrauben oder
was immer du gemacht hast.
Es ist eine Nadel drin, die auch sehr gut funktioniert, um aus altertümlichen
Telefonen die SIM-Karten rauszupulen.
Kannst du mal einen Link irgendwo reinspeisen?
Ja, ich lade gerade hier langsam die Seite.
Ist schon gepostet? Es hat natürlich eine Pinzette und einen Zahnstocher,
aber es hat als weiteren Clou einen Kugelschreiber.
Und wenn ich mich nicht recht täusche, ist der sogar pressurized.
Sprich, du kannst auch Upside Down schreiben damit.
Es hat eine sehr gute Schere. Also die Victory Knox Messer, eigentlich alle,
die eine Schere haben, das sind sehr, sehr gute Scheren.
Das sind nicht so flimsy, wackel Scheren, sondern man kann wirklich was damit schneiden.
Und dann hat es halt noch den Dosenöffner, Schrägstrich, flachen Schraubenzieher,
Schrägstrich, Flaschenöffner.
Auch noch dabei, das einzige Tool, und das ist halt der Kompromiss,
sonst wäre es wirklich das absolut Perfekte, da ist ja dieser Metallhaken dabei,
der sogenannte Parcel-Hook.
Es gibt einen Schweizer oder es gibt so einen YouTube-Kanal,
der sich ausschließlich damit beschäftigt, sinnvolle Anwendungen für diesen
Metallhaken vorzustellen.
Und es ist ein unglaublich geiler Nerd-Dive, weil der kommt auf die absurdesten
Konzepte, was man damit machen kann.
Aber angeblich ist es tatsächlich wirklich ein Parcel-Hook, der dafür sein soll,
Pakete, die mit einer dicken Bindschnur zusammengehalten sind,
irgendwie bequemer in einem Griff zu haben. Dieses Tool habe ich noch nie benutzt.
Ich würde es gerne ersetzen durch was anderes, aber alles andere ist perfekt.
Es ist auch sehr bezahlbar, 47 Euro und ich habe das auch schon so oft verwendet für alles Mögliche.
Und meine Freundin fand es so praktisch, dass sie sich das immer öfter ausleihen
wollte und jetzt habe ich ihr mal eins geschenkt, damit meins bei mir bleiben kann.
Aber ja, also finde ich gut.
Genau, also ich habe seit auch schon echt langer Zeit das Cyber-Tool von denen.
Das kennst du bestimmt auch.
Allerdings in einer kleineren Ausbauform als das, was ich jetzt hier gerade
bei denen auf der Seite sehe. Das ist aber auch...
Cyber-Tool.
Wie lange habe ich das? 20 Jahre oder so?
Ja, das war auch mal eine Zeit lang im CCC war das auch relativ beliebt.
Genau, da hast du halt noch so kleine Mini-Bits, mit denen du auch noch schnell
irgendwie mal was geschraubt kriegst.
So eine Zange, um hier Jumper zu setzen und ähnliche filigranere Geschichten
zu machen. Also diese Zange ist in der Tat sehr, sehr praktisch, finde ich.
Und es ist nicht genau das Modell, aber relativ ähnlich.
Genau, ich hätte zum Beispiel...
Ich glaube, es ist das. Bei meinem ist auch ein Kugelschreiber dabei.
Der ist in dem jetzt hier nicht drin.
Weil hier zum Beispiel ist ja der Parselhook dabei.
Ich hätte statt dem Parselhook nämlich gern die Ahle, die da bei dem sogar mit
dabei ist noch zusätzlich.
Ahle ist praktisch.
Das wäre mein Wunsch an Victorinox. wenn ihr zuhört, macht mir doch mal das
Huckel-Spezial Compact und ersetzt den Parcel-Hook durch eine Aale und dann,
kaufe ich euch direkt noch eins.
Also ich habe in der Tat kein Parcel. Das kann gut sein, dass es meins einfach
schlicht nicht mehr gibt. Das ist einfach.
Es gibt ja auch ein Cyber-Tool L.
Ja, da ist aber auch kein Kugelschreiber dran. Wobei, das ist nicht ganz aufgebaut.
Guck mal da, weil dieser Schnupsi, dieser graue Schnupsi unten links,
da ist eine Pinzette beispielsweise drin und dann kann es nämlich gut sein,
dass auf der anderen Seite doch
der Kugelschreiber ist und der jetzt hier einfach noch nicht zu sehen ist.
Pinzette finde ich ja immer ganz praktisch.
Pinzette hat das Compact nämlich auch noch, ja.
Habe ich vergessen zu erwähnen, aber ja, für mich war es halt wirklich so die Größe,
also das Compact ist halt wirklich ziemlich compact und kannst dir halt wirklich
hier bequem in die Hose schieben, ohne dass das groß auffällt.
Hat Kugelschreiber, steht hier.
Und ich habe mir nämlich, ich habe lange überlegt, welches von denen,
weil das ist wirklich so eine Welt der Kompromisse.
Für mich war dann die Größe und das Gewicht halt noch ein Faktor.
Und weil das mit diesen Pin, mit den Bits ist auf jeden Fall auch ein Punkt,
da habe ich aber eine andere Lösung, die vor allen Dingen auch Bits verwendet,
die so dann in gängige Akkuschrauber und so weiter auch reingehen.
Ich hatte irgendwie beim Leatherman schon mal so diese kleineren Bits und irgendwie
war ich immer so in Situationen, wo ich dachte, ah, wie schön wäre es,
wenn ich jetzt dieses Bit auch noch anderweitig verwenden könnte.
Aber klar, manchmal ist das besser als nix.
Ja, dieses Cyber Tool L beispielsweise ist auch schon irre breit.
Also das ist einfach schwer. Es ist groß. Meins ist kleiner.
Also meins wird es in der Form einfach schlicht nicht mehr geben.
Wie viel wiegt das M, das Cyber Tool M? Kannst du da nochmal kurz draufklickstron?
Ähm.
Oh, guck dir das an. Das ist ja wirklich Oh.
Richtig. Dieses Swiss Champdinger, das ist irgendwie das Schlimmste.
Ja. Cyber Tool M und dann steht da unten mein Gewicht 153 Gramm,
weil das Kompakt wiegt 64 Gramm.
Das hat aber keinen Kugelschreiber. Den
finde ich schon irgendwie Druckkugelschreiber. Doch, das steht da drin.
Dann reicht das wahrscheinlich in der Tat.
153 Gramm. Oh ja.
So nah wie ein kleines Steak.
Jo. Und sonst?
Fällt mir sonst noch irgendwas total Tolles ein, was die Leute dringend in ihre
Warenkörbe schieben sollten?
Ich glaube nicht, oder?
Ja, äh, ah, ich meine, ja, das ist auf jeden Fall eine Produktkategorie, ähm,
äh, die auch, die ich sehr spannend finde und die ich auch schon,
ähm, äh, oft verwendet habe.
warte mal, wie heißt sie, die Firma, Silky, Silky macht so Klappholzsägen und
wenn du das Konzept Klappholzsäge hörst, denkst du dir, nee, komm, geh weg,
klingt scheiße, klingt schlechter als ein Fuchsschwanz oder so,
weil irgendwie stellt man sich so direkt so was Bobbliges vor,
was nicht funktioniert.
Aber ich sag dir, die Silky Klappholzsägen, also ich hab eine in dieser Tasche,
wo auch meine Knippbacks und so weiter drin ist, die ist so lang zusammengeklappt.
So lang ist?
Was sind das? Vielleicht 20 cm. 20 cm.
Du kannst nachschlagen, wie heißt denn das Teil?
Mein Modell, es ist nicht der Big Boy, weil das ist wirklich so ein Schwert.
Warte mal, ich muss mal hier...
Pocket Boy vielleicht? Outback Edition?
Es könnte sein. Warte mal, ich gucke mal hier gerade.
Also der Clou ist, sie sind so leicht gebogen, aber man kann sie halt einklappen,
wie man das so aus dem Klapptärschenmesser kennt.
Und die Sägen wie Hölle. Also deren Sägeblätter, das macht richtig Spaß.
Da gehst du wirklich durch relativ straffes Astmaterial ziemlich gut durch.
Und es gibt also die großen, die Big Boys, kannst du so wirklich auch Baumstämme durchjagen.
Relativ schnell. Und das Schöne ist, die sind wirklich geil vom Klappmechanismus.
Fühlt sich sehr solide an. Und die Messer sind auch...
Link in Chat.
Ich muss jetzt nochmal hier kurz, warte mal. Klappsägen, Faltsägen, gebogene Klinge.
Da gibt's ja nur neun. Ne, doch. Warte mal.
Die Seite ist leider von denen irgendwie zumindest bei mir hier relativ langsam.
Ich habe ich habe den warte mal, welchen habe ich denn?
Ich habe den Pocketboy 170 glaube ich.
Genau. Und zwar den hier, warte mal Link.
Das ist doch genau den ich gerade vermutet hatte.
Guck mal, ich packe es mal in den Chat.
Ich meine, den habe ich auf jeden Fall einer aus dieser Pocketboy-Serie und
ich meine, ich habe den 170er.
Die sind wirklich ganz vorne mit dabei.
Verarbeitung super. du kannst die Sägeblätter auch wechseln das ist auch kein
großer Act wenn die mal dann doch irgendwann durch sind,
und ja also portable Holzsäge für diverse Outdoor-Aktivitäten,
oder wenn man den Grenzbaum fällen muss.
Kommt ja immer so ein bisschen drauf an was einem so begegnet ich hatte jetzt
für meinen Outdoor-Sommerbedarf vor allem,
das nützlichste Gerät, was ich jetzt gekauft habe, ist halt aus der Makita-Welt,
und ich finde das ja immer bemerkenswert,
wenn, also ich meine akkubetriebene Dinger und so weiter, über Akkuschrauber
brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht zu reden. Ich meine, ich weiß.
Was kommt.
Ja?
Oder?
Weiß ich nicht, was kommt, aber generell, also Akkuschrauber ist natürlich quasi
so das Nonplusultra und ich bin vor allem immer wieder begeistert,
was es mittlerweile alles für crazy Zubehör gibt für Akkuschrauber,
was man einfach da reinstecken kann.
Also ich mache zum Beispiel natürlich auch meinen Waffelteig mit dem Akkuschrauber,
weil es natürlich fertige Reinstecksets gibt für, anstatt dass man jetzt irgendwie nochmal einen,
Schaumschläger mitnimmt oder Teigkneter oder sonst irgendwie sowas.
Gibt es alles zum reinstecken und immer wieder beeindruckend.
Oder auch nur um den Wassertank nachzufüllen. Hast ja immer das Problem,
wie kriege ich jetzt das Wasser, was da im Kanister ist, in diesen Tank rein.
Ja klar, man kann den Kanister hochhalten, aber so 20-30 Liter Tank hältst du
halt auch nicht irgendwie gerne und lange und einfach und so weiter.
Also gibt es irgendwie die Gardena-Wasserpumpe, die du einfach vorne in den
Akkuschrauber reinsteckst und schon pumpt das Wasser.
Ich habe live eine Demo bekommen. Ich habe Tim in seinem Wasserpumpstudio besucht, habe französische,
Fahrstuhl-Jazz-Musik abgespielt und dann hat Tim uns in der Nacht eine Vorführung
von seinem Wasser- und Pumpequipment gemacht,
inklusive dieser Makita-Kompat, also Akkuschrauber- kompatiblen Pumpe und ich
muss sagen, es war sehr beeindruckend und wenn ich mit einem Camper unterwegs
wäre und Wasser bräuchte,
dann würde ich auf jeden Fall auch mich bei Tim ausführlich informieren über
meine Möglichkeiten und,
ja.
War gut. Man ist einfach begeistert. Man muss einfach nur den richtigen Set
an Adaptern dabei haben, damit man dann dem Adapter natürlich auch seinen Dank aussprechen kann.
Hier ist euer Ohrwurm für heute.
Dank des Adapters genau aber ich meine das grandioseste Werkzeug ist natürlich
das einfach schlicht Multifunktionswerkzeug genannte Teil das.
Meinte ich genau.
Ich weiß gar nicht in welchen habe ich den DTM 51 52 Leute.
Ihr müsst den Chat hier ein bisschen beschicken zumindest in den.
Shownotes ich.
Habe doch beschickt.
Ja ich beschick auch,
Weil darauf wollte ich ja jetzt hinaus. Ich meine, ich kann auch gerne nochmal
die Gardena-Wasserpumpe... Die packt man mit rein.
Ich glaube, die Welt will das auch wissen. Weil das ist zum Beispiel ein Teil
von dessen Existenz wusste ich nicht. Und bin froh, dass ich jetzt davon weiß.
Genau, so einfach und auch so billig. Aber dass die Dinger einfach nur Multifunktionswerkzeug
heißen, finde ich ja irgendwie bemerkenswert.
Wahrscheinlich haben die auch noch sehr viel mehr Funktionen. als ich weiß.
Also ich sehe jetzt ein Bild davon, auch in 3D und kann nicht ergründen, was es tut.
Du weißt nicht, was ein Multifunktionswerkzeug ist?
Das ist wirklich, pass auf, ich kann nur so viel sagen, ich hatte es selber
noch nicht in Benutzung,
aber ich verfolge den Herrn Adam Savage nach wie vor auf YouTube und wie er
so in seiner Werkstatt Dinge baut oder Dinge prototypt und dieses Werkzeug ist auch auf seiner,
Gotttier Liste vor allem, was ist bei Tim jetzt los?
Ich habe mein Kabel der hat sich verädert.
Achso, auf so der Gott-Tier-Liste von Rapid Prototyping Tools und ich hab's
jetzt bei Tim dann mal live in Action gesehen auf der Nation und ich glaube,
das wird auch eine meiner nächsten Makita- Anschaffungen sein werden.
Also, was macht man mit diesem Teil? Also das Ding ist halt so einfach so ein
Knochen, hinten machst du den Makita-Akku dran, da ist ein relativ starker Motor
dran, der aber nicht rotiert, sondern vibriert.
Das ist also ein Vibrationsgerät.
Und durch ein,
Befestigungsmechanismus, wo du so in der Mitte so einen Schnippel rausziehst,
einen Werkzeugaufsatz drauf machst und dann den wieder festklemmst,
kannst du da eben alle möglichen Sägeblätter ranbringen.
Und im Prinzip macht das Ding genau das gleiche, wie die Säge beim Chirurgen,
wenn sie dir den Gips abnehmen.
Hast du schon mal ein Gips am Arm? Oder ein Kind mit Gips am Arm?
Zum Glück nicht.
Zum Glück nicht. Aber du hast ja schon mal gehört, Gips am Arm.
Gibt es? Ja, wie kriegt man den Gips ab?
Wird er nicht geschnitten?
Ja, früher wurde er geschnitten, heutzutage wird gesägt. Das heißt,
da kommt dann jemand mit der Säge und sägt so richtig an deiner Haut entlang.
Und du denkst, oh, was, wie?
Und sie werden dir sagen, ja, da kann nichts passieren oder machen vielleicht noch einen Witz.
und es passiert deshalb nichts, weil diese Säge eben nicht rotiert,
was ja dann alles aufreißen würde, sondern vibriert.
Wackelt einfach nur sehr schnell hin und her, wodurch alle festen Stoffe sofort...
Also wie eine Stichsäge.
Ja, nee, sehr viel feinere Vibrationen, sehr viel kleinere Bewegungen.
Eine Stichsäge macht ja richtig Hub und wenn du die dir in den Arm reinsägst, dann nicht gut.
Aber mit dem Teil kannst du dir halt einfach wirklich mal in den Arm rein sägen und passiert nix.
Warum nix? Weil diese Vibrationen so klein sind, dass die Weichheit deiner Haut die einfach mitführt.
Das heißt, du bringst nur deine Haut zum Vibrieren, aber du schneidest halt nicht durch.
Aber durch harte Sachen schneidet es.
Ja, weil die dem halt so viel Widerstand entgegensetzen, weil der Motor ist halt trotzdem stark.
Der macht halt die Vibration nicht so ein bisschen, sondern der will diese Bewegung auch machen.
Aber wenn die andere Seite hart ist, dann wird sie einfach zersägt.
Wenn die andere Seite weich ist, dann wabbelt die mit.
Und das macht die Dinger so safe. Und deswegen kannst du damit halt auch super geil arbeiten.
Und vor allem anders als bei den meisten Sägen, kannst du damit so richtig Löcher
gerade reinsägen. Also du kannst so vorne, hast du so eine Säge,
die Sägeblatt jetzt vielleicht nur einen Zentimeter breit ist.
Ja sowas zum Beispiel irgendwie so eine, also das ist hier, wir gucken gerade
so ein Bild im Chat an mit den ganzen möglichen Sägeblättern.
Jetzt hast du hier eins, was relativ schmal ist und so eine gerade Kante hat
vorne und damit kannst du dann so frontal ins Holz einfach rein...
Und Tim hat zum Beispiel auch auf der Nation dann so einen Holzpfeil gehabt
und hat da irgendwelche Quadrate rausgeschnitten, was du mit einer normalen
Säge so nicht machen könntest.
Genau. Und das geht da einfach durch.
Und ziemlich schnell auch.
Ja, und ziemlich einfach.
Also du kannst dir zum Beispiel, es gibt so ein Video, mal sehen,
ob ich das spontan jetzt noch während der Sendung finde, von dem Adam Savage
von ehemals Mythbusters.
Er schaut so sehr, ich muss das Teil jetzt mal hier raus holen.
Genau, jetzt sägen wir mal in die Messereien.
Wo er so sein Loblied auf dieses Tool singt und verschiedene Anwendungsfälle
dafür zeigt, das kann ich...
Okay, es ist schon mal groß. Es ist vom Griff her größer als eine Bohrmaschine.
Welche habe ich denn jetzt eigentlich? Ich habe die... Wo steht es dran?
Also handlich ist es...
DTM 52.
Handlich ist es schon mal nicht.
Ja, naja, aber du willst auch...
Gewicht ist zu erwarten.
Du willst auch Power haben. Ist da noch Power im Akku? Ja, ist noch.
So. Und, naja, vorne hast du so einen Locking-Mechanismus, den man so aufschnappt.
Dann ziehst du halt da diesen Befestigungsnagel raus, machst halt,
haben wir irgendwas zum Zersägen hier eigentlich?
Wollen wir irgendwas kaputt machen? Da hast du Papier da vorne.
Pappe.
Genau.
Und jetzt habe ich hier so verschiedene Teile. Die sind dann meistens für Metall
oder für Holz. das steht so drauf, je nachdem,
wofür die so angeblich geeignet sind. Das ist ja eigentlich ziemlich Wurst, was man nimmt.
Echt, aber damit kommst du doch dann durch die Haut durch hier.
Das ist doch voll spitz und scharf.
Ja, nee, das ist...
Na, dann demonstriert das doch mal, Tim. Ja, das macht der Tim... An deinem Arm.
Das macht der Tim sehr gerne, weil das ist tatsächlich so ein Ding, was...
Jetzt haben wir wieder ASMR, wenn ich das Ding anmache.
Ja.
So, und jetzt kannst du halt hier einfach so direkt an die Hand rangehen damit,
und es passiert einfach gar nichts.
Ralf guckt schon ganz komisch, aber ich mache das jetzt hier einfach ran.
Ralf guckt gerade so, wie Tim geguckt hat, als wir die Meta an die Nägel gehalten
haben. So guckt Ralf gerade.
Aber durch meinen Fingernagel würde das jetzt durchsägen.
Ja, den Fingernagel würde er eher schon Und wenn er dann auf der Haut ist.
Dann wird er quasi Ja.
Dann hört er wieder auf.
Okay, wir vertiefen das nicht weiter.
So, jetzt gehe ich hier mal den Karton rein,
Okay.
Das will ich jetzt auch probieren.
Und ich kann halt vor allem so von vorne einfach drauf. So, zack. Zack.
Zack. Jetzt habe ich hier einen Quadrat. Nicht ganz getroffen,
aber jetzt habe ich hier irgendwie einen Quadrat. Das ist toll, oder?
Er kannte das mal. Das ist ja wirklich unglaublich.
So, jetzt muss es.
Das ist ja toll.
Rufen Sie jetzt die Nummer neben Ihrer Landesflagge an.
Macht Spaß, oder?
Ja, und vor allem, die werden dann auch warm. Vor allem, wenn du es in Holz
machst. Und vor allem, es geht auch mit Metall.
Also eben mal ein Rohr kürzen. Einfach durch.
Gerade so, ich habe jetzt gerade meine Pussy-Telefone installiert und dann musste ich halt,
so ein Rohr kürzen. Dann gehst du nicht mit einer Metallsäge da ran,
wie früher, sondern ich habe einfach das Teil rausgenommen, habe da ein Metallblatt
dran gemacht und dann war das in einer Sekunde durch und fertig.
Also, es ist verstörend. Weil das scheint wirklich wieder die Physik zu,
Das Gefühl ist völlig nicht erwartungskonform. Also ich versuche gerade irgendwie
jetzt mal den Haarfinger draufzulegen, womit ich das vergleichen würde vom Schnitt-
oder Säge- oder Fräsgefühl her.
Das ist ein Multifunktionswerkzeug.
Nee, aber weißt du, ich meine, du kennst ja von Ultraschall,
also zum Beispiel Ultraschallzahnbürste oder Ultraschallbrillenreinigungsbad,
wo letztendlich keine großen mechanischen Bewegungen, also zumindest so für
dich als Mensch wahrnehmbar sind, aber du ja dann trotzdem merkst, okay,
aber diese kleinen, feinen Vibrationen, die haben Wirkung.
Die haben Wirkung.
Und im Prinzip ist das.
Es hat sowas Chirurgisches so eine Anmutung von Präzision und von Ruhe und Stabilität,
also wir haben jetzt wirklich nur halt in einen Pappkarton rein aber ich glaube
der Effekt ist relativ übertragbar auf Holz oder auf Metall,
ich habe jetzt hier gerade nicht so viel Holz rumliegen Ich habe aus der blauen
Serie Bosch so eine Stichsäge, ziemlich gutes Teil damit kommst du gut durch,
aber gefühlt stresst dieses Teil,
du machst es an und es ist gefährlich und was mache ich jetzt irgendwie und
schnell alles zu Ende bringen.
Das hier, das evoziert sofort so einen Spieltrieb.
Ja, und vor allem auch mit Kunststoffrohren und sowas. Also überhaupt Kunststoff
kannst du damit ganz hervorragend machen und dadurch, dass man eben so wunderbar
auch Cutouts machen kann, ist es halt einfach super universell.
Und mit einer großen Bandbreite an unterschiedlichen Einsätzen.
Schleifen kann man wahrscheinlich auch.
Ja, und kannst halt nicht super damit schleifen.
Das ist wie so ein großer Proxxon irgendwie oder so Dremel irgendwie, weißt du was?
Also nicht vom Prinzip, aber so vom Feeling,
weil beim Dremel und Proxon hast du ja auch so 1001 Aufsatz und kannst irgendwie
die verschiedensten Tools da noch draufschrauben, aber das ist irgendwie nochmal
so eine neue Dimension von Multifunktionswerkzeug.
Ich finde es bloß erstaunlich, dass es ihnen nicht gelungen ist,
dafür einen Namen zu finden und sich auch bis heute irgendwie so richtig kein
Produktname durchgesetzt hat.
Und haben die das erfunden?
Nee, wie gesagt, im medizinischen Bereich gibt es das schon lange.
Ich denke mal, die sind da sogar für erfunden worden ursprünglich mal.
Einfach um dieses Problem Gips abkriegen.
Weil du hast dann irgendwelche Kinder oder Leute, die, was weiß ich, irgendwie reagieren.
Und mit der Schere war das dann doch immer ein bisschen anstrengend auch.
Weil so mit einer Schere den Gips durchschneiden, da brauchst du richtig Kraft.
Und mit dem Teil machst du einfach, bis das Ding durch...
Okay, also wirklich interessant, dass ich sowas A noch nie irgendwo gesehen oder gehört habe. Und,
warum erfindet man sowas? Wie lange gibt es das? Weiß das jemand?
Ich würde auch sagen, so zwei, drei Jahre kenne ich, habe ich das schon auf dem Radar.
Lass es fünf sein. Was hat die Menschheit wieder die 100 Jahre vorher gemacht?
was gibt es noch an schönen Erfindungen da draußen, die noch auf uns warten
also wenn ihr die Gelegenheit habt, probiert das aus, das ist mindblowing ist
das wirklich ein völlig anderer Zugang zu sägen oder schneiden,
irre, ist es, cool schmeiß.
Deine Küchenmesser weg.
Jetzt nur noch durch eine Tomate geht es wahrscheinlich dann nicht durch doch.
Bestimmt Das ist jetzt geil.
Der Tomaten-Test.
Von der Konsistenz her.
So ein Tokumesser kannst du wegschmeißen dann. Machst du nur noch mit der Makita jetzt.
Das ist auch ein schönes Bild.
Aber warum hast du jetzt das Papier hier noch in die Schale reingemacht?
Weil das Müll ist. Müll, das ist kein Müll, das ist Tomaten.
Ja, aber da ist Schleifschlamm dran.
Schleifschlamm.
Okay, jetzt wird ein besonders martialisch aussehen.
Ja, das ist so das, was so beim Chirurgen auch verwendet würde.
Man hat erstmal echt Angst, wenn man es so in der Hand hat und sich anguckt.
Mein Gott, mach mal ein Bild davon, wie wir jetzt hier durch die Tomate durchgehen.
Moment, da muss ich mich hier erstmal in die Foto.
Das wäre eigentlich geil, ein Video davon zu machen.
Ja, da mache ich halt ein Video davon.
Ja, okay, es geht, ja. Aber erstaunlich, dass es durch die Tomate geht.
Aber wahrscheinlich, wenn man ein bisschen drücken würde, würde es halt auch durch Haut gehen.
So, jetzt läuft's.
Ja, aber es ist nicht wie durch Butter, sondern, also unsere Messer sind effizienter.
Ja, weil die Tomate halt jetzt eigentlich so ein bisschen mit Wabat.
Mit Wabat, genau. Ja, sehr cool.
Ja, das ist, also ich hatte...
Man kann sofort alles zerschneiden, so.
Das Ding ist, ich hatte das halt auch schon ein paar Mal so auf meinem Einkaufswagenzettel,
wie auch immer, aber dann habe ich jedes Mal nochmal so vorher,
was würde ich damit jetzt produktiv gerade machen wollen und ich habe halt keine
Werkstatt, ich wohne halt in einer Wohnung in Berlin,
ich habe sehr selten einen Anwendungsfall für das Tool, aber ich liebe dieses
Tool und dessen Existenz und,
ja, also ich würde auch sagen, wenn ihr die Gelegenheit habt,
nehmt es mal in die Hand und sägt mal was auseinander.
Da will man dann einfach mal alles zersägen Ja Okay.
Hier ab der Kader, wer sonst schreibt gerade, das gäbe es seit 1967.
Was?
Unter dem Namen Oszillierer.
Ah, ja, Oszillierer, das trifft die Sache natürlich sehr gut.
Aber das ist so richtig als Akkutechnik, so Makita-mäßig.
Ja, bei dem Bild hier ist ein Stromkabel natürlich dran.
Ich hätte hier sogar noch die Intensität weiter hochdrehen können.
So, was ist der Strafpreis hierfür? Was wird hier aufgerufen?
Da musst du jetzt ja, wenn du Bosch Blue-Kunde bist, musst du ja mal da deine,
Apotheke fragen.
Also das war okay.
Na, hast du schon einen Preis gefunden?
Also so 117.
Das ist ja nichts. Was heißt, es ist Geld, ja, jammern auf hohem Niveau.
Aber was man alles zersägen kann.
Ohne Akku 49 Euro. Gott im Himmel.
Ja, ist überschaubar.
Den kannst du auch zersägen.
Ja, was ich noch gar nicht so
durchexplored habe, ist, was es alles so für Sägeblätter-Optionen da gibt.
Da will man auf jeden Fall verschiedene
Formen haben, um einfach so dünne Löcher machen zu können und so.
Und dann halt eben zum Nachschleifen ist vielleicht auch noch ganz cool.
So, bei Bosch sind blaue Serie sind wir dann gleich bei 255.
Makita.
Ja, ich bin halt nicht in dem Akkursystem drin. Nee.
Ich habe ja jetzt, ich bin, ich habe jetzt auch noch festgestellt,
es gibt jetzt auch noch so einen kleinen kompakten Kärcher von Makita.
Akku-Kärcher. Ich meine, da muss ja immer noch was verstehen.
Also wirklich von all diesen Firmen, Makita dreht wirklich am freisten,
was es so an Produkten gibt, die mit ihren Akkus irgendwie funktionieren.
Das ist wirklich, ich feiere das auch sehr und jedes Mal, wenn ich mit irgendwelchen
Leuten spreche, die da mehr in dem System drin stecken als ich,
denke ich mir auch, also was hat ihr auf der Nation erzählt?
Wärme, Weste und Wärmehose.
Ja, ja. Das ist Makita Wunderland.
Und überhaupt gerade so diese Thermosachen, das ist halt einfach ganz weit vorne.
Weil wenn es kalt ist.
Dann willst du warm.
Ja, also so im Stadion, kann ich sagen, bringen diese Technologien wirklich was.
Oder halt woanders hinfahren. Das hilft natürlich auch.
Leicht handgeführter Druckreiniger mit 8 oder 24 Bar Arbeitsdruck.
Wow.
Ja, also da kann man mal eben was sauber machen.
Sag mal, gibt es dann von Makita auch noch den Luftkompressor,
der dir dann deine Air-Tools powern kann, dass du dann sozusagen noch mit so
einem Druckluft noch unterwegs hast? Gibt es einen Makita Akkukompressor?
Ja, den habe ich auch immer dabei. Das ist das zweite wichtige Gerät,
was ich neben meinem Akkuschrauber immer am Start habe.
Weil das ist zum Beispiel sehr wichtig. Ich habe ja einen Wohnwagen.
Und beim Wohnwagen hast du ja beim Platzieren immer das Problem,
das Ding soll ja gerade stehen.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht hat man es beim Wohnwagen ja einfacher als beim Wohnmobil.
Weil wenn du beim Wohnmobil irgendwie erstmal schräg stehst,
dann kriegst du so ein Auto hochgebockt.
Naja, dann kannst du halt so Keile nehmen, kannst auf die Keile drauf fahren.
Damit kriegst du natürlich immer nur so einen begrenzten Teil.
Und wenn du halt irgendwie so eine schräge, blöde Situation hast,
wo es nicht gleichmäßig schräg ist, sondern unterschiedlich schräg,
so mit vier Auflagepunkten ist es schwierig.
Während jetzt bei dem normal großen Wohnwagen, der also nur eine Achse hat,
bei zwei Achsen ist nochmal ein bisschen was anderes, Aber wenn du so eine Einachse
hast, dann ist ja das vorne hinten quasi eingebaut.
Da kannst du dann eben einfach entsprechend hochschrauben und mit diesen Stützen das ausgleichen.
Bleibt immer noch das links-rechts ausgleichen.
Und das kann ja schon mal sehr extrem sein.
Gerade wenn du also schräg am Hügel stehst, dann willst du natürlich auch eher
so stehen, dass du wirklich die Achse ausgleichen musst.
Und da war dann mein ursprünglicher Ansatz halt auch dieser Keil.
Aber der Keil hat halt eine ganze Reihe von Problemen.
Erstens, du kannst diesen Keil ja wirklich nur wirklich nutzen in dem Moment,
wo du noch den Wohnwagen am Auto hast und musst ihn dann quasi mit dem Auto
auf diesen Keil drauf schieben. Das geht natürlich.
Aber in dem Moment, wo du dann den Wohnwagen wieder vom Auto abmachst,
hast du eine extreme gegenläufige Zugkraft, die dir dann das Teil halt,
dann rollt es halt einfach wieder runter.
Ja klar, dann kannst du eine Handbremse machen, kannst irgendwelche Klötze noch
drunter legen und so weiter.
Das klappt dann auch irgendwann, wenn man das so ein bisschen im Gefühl hat,
aber dann stimmt die Höhe nicht und dann kannst du auch irgendwie nichts mehr
nachträglich ändern und dann ist es irgendwie dunkel und dann hast du keinen
Bock mehr und dann lassen wir das jetzt einfach so.
Und ich habe halt lange irgendwie geschaut, wie man das Problem irgendwie lösen könnte.
Und es gibt ja wirklich für jeden Scheiß, gibt es ja irgendwie so eine Spezialfirma.
Und die Spezialfirma, die solche Wohnwagenprobleme löst, ist die Firma Emuk.
Ich war übrigens gerade in Düsseldorf auf dem Caravan-Salon und habe mich mal
wieder über den aktuellen Stand der Technik informiert.
Spoiler, es ist nicht viel passiert.
Und die machen, okay, ich dachte jetzt, entweder bauen sie dir jetzt da so ein
Citroën DS Nivellierungssystem ein, wo du da deinen Kompressorschlauch anschließt
oder sie machen so kleine Kissen.
Genau, sie machen so kleine Kissen, aber das sind halt so die Kissen,
die so richtig was halten.
Also Emuk ist groß geworden eigentlich mit Wohnwagenspiegeln und ihr neuestes
Ding sind aber jetzt eigentlich diese Kissen, die einfach wirklich grandios sind.
Es gibt R-Lift heißen die Teile.
Und ich weiß nicht, habe ich das hier noch nie erzählt?
Naja, auf jeden Fall habe ich
so einen Teil mir geholt. Ist ein bisschen teurer, aber löst das Problem.
Weil jetzt kann ich mit dem Wohnwagen einfach,
Bestimmen, okay, ich möchte jetzt hier stehen, dann lege ich halt dieses Kissen
einfach vor den Reifen, fahre mit dem Wagen den Wohnwagen auf dieses Kissen,
dann Handbremse und so weiter, das passt, koppelst du ab, Auto weg,
Wohnwagen steht alleine auf diesem Kissen.
Und dann kommt der Makita Akkukompressor.
Den machst du da ran und dann sagst du und du kannst mit dem Teil 20 Zentimeter Hub ausgleichen.
Das ist wirklich eine ganze Menge.
Und das funktioniert und die Teile können irgendwie, was war die Spezifikation,
ein Teil kann irgendwie 6 Tonnen oder so tragen.
11 Tonnen bei 6 Bar.
11 Tonnen, genau. 11 Tonnen.
Ich kenne dieses Prinzip halt so von so, weißt du, willst du meinen Schrank
irgendwie anheben oder irgendwie so eine Tür aushängen oder ist es zu schwer?
Und da gab es halt auch schon immer diese Luftsäcke, die man halt von Hand oder
wie auch immer aufgepumpt hat.
Aber das ist halt nochmal eine Kategorie More Heavy Duty da mit 11 Tonnen bei 6 Bar.
Aber ja, Luftdruck kann viel wuppen.
Ja, das ist richtig. Und es ist, ja, ich kann sagen, das funktioniert.
Also das war jede Mark wert, die ich da reingeworfen habe in das Luxusproblem.
Und wenn man halt keine andere technische Lösung hat mit dem Auto,
was sich irgendwie selber anhebt, dann ist das eigentlich wunderbar.
Vom Wohnwagen brauchst du halt vor allem nur einen in der Regel und wenn du
jetzt so einen Laster hast, dann willst du vielleicht zwei haben.
Aber dann kannst du halt auch größere Kippproblematiken da auch noch lösen.
Ja, ich warte ja dann, also ich muss glaube ich auch noch mal für die nächste
Segelreise, muss ich noch mal vorher im Makita-Katalog nachgucken,
was man so als für Segelboote noch irgendwie sich anschauen kann.
Also bei Makita, also wenn ich so Unlimited Money und Unlimited Abspeicher-Plays
hätte, es gibt so diverse Geräte, die ich gerne hätte.
Makita Unlimited Premium Account, wo du quasi einmal so 20.000 Euro bezahlst
und dann kriegst du aber auch jedes neue Produkt direkt,
wenn es rauskommt.
Okay, um diesen Makita-Traum, den Feuchten, einfach kurz zu Ende zu spielen.
Makita-Geräte, die ich im Auge habe, aber wo ich eigentlich sage,
ich brauche sie eigentlich nicht, ich brauche sie eigentlich nicht.
Aber wenn man in der jeweiligen Werkzeugkategorie unterwegs ist und sie mal
braucht, dann hätte man gerne die.
Zum Beispiel Akku-Kartuschenpistole.
Wenn du so Silikon aufträgst, diese mechanischen Teile machen dich wahnsinnig so.
es gibt eine Akku-Kartuschenpistole also wenn du wirklich professionell größere
Mengen von diesem Zeug, Silikon was es auch immer ist, aufbringen musst dann
eine Kreissäge wäre natürlich aber wirklich der Brüller und generell Gibt.
Es eine Nailgun-Akku.
Betrieben? Ja, es gibt auch eine Kettensäge es gibt einen Tacker Tacker ist
bei mir auch ganz weit vorne, Akku-Tacker und Nagler der kann glaube ich sogar beides ja,
gut, dann gibt es eine ganze Menge Sachen, die ich jetzt nicht brauche,
so Blechschere und so weiter, das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Sein Bandsäge finde ich ja also ich bin ja manchmal bei Proxon,
da gibt es halt auch irgendwie so das in kleiner alles Bandsäge finde ich ja
auch richtig gut, aber Bandsäge?
Was macht eine Bandsäge?
So für ganz feine,
Google, gib mal da hier ins Image-Ding, sie Bandsäge ein.
Ja, da schiebt man dann das Brett so hin und her drauf, weil das so dünn ist,
dass du es in alle Richtungen gleichermaßen sägen kannst.
Achso, wo das Ding die ganze Zeit im Band, im Kreis durchläuft und du schiebst einfach das.
Im Kreis, glaube ich, auch nur so ein Vibrier.
Das war, glaube ich, früher mal so, aber heutzutage, glaube ich, nicht mehr.
Ah, such mal, mach mal Proxon. Ah, doch, es gibt noch so ein Durchlauf.
Such mal nach Proxon noch dazu.
Die in kleinen. Das ist so mein ja, Proxxon macht so süße Sachen. Klein?
Das ist doch nicht klein.
Doch, ich glaube, die ist ziemlich klein.
Boah, dieser Multicutter macht mich immer noch so fertig.
Ja, das läuft dann im Kreis. Das ist ja schon ein bisschen Gehäuse.
Genau, so eine Sache. Also bei Proxxon zum Beispiel, da gibt es so ganz viele
Gerätschaften, die ich gerne so in meiner Heimwerkstatt hätte.
Nicht für so Großbaustellen, aber da gibt es Bandsäge, ist zum Beispiel eins davon.
Ich hätte auch der Adam Savage, der hat ja in seiner Werkstatt alles mit Druckluft, ne, der hat Schrauber,
Nagler, Tacker und so ganz viele andere Tools so mit Druckluft und dann halt immer dieses,
zusätzliche Feature, dass wenn du dann mit Holz irgendwas gemacht hast an der
Kreissäge oder an der Drehbank, schnell mal kurz die Druckluftpistole unterm
Tisch vorgezogen und alles wieder weggepustet.
Saugst du noch oder pustest du schon? Das ist da die Frage quasi.
Du mit deinen Rumbas hier bist noch beim Saugen, aber stell dir vor,
du hättest Druckluft und könntest dir einfach alles einfach rauspusten.
Ja, ja.
Naja.
Die Welt der Gerätschaften, sie ist schön.
Ich habe dich ja auf der Nation im Spaß natürlich nur mal ein bisschen angeranzt,
weil deine Schiebelehre so minderwertig rüberkam.
Aber das kam natürlich auch nur daher,
dass ich mir vor kurzem eine Mitutoyo-Digital-Schiveliere gekauft habe,
die deutlich über dem sinnvollen Preis liegt, aber leider auch natürlich mega
geil ist, weil sie ultrapräzise ist und...
Mitutoyo.
Kami-Pers.
Genau, ich habe die 500-196-30, weil es gibt für jede Farbe und Form gefühlt
eine Schiebelehre von denen,
mit verschiedenen Toleranzen und Präzisionen und Etz und wasserbeständig und was nicht alles.
ja das war halt auch so ich hatte seit 10 Jahren, 15 Jahren immer eine einfach
rein analoge Schiebelehre und es ist mir immer öfter passiert,
dass ich dachte, ach komm dann müssen wir jetzt langsam alt genug,
jetzt kannst du ja auch mal eine digitale kaufen und dann Ich.
Habe einfach ein D von iFixit mir geholt.
Und das.
Funktioniert auch ganz.
Wunderbar Ja, ich würde auch sagen für die allermeisten Anwendungsfälle reicht
auch so eine 08 15 13 Euro Digitalschiebelehre, vollkommen ausreichend.
Aber wenn man halt so mal rum nerdet und sich denkt, okay, was ist denn jetzt
die Referenzklasse? Dann,
guckt man, ist das noch im Budget drin? Und wenn da die Antwort ja lautet,
dann kann man sich halt mal so eine kaufen.
Okay, wie heißt das Produkt?
Ein Tutorio was?
Ich habe hier einen Amazon-Link, warte mal, schicke ich dir den mal rein.
Mach einfach einen Chat da. So,
jetzt haben wir eigentlich unser typisches Freakshow-Zeitlimit erreicht.
Nicht ansatzweise mit unseren Themen durch.
Wie der Chat schon sagt, eine sehr teure Sendung.
Freakshow-Home-Shopping-Efficient.
Und das alles ohne einen einzigen Affiliate-Link. Noch. Ach stimmt, nur mit einem Voucher.
Ja, genau.
Der Trikiwi-Voucher. Ihr kriegt sogar noch billiger alles hier.
Genau.
Ja, dann musst du wohl noch mal wiederkommen.
Dann müssen wir über Elixier sprechen.
Genau, da holen wir uns noch mal Luca noch mit dazu. Dann passt das irgendwie.
Nächste Woche bin ich ja auf Konferenz. Da gibt es dann sicherlich auch eine
ganze Menge zu erzählen.
Ja, ich glaube, mein September ist irgendwie so einigermaßen Folge.
Naja, da befinden wir schon einen anderen Termin.
Also ich glaube, ab Oktober bin ich wieder richtig flexibel.
Irgendwann muss man ja auch mal chillen zwischendurch.
Ja, chillen. Ralf, hast du noch eine Botschaft an die Menschen?
Ich bin immer noch total geschockt von diesem Motiv.
Ich gucke jetzt gerade, in welchem Preisrange man da irgendwie einsteigt.
Du willst dieses Gerät haben, genau dieses Gerät willst du. Achso, du willst nicht...
Verkauf deinen ganzen Bosch-Karberschneig rum.
Ja, Bosch, das geht super back auf Ebay und so. Und dann bist du auch im Makita
Wunderland. Da ist es einfach schön.
Ich bin jetzt halt genau in dieser Falle von 3D-Drucker. Ich schlängel jetzt
seit zehn Jahren um 3D-Drucker rum und weiß halt nicht so richtig,
was würde ich da aber damit machen. Eigentlich ist es geil.
Und ich fürchte, diese Säge hier ist ziemlich genau diese Produkategorie.
Man will es eigentlich unbedingt haben, aber dann braucht man es nicht.
Das Aber es macht mich fertig Ja.
Also ich muss sagen, das ist schon eher ein Gerät, was ich jetzt häufiger verwendet habe.
Gut, jetzt hatte ich auch konkrete Anwendungen, klar, wenn man so draußen ist,
aber wie gesagt, Rohre kürzen, Holz zuschneiden Ich überlege.
Ob das für meine Kinder in der Tat was ist, weil die nämlich so im holzverarbeitenden
Bereich so und denen jetzt halt irgendwelche stumpfen Sägen in die Hand zu drücken,
ist halt auch immer nur so eine semi-gute Idee.
Ja, gerade um so Löcher reinzumachen.
Was würden die mit dem Teil für Spaß?
Und das Ding mit den 3D-Druckern, im Gegensatz zu dem ist, je länger du wartest,
hast du besser werden sie. Das Ding ist halt schon ausgereicht.
Auserzählt.
Das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich, genau diese Produktkategorie wird jetzt wahrscheinlich
keinen großen Sprung mehr machen.
Das glaube ich auch.
Oszillator.
Was kosten denn, also ich steige irgendwie nicht durch, was dann irgendwie hier
Ladegerät und Akku dann eigentlich immer noch kosten.
Das ist irgendwie ein sehr opakes System.
Ach, da macht dir Tim bestimmt im Nachgang gerne nochmal eine Message mit den
richtigen Links zusammen.
Aber im Wesentlichen kauft man sich einmal so ein, ich habe auch nur so das
Standard-Ladegerät für diese 18-Volt-Akkus und...
Also was ich jetzt gesehen habe, ist, dass es die aber nochmal in deutlich kleiner
gibt. Also das ist jetzt schon hier ein sehr großes, sehr wuchtiges.
Ja, aber...
Hast du das dann mal aber gegengehalten gegen ein kleineres?
Aber für Kinderhände wäre das wahrscheinlich ein bisschen...
Ich habe mich ja auf diese 18 Volt Akkutechnik, das ist ja meiner Meinung nach
derzeit so das Sinnvollste.
Da kriegst du irgendwie alles für, das hat ordentlich Power,
und Akkus, ich meine, gut, da kaufst du halt mal ein paar und dann nach ein
paar Jahren musste vielleicht mal einen austauschen, aber bisher habe ich das
noch nicht gehabt, das Problem. Schnellladegerät dazu, fertig.
Schauen wir mal.
Jetzt hast du schon wieder was. Es ist schon wieder ein Headset kaputt gemacht.
Gut, we're losing droids fast.
Ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt aufhören.
Abbrechen.
Die Sendung ist ungültig.
Und Schluss.
Los, dann machen wir jetzt hier Schluss, wenn die Technik schon... Packt die Messer ein.
Leute, ich hoffe, da war was für euch dabei. Kauft euch alles,
wovon wir geredet haben.
Vor allen Dingen Trickkiwi-Trigger. Genau, in den Kommentaren lesen wir dann alles nach.
Okay, das war's. Hucke, vielen Dank fürs Kommen und ihr habt uns bald wieder. Das war's. Bis bald.